the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
giving a little extra is always the
right call at the U.S women's and U.S
open championships in St Louis if you
phone it in then you're going home
empty-handed in such a tightly contested
feel Fabiano caruana is still riding
high but needs to keep pedaling to
outpaces pursuers for a second National
Title Irena crushes over the moon after
taking advantage up and leapfrogging of
blundering Jennifer you for sole lead in
the women's section the pieces are in
place for an epic finale and the best
place to see it will be right here day
13 of Out of This World Chess coming up
next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the
championship day here at the US Chess
Championship and U.S women's chess
Championships held at the St Louis chess
club it's been a fantastic event so far
filled with trails and spill but finally
it's time to Crown The Victors who's
going to come out on top let's go to the
studio and start the action with Yasser
and Anastasia from the home of Chess in
the United States welcome to the Saint
Louis chess club and the last 13th round
of the yes chess championships and the
U.S women's chess championships
hello everyone I'm Anastasia and I'm
here joined by Grandmaster Yasser
ceravan yaser what a pleasure to be here
with you maybe for the last time
absolutely Anastasia has really been
quite the adventure the disrespectful
championships are coming to a close that
has really been a lot of fun quality
reaction with you and Christian we had
such a round yesterday yes
with some decisive results but also with
some kind of intriguing situations
beheading of the king is what happened
hello everyone and Welcome to our show
this is indeed the championship round
the 13th and final round of these very
lengthy championships but boy they've
been a lot of fun who will be Champion
well Anastasia let's start with the
ladies and our leaders there
so after victory in the 12th round Arena
crash Club climbed to the solid with
eight and half points so he's on the top
and Jennifer you would Italia Cervantes
both of them followed the step of the
leader and hope maybe to try to win
still the championship and we also have
Ellis Lee and Ryan shared the first
place but they don't have chances for
the first place at the moment absolutely
and in the open section who can win and
in the open section Fabiano caruana is
still on the first place then we have
also Ray Robson with seven and half
points and linear Dominguez together
with a Wonderland shared the third
position right now and our format is
well pretty clear this is our our final
day we have our normal time controls as
we do for every round but what would
happen in case we see a tie Anastasia if
we have time in this case the two
players will play two rapid games with
10 min it's plus two seconds increment
time control if it's still tight we'll
have five megadon which is always great
to follow five minutes for white four
for black black winds in case the game
is a draw and not much of a schedule
left but let's take a look anyway I will
have the last round today it's October
19th and in case of playoffs we'll have
them on 20th of October as well as the
closing ceremony which will start at 6
PM more details about the closing
ceremony so if you would like to see two
we need players and the commentators
then you'll have your chance if you buy
the tickets for 25 in this case come at
6 PM we'll have cocktails first and then
closing ceremony and of course after
party with DJ in case if you are not in
San Luis you have chance to check the
live stream on YouTube channel promise
is to be a wonderful closing ceremony
and Christian good to see you my friend
we here we are the 13th and final day
and tell us what these players are going
to have to do to become champion
great to see you guys and there's a
Fabiano caruana and tatev abrahamian
joining the action finally Fabiano wants
to close the show today there's Journey
for you with her good friend
they've been having quite a good event
as well but I have to say guys I've had
a lot of fun calling the action here at
the U.S Women's Championship as well as
the U.S open Chess Championship it's
been a lot of fun but finally it's that
day the day that we're going to Crown
Victors and let's take a look at where
our leaders are standing we're going to
start with the ladies section well it's
been Irina Crush Jennifer you and right
now Talia Cervantes who has been having
an incredible streak she's a won five
games in the last five rounds just an
incredible performance by Italia
Cervantes right now tied for second
position with Jennifer you who has been
leading so much of at this event but the
eight-time national champion Irina Crush
right now in the lead and by the way
number two and three well tied for
second position are playing today for uh
the second or the first place that is
the big match between Talia Cervantes
versus Jennifer you two wins for Tanya
two losses for her and two draws this
one is a very close matchup and let's
take a look at one for the history books
well that's indeed the matchup between
our leader Irina crushed the eight time
National Champion versus one of her
Rivals who are throughout the history
that is international Master Anna
zatonski they've played so many times in
different time controls rapid and Blitz
and classical chess as well 11 wins for
arena 9 losses and nine draws this one
is going to be a huge matchup today and
let's take a look at where we stand in
the open section of course we have
Fabiano caruana still leading the event
he's been leading the event since the
first round right now Ray Robson seven
and a half points only half a point
behind Fabiano caruana he's been half a
point behind Fabiano caruana for the
past five rounds and Lanier Dominguez as
well as Wonder Liang have a mathematical
chance to actually catch up with Fabiano
in case Fabiano loses today against
Levon aronian but of course we have two
incredible matchups that we are going to
be focused on and the first one is the
one between Ray Robson versus Jeffrey
Sean and he came to the studio yesterday
and gave us an interview and he said
this is a must win situation for him
three wins two losses and five draws
between these two players just an
incredible mouth-watering matchup but
another mouth-watering matchup is the
big clash between two friends and Rivals
as well that is Fabiano caruana versus
honoronian and I have to say Fabiano
having the white pieces in the last
round it's a big plus for him and his
chances for the championship and as we
can see Levon has arrived at the board
they're not really in chatty terms right
now of course there's too much tension
in this championship and uh we will see
an incredible battle between these two
players well those are indeed fantastic
clashes to be sure at Anastasia tell the
viewers what all the pairings are going
to be like and let's start with the
ladies let's start with the latest once
again let's check on the top we see
Thalia Cervantes with Jennifer you both
of them share now second place it's very
important match for them and then it
will go all the way to the bottom you
can see Arena crash with Sanders once
again another very important game so we
also will follow the game between
ellisley and Megan Lee because still
they're fighting for top places in this
event as well as also the game between
you Roy and Jan and a big impact of
Jonathan and in the open what are all
the key matchups in that and for those
parents actually all of them are quite
important so Fabiano Karana plays
against Leon and we can see immediately
Lanier Dominguez game against Sam
Shanklin that's a crucial yes for the
standings Ray Robson plays against
Jeffrey Zhong and also we can see Hans
Neiman who will face today a Wonderland
and Amanda also has chances to catch the
leaders in case of if Fabi will not
manage to win
and the hottest player participant in
any of the two competitions Talia
Cervantes five wins in a row good for
her can she make it six imagine
finishing the tournament on a six win
streak and actually winning that's
pretty memorable
wow and uh they've been fighting really
really hard Anastasia what is the price
fund for the ladies really great first
month 160 500 40 000 for the first place
I remember times it was tenant can look
at it 40. in the first place and then
second place Thirty and third twenty so
every Point counts in this situation all
the way until 14th Place was three
thousand and in the open section what
are those participants fighting for 262
000 price funds and the winner will get
sixty thousand and then forty five
thirty five twenty five all these
numbers sound really good uh the 14th
finisher 5500 when I won U.S
championships it was six thousand
[Laughter]
this one thank you St Louis and thank
you to St Louis chess club the fries
funds are indeed very very handsome as
we see there the playing Hall and the
few cheers Empty Chairs means the
players are still going through the
security check wanding
exactly and yes it is
Championship Round Guys yes do you feel
the last round the tension will be for
E5 yeah okay are we going to see a
Berlin mom or
a joker piano or scotch or Scotch Gambit
no we're going to find out B5 okay now I
mean Lavon has always had a7a6 in his
repertoire everything ever since he
started playing chess it's just that the
Berlin guys we go to castles oh no very
quickly not D2 D3 d2d3 today has kind of
been the go-to move when you really want
a full body game end game final rookie
one no no no no no
bad news is everybody in Knight D6
I'm not sure about bad news because
we've seen Fabiano actually put a lot of
pressure in this same line against
Wesley saw earlier in the tournament
right it is a dryish line of course and
if black knows what he's doing probably
will equalize out of the opening just I
mean ask Fabiano what is your strategy
yeah right now you probably want you
just want to make it anyways I think so
yes like a normal draw and then you just
wait for the other to see if Ray Robson
can you catch me exactly actually it's
only one okay
the only player in that case and I do
believe that Jeffrey has not lost a
single game in this story exactly is on
plus one uh winning one game not losing
a single one and drawing the rest so
it's a very difficult player to be quite
a number of players actually undefeated
uh in this competition including uh
Jeffrey who you mentioned but also
Lanier Millennial yes exactly yes and
let's just remind our viewers along with
a very very handsome price fund
Anastasia you also have a situation
where this is a qualifying event to the
World Cup that's the 128 player knockout
so the top five finishers of the open
section will go to this knockout which
is important it's a very important
moment because part of the candidates
yeah the whole cycle and for the ladies
we have two places participants who will
qualify so for Jennifer you and Talia
yes
it's also very important uh
situation yes like they're also fighting
well for those Sports and let's remember
the two winners of the candidates
tournament the finalists will go to the
candidates tournament so it's really
important event where you have chance
even to qualify in the end for the world
championship match exactly I wanted to
mention it seems like uh Ray hasn't
arrived oh really yeah okay we're
waiting for Ray remember Luan said
yesterday I mean there are some special
rules for the last round he said it
during his interview so what do you
think he meant by special rules he also
there is Jeffrey waiting for Ray and
Jeffrey yeah luckily for him he plays
the Black pieces and he doesn't have to
be on time undefeated Jeffrey Sean right
now in this tournament waiting for his
opponent such an important crucial round
for both of these players and this is a
career defining moment for Ray Robson if
he manages to win this one wow and win
the USGS championships but so many
dreams come true for these young men for
sure
but it it's uh
uh there there we see that raised coming
through
yeah but it's not an easy path for a
rape as it turns out Jeffrey is
undefeated not lost a single game in the
12 that he's competed in so I was
expecting of course a bit more from him
but he was really really solid right
exactly
so just uh the rain finally made it
through the security right and he goes
to his game exactly that is a five
minute
well um time Advantage for Ray for
Jeffrey shock and when you're playing
against Rey who's notorious for his time
travel uh I kind of
feel that Rey should not be the one
giving up five minutes at the start he
shouldn't be giving up any time
whatsoever as he adjusts all of his
pieces let's see does he have his
Knights to decide
the G1 Knight is facing uh the king but
the B1 Knight it's also to the side a
little bit
it's looking straight ahead no no yes
45 degrees what I prefer right
it's a good question we've got Jeffrey's
nights though I mean those are
straightforward looking nights yes Dead
Ahead okay very good and let's just uh
take a look at some of the other games
just to see
what a rivalry uh this has been we saw
the head-to-head as Christian uh told it
and I think it's been two decades
exactly do you remember this fantastic
video I've watched it so many times when
they played this
game yes and the pieces were flying oh
yes Unforgettable yeah just one of the
one of the Great Moments uh in women's
championships history
it's too great that there are also
teammates and after all I mean all these
troubles they had in the past they are
good friends and they are really playing
so many years for the team the U.S team
exactly and so fighting when they play
against each other and teammates when
it's about the team championships an
arena crash everybody is chasing history
she is the eight-time U.S women's
champion should she win her ninth title
she will tie the great gestala dresser
who is the most decorated Women's
Championship chess player in U.S chess
history who had nine titles so Arena
chasing history today Queen's Gambit
declined exchange variation let's keep
an eye on that one by the way big game
going on between the Lanier Dominguez
and Sam Shanklin those are two Olympians
playing against one another and Sam
said let's play an open
Sicilian well a night or in fact against
Lanier one of the most well prepared
players so in terms of a theoretical
duel you can ask for a better setup for
this 13th and Final Round And then your
repeated once with Bishop to eat wait
are they repeating again what let's see
okay he's played Bishop E3 inviting the
English attack Knight to G4 I I don't
think we're going to see a repetition I
don't think we're going to see Bishop C1
Knight F6 F3
yes well they've done it twice here it
goes
so space keys look
okay wait so right now with Knight is
that the third time if you place Knight
F6
I think so really so he can just uh yeah
he's playing yeah that's he's played
Knight F6 that was the third time I
cannot believe it really I think so
if he plays Knight F6 he can claim the
draw right now Sam Shanklin okay so with
Knight F6
it will be an eight minute game yes
which will break Lanier's record of a 10
minute
10 minutes maybe he won the 10 minute
rate for 10 minutes Sam's gonna say come
on what is what is it oh my gosh what is
the anguishing emotions right come on
it's a really crazy moment like in a way
you you understand that you're you have
black pieces and joy is a good result
but you probably wanted to have a game
and now your opponent
not to expect this I have to say here's
the disappointed one of the linear will
be trying for more yes maybe it's also
about the sports what you were doing
that's exactly what I'm thinking yes
Lanier has plus two yes a draw clinches
his qualification into and no draw it
doesn't he doesn't claim well so now
I cannot do it by myself if you want to
do it okay you can do it but I'm not
doing it myself right I don't kill my
chances to be but Lanier has already
signed the score sheets
there we go there
Sam seems a little disgusted a bit
disgusting but again I uh I'm gonna say
this that Lanier with the draw yes this
is a spot whereas Sam needed uh a fight
yes he needed to win probably the game
in order to try to be let's say on this
top five right precisely so I mean it's
just a crazy situation actually
psychological also situation right so I
mean Sam could maybe try to do something
else but uh yeah everything you can read
it no no no no no but you're not
supposed to try with black yes
sami's been having a pretty solid event
himself exactly I think he's on plus one
have a point behind linear and that's a
respectable result
respectful results
exactly exactly so
um
what to say to that one Hans Neiman
versus a Wonder Liang I kind of just
thought that this was an interesting
start to the game uh by Hans after E4 E6
we have this Queenie too I know this
lens guys we're going to see a drawing
Fabiano's game as well that one as well
wow well there's oh my God
it's over the pieces are gone they went
from the opening to the end game in uh
well record time yeah
well I mean look this makes sense right
uh if you are Fabiano caruana this makes
sense you're not going to take any
unnecessary risks right you just make it
this guarantees Fabiano a playoff
s
yes
that's only yes yes he's the only one
who can still catch him if he wins only
Ray can force Supply by the way that's a
symmetrical position after 30 moves in
the game between
and did I just see the move King G1
that's kind of yeah that's pretty
hilarious yes maybe G1 I mean like a
taken advantage
I mean how to professionally uh make a
repetition as soon as possible oh there
we go what can you do one again yeah
let's analyze this position exactly and
why not King G3 King G3 you know you
might go running up the board and when
well that clarifies things very very
much so it's all on Ray robson's
Shoulders
by the way he's like yes I want the bill
right yeah that's what I was about to
say the Dutch have a fantastic word uh
for the bill in in Holland so after the
dinner and you want to pay you go the
Reckoning
and well he ordered the Reckoning and
the reckonings of draw a Christian no
absolutely and uh we we sort of expected
this of course now the pressure is on
our way will he be able to take matters
in his own hand and actually force a
playoffs and all attention also
Anastasia when we're starting you said
that Lavon came in and you reminded me
yes that Lavon said the last round has
its own rules yes exactly kind of seeing
it it's sort of like all the work of the
12 previous rounds allows Fabi the
luxury of making a draw that's why I'm
saying I've got the white but I'm making
it wrong I think so but at the same time
like
um
I mean he said tomorrow we'll just try
to play normal game and see what happens
right so like you have black pieces
against the leader of the tunnel who has
good event you are not in the great
shape you kind of accepted its few days
ago but like okay let's just finish this
tournament and let's say wait for the
next one right five wins in a row that's
what I'm talking about and who am I
talking about Talia Cervantes versus
Jennifer you Jennifer you coming off a
shock loss in round 12. I mean she was
up against Arena crash
she had a really bad position suddenly
she had a great position made an
incredible blind spot and uh lost it
literally in one move Bishop before this
most you'll remember it's a long time
and I think Yasser will remember it too
well that hurts so a lot of Fame on so
many levels yes
uh let's jump into the game again tell
ya is started the event with five draws
it's incredible and has gone on a on a
tear of five wins so rookie one uh very
very common
um Queen's Indian uh
defense and the move rookie one brought
about A7 A5 interesting move now I
always liked polygievsky's sacrifice uh
with this with this Pawn including the
moves rookie one and A5 well that will
be interesting she didn't play this uh
Talia just went for the more sedate
approach with Bishop G5 her idea is that
in case the bishop is put to the
question takes takes takes well thanks
to the Rook sitting on E1 she supports
upon going to E4 and Christian will jump
over to you we have guest in studio Sam
we were watching you on camera as this
game was unfolding and you seemed
distressed uh yeah well that was the
reason well so first of all they didn't
even ask me to come for an interview I
came because I requested I just wanted
to say I'm I'm sorry for how this ended
uh I've been one of the most vocal
critics of people making this queen E4
Queen D4 draw in the Berlin I wrote in
my trustable course with anyone who does
this more than once with white you
shouldn't be invited to tournaments like
and so
uh it just feels like I just felt like I
show the world an apology I know I'm
playing Black and there's not much I can
do but I remember I really wanted to win
this game I mean I played the night or F
and
um I was ready to take a lot of risks
but I remember preparing like it just I
had never once ever seen Dominguez Force
so draw with white like literally zero
times it's just such a principled
aggressive strong player who really
tries to fight for an edge I just hadn't
occurred to me at all and I just found
myself wishing I had found some way to
just like play E5 and go but I just
hadn't checked it in the slightest and
having tried to win with black several
times this tournaments when it was
probably inappropriate I like for
example against Jeffrey when I could
have just shredded all the pieces and I
played Bishop D5 and gave myself an
isolated Pawn instead I just sort of
decided to make the adult decision but
it was not one that I'm proud of or not
one that I think that we should use as
an example for chess players in the
future and I assume you're talking about
your game against Levon aronian where
you had white people that one was a
little different and that I just got
caught in preparation and some extremely
obscure line uh that just I mean that
can happen and then that's that's that
but that's that's very different than a
draw happening that's probably been
played a thousand times in the past uh
and when that happens I don't really
think you can blame the black player but
still I don't like how it went down Sam
uh you finished on plus one how would
you assess your performance do you feel
you could have done differently it was
mediocre
um not terrible like I've probably lost
a little bit of writing despite having
an extra white I mean I remember I've
had an extra black and something like 10
of my last 10 events and so when I got
an extra light at this tournament I just
felt like a kid at Christmas and I was
really looking forward to trying to do
something and I just I mean there's
basically I finished on plus one and
there's three games where I could have
gotten another half point I didn't have
to lose to Wesley uh I could have beaten
me a minute I could have beaten saffian
and so you could sort of say that if I
was on absolute Tip-Top form and I
cashed in all three of those games I
would tie for first but even if you're
on like good form and not amazing form
yeah I still probably wouldn't have time
for first I might have only gotten two
extra half points out of that and
finished on like plus three so it was
not the end of the world but it was a
tough tournament Sam absolutely no shame
in making a draw with the black pieces
against one of the best players in the
world thank you for your games and we'll
see you in your next event which is
I have literally no idea I have nothing
planned at all
um I wouldn't mind at least a little bit
of a break but you know come December
and January I'd love to get into playing
classical chess again I just don't know
of any events nothing a I don't know of
any I've been invited to but B I don't
know of any at all so you know once
tournaments come you know come at me I'd
love to play but it's uh and I hope I
can play more feisty than I did today
Sam thank you very much Sam a quick
question to you uh was your
determination to play for a win today
motivated by the fact that uh World Cup
uh playoff spots were are up for grabs
yeah I mean certainly in part that was
that was part of it yes uh just also
like I mean I felt like I wanted to get
more points on the scoreboard I mean you
shouldn't lose objectivity based on how
your previous games have gone but also
just with Dominguez like I'm not
I'm not that confident in my ability to
just you know play E5 against him and
just forcefully draw like he's always
able to put pressure and I wanted I just
against him in particular I think the
best strategy is to try to play a
fighting game regardless of whether
you're trying to play for a win with
black on command or not but yeah that
was part of it I just was very very
surprised by Bishop C1 I've literally
never ever seen him make a quick draw
with white once and to that effect you
know I would say look everyone's allowed
one in discretion before you start
condemning them so I'm not gonna give
him a hard time like he if he's
literally never done it once before you
know look everyone gets to do it once
but it was just disappointing to see all
right once again thank you uh very much
uh Sam Shanklin and well our standings
after those two very quick results uh
Anastasia exactly made a draw already
with lemon Arwen and we can see he
climbed on eight uh during the first
place with eight and a half points
exactly and linear Dominguez also made
the draw with some shenkun so he has
seven and a half points no chances to
catch farby exactly only Ray Robson
who's still at play uh with the victory
could potentially uh force a playoff and
there he is uh playing uh with Jeffrey
Zhang at the moment I just have uh in
front of me the game uh that Arena crush
is playing against Anna zatonski Anna
zatonski her whole career really has
played the Queen's Gambit declined and I
want to say that in this tournament in
particular Anna has not been successful
either with the white or black pieces
it's just not been clicking for her uh
we're we're still in the the throes of
theory black castles puts the Rook on E8
plays for the move Knight E4 I myself is
black in this position has played on
numerous occasions move Knight H5 the
idea is that after takes takes white
doesn't anymore have the luxury of
trying to Castle long white has to
Castle short because after the move
Queen C2 which might look just fine well
why did I put my knight on H5 well I
want to harass the pawn on G2 as well as
the bishop on D3 so we'll see what
happens in this game but back to you
Christian as we have another guest in
studio Fabio strategic decision to ice
the game early on with the white pieces
how did you come to that conclusion
oh well normally I would have
um liked to play at least a little bit
of course the draw is is a good result
in the last round considering the
tournament situation but
um I don't know I'll try to say this
delicately I mean it's a big day for
Levon and I didn't think it would be I
thought it would be wrong for me to to
play this game uh that was also part of
the reason for this so I I just I just
thought okay draw uh make sense from
every point of view absolutely and well
a short day for you let's talk about
this game because you're probably
interested in this one as well how do
you assess uh Ray's opening
no I think this is a
in general I'm happy with this how how
the opening is turning out for Jeffrey
okay of course why does it better I'm
sure he'll try to press this for a very
long time but it's a very solid position
and Jeffrey
uh I mean he has experience in these
lines he's been he even played this with
the similar line with with white against
Wesley earlier in the tournament
very difficult for white to get any sort
of edge here I mean you have like the
tiniest
tiniest development Advantage with white
I guess I mean the bishop on D7 is a bit
awkward but uh usually I played this
with blocking and Sonic a few years ago
so more or less same position
um it's a very very tiny extra white and
very solid for black was your decision
also based on the fact that Ray was
facing a player that hasn't lost a
single game in this tournament
no again my decision was not really
based mostly on the tournament situation
uh it just conveniently worked out that
the tournament situation is kind of a
draw was also good for me
um but uh
but yeah it wouldn't have changed
anything for me no matter who Ray was
playing that makes a lot of sense guys
any questions for our leader absolutely
Fabby well first of all congratulations
on a very fine tournament a very fine
performance but you yourself have said
it Fabi the disrespectful U.S
championships coming to a close uh give
us your thoughts as a player about these
uh disrespectful U.S championships okay
but what can you say I mean this uh it
culminated yesterday didn't it with the
beheading I I'm I've never seen anything
like this it's like uh I think maybe the
tournament is quite long also and uh
people are starting to go a bit nuts
I mean I I just couldn't wrap my head
around this moment
um
when Sam
what's your read on the whole situation
what do you think actually happened
there well we kind of we're told what
happened right that the king's has his
side no but this was also corroborated
by Arbiters
that these Kings have loose tops the
crowns are loose I didn't notice but
apparently that's a thing and the only
thing is like why at that specific
moment did Sam decide to take the king
off the board and it wasn't his move
yeah it was hans's move he he
decapitated it and then he threw it I
called the Lord
I've never seen this before actually I
want I have a question do you remember
when your king was disrespected as well
do you remember any moment when your
king was actually in trouble I would put
it this way thrown out of the board not
on not in chest in the chest sense
more or less just sense yes do you
remember this picture a woody woody
resigning on your behalf on move one
yeah well okay this was a long time ago
I'm not very long long time ago I'm not
very superstitious but a lot of chess
players are and they they might have
gotten like I didn't care so much but a
lot of chess players might have been
really pissed off
if someone resigned on there be happy
for the game yes but look at also Magnus
face in the pictures
yeah but the thing is Woody is such a
eccentric individual right I mean I I
only met him briefly but he's he's so
interesting
and so unusual that uh didn't surprise
me that something like this happened
um but he is also a genius I mean uh
like as an actor it's amazing
exactly yes no just I remember this
funny moment and like I tried to
remember something connected to the king
and suddenly this moment came to my mind
in London 2018 match yeah but it still
wasn't decapitated yeah I agree yes he
had it I I just know why the why the
crosses are kind of little peg-shaped
because it very often happens that they
do snap
and so then the idea is it's kind of
easy to replace them
but
I can do this any other any other things
about this disrespectful
um
yeah so after yesterday right every
individual King was glued on
individual Crown was glued onto the king
very carefully
so this doesn't happen again yes to make
sure for the last round I guess uh and
this is what we're discussing
yesterday's 12th game Hans was thinking
about what his move was and then Sam
just picked up his King and then he
headed
the black king announces like hey man
give me back my king
and life also looks uh you can ask this
line is amazing it also looks a bit
guilty like he was caught doing
something very naughty
Sam looked very confused in that hole
time and time again and still still pick
up things were you there at that moment
by the way no no you'd already left yeah
yes okay
you can enjoy it I mean the game was
interesting from my point of view
because Sam was plus two and okay he was
never
and close to winning that game but if he
had won the time he would have gone to
plus three so right so I was kind of uh
curious about that game from a purely
tournament standpoint right exactly yeah
and for the result of Ray Robson games
yeah thank you very much uh uh Abby and
sorry sorry last question have you ever
played a playoff with uh Ray did you
ever get into a tiger
assorted Blitz Games right but never
play and some rapid games some online
shots but never play off are you going
to get prepared right now what are you
going to do no okay I mean I'm going to
follow the end of the the tournament and
see if I'll need to prepare and if so
then then I will of course but I'm not
gonna
prepare for something which may or may
not happen okay
okay thank you very much Fabio thank you
for the interview still uh what what a
tournament what what very very strange
happenings or have taken place over
these last few weeks I I don't know
Anastasia it's just it's it's been
bizarre I don't want to repeat that but
it seems like people are under big
pressure right now and everybody knows
how it feels like if you play really
long you want it but actually yes you
were telling me the other day that some
events could last month oh yeah yes and
like for months and I mean what people
the craziest thing people did let's say
during this event I remember I would
hasten uh to gas but yes exactly I mean
we had these interzoneal tournaments 22
players and we played three three games
per week wow three games
yes
why because we had a Germans so they
were special days for adjournments but
then if you played you adjourned you
played you adjourned you played your
adjourn the organizers always wanted
make sure that you also had free days so
we had a German games we had free days
we had rounds then we had uh what it
were these these were like organizer
days because they needed to repair the
tournament hall or do anything so these
events lasted a month
well and I still remember my absolute
absolute favorite was the world
championship match 1984 between Gary
Kasparov and Anatoly karpov that went
six months my friend Jonathan Tisdale
was the Reuters reporter he was there
for six months in Moscow
and he said that he lost his lease on
his apartment he lost his girlfriend and
he spoke Russian
s
your life absolutely we are in fact with
a linear linear we've heard the Sam's
account what is your account about what
transpired in today's game uh well I I
mean I was already so tired a few rounds
ago that I was having a hard time uh
getting out of bed and preparing at all
in the morning so uh you know I thought
I would I would play solely today I had
something in mind I thought he would
play neither and I had something in mind
against the E5 against the English
attack which is the line that he usually
plays I mean we played that line in fact
a couple of times in our games
uh but this line with 94 I wasn't
expecting it's it's kind of sharp I
didn't repeat it and I didn't remember
at all the the details I played it
against firusha in the singfield cup
it's quite sharp and um so I didn't
especially prepare for that so I thought
that I would in in that case I can I can
just repeat moves because uh anyway uh
it's uh it's it's uh I was going to play
solid so I thought that he would go E5
and and and then we would we would have
a game but yeah anyway it's uh it's
normal result we were discussing here in
the studio how important the energy
levels are in the last few rounds
especially in a 13 round event what is
your routine usually looking like yeah
it's kind of tough of course as I was
saying it's uh the last few rounds were
were difficult also I had this uh
three games over 90 moves I had one game
with 130 moves and another one with over
100 moves so it was quite uh quite tough
and uh yeah I mean you try to save
energy to sleep well but uh uh 13 Rounds
it's it's quite a lot it's uh it's been
a long time that I didn't play such a
tournament so yeah it was it wasn't easy
but yeah it's this is the good part
where where all the software and it's
it's over and you get to relax a bit
then here congratulations guys any
questions yeah quick question for you
Lanier first of all congratulations on
your result uh undefeated uh you're
qualified for the World Cup all of those
good things 130 131 move game against
Christopher you is that your longest
game in your chess career oh
I'm not sure I had some some long games
uh
some time ago but I think yeah 130 has
to be I mean if not if not the first uh
it's it's it's a it's second or
something but yeah I think I'm pretty
sure it's it's my longest game yeah
right because it's too much I mean 90
already feels like you play two games
instead of one but uh
yeah but in fact I know for sure because
I never got to feel like more than two
score sheets right so yeah when I when I
saw the third score she's like no this
is this has never happened before so
that was the giveaway
what are your plans linear for them
after this event what are you going to
do where we will see you next time well
I'm going to to take a break that's for
sure now uh which I was very much
looking forward because it's been a
really busy year for me with the grand
chest tour and the Grand Prix so I have
been playing a lot which also I think
took its toll now in this tournament uh
especially uh the the second half
so I'm planning to take a long break and
probably I'll play the the world rapid
and Blitz event
um which is going to be I think in the
end of December as usual so I'll
probably play that but other than that
I'll maybe play something online or
something but just mainly
um mainly resting speaking of rapid and
Blitz we've seen you make your moves
with one second especially in that game
against Sam Seville and what were you
trying to do at that point I don't know
I mean I just I didn't realize I when I
saw that I played with one second I got
scared and then I you scared us as well
yeah no I think that the same that same
evening when I got home I was still
still having a bit of nightmares with
this one second I said my God if I lose
some time this game it just would be
over and it's the end of the tournament
so yeah I don't know I mean I guess you
get a position where you know you you're
never I mean you're pressing and you
will never lose but of course there's a
Time Factor yeah you can lose so I guess
I got too too confident somehow but uh
but yeah that was that was a risky
situation there
linear a lot of adrenaline in those
moments exactly yeah once again uh
congratulations on a very successful
tournament we wish you all the best in
your career
thank you oh absolutely
uh yeah that one yes
you do let's jump to that game of Ray
Robson because that's what it's all
about Ray with the white pieces against
Jeffrey Zhang Jeffrey again coming into
the
into today's round as is Ray undefeated
uh with the Blackness
and it was hopes to win this tournament
exactly still Knight a C6 and I was a
bit surprised I I'm actually I don't
like this move that Ray Point Knight D4
to F3 that's theoretical and I
understand all of that I've played this
position as white myself it's really
about
controlling uh the square E5 in this
particular variation of the Queen's
Gambit Exchange
Trade trade and you want the Knight to
come to E5 this move by Rey which has
again been played before I like
Jeffrey's response very much just play
the move B7 B5 again it's about the
control of the E5 Square Knight C4 95
was on White's agenda black says I'm not
going to let you go with Knight C4
that's it what are you going to do
everybody usually plays something like I
don't know A4 and or A3 here and seeks
you know these little little moves on
the queen side well Ray play Rook C1
that's a a new move according to my
database my database is not as big as
everybody else's so maybe it's been
played before but it sure looks uh
pretty even Steven Jeffrey thinks so too
he didn't spend so much time on the Move
Rook C8 Christian please jump right on
it and actually we probably had one of
the experts in this line Lanier
Dominguez
but I just saw this game between uh
please come back and and Dominguez in
fact in March of this year so so very
fresh very very fresh ideas and that was
played with Queen to B1 Queen to B1 yes
Queen to B1 and I think the response was
H6 Rook to D1 and now Queen to B6 Knight
to E4 Knight to D5 and now Knight to G3
this was kymer's idea to put the queen
on B1 use that lever to get the Knight
to the other side of the board and try
to give the knights some offensive tasks
right after the move Knight to H5 and
this is exactly what happened in that
game Rook da Knight H5 Bishop to f8
kymar in fact won uh that game but
according to the engine the position is
still very much in the balance so quite
an interesting situation in this one
there's we have a middle game on our
hands not a lot of pieces have been
exchanged we know that Fabiano caruana
said that this position is very very
close to equality and uh White will have
to find something special to break
through Black's defense in the
symmetrical uh structure position very
intriguing game very intriguing option
chosen by Ray Robson as well was
Anastasia as was that game that Vincent
place from the Grand Prix I I'm not 100
sure
this year I think it was this event
yesterday but it must be yes it must be
yeah
you know they were playing in the same
group this I remember
for the candidates tournament two places
would go for the candidates tournament
and there was a fight also between a
linear and the Nakamura at that time and
Wesley so I remember was he went in
Berlin on March I was thinking it was
around four that day
my memory is uh I know your tricks I
know your tricks you've done this to
Alejandro I know in Alejandro
this is really funny you know sometimes
but there are players who can say 1953
always never trust like a wise box such
as yesterday no chance no chance guys uh
you guys are catching on to all my
tricks I'm gonna have to come up with
some new ones
8283 by Ray Robson no Queen B1 no
Vincent uh ideas just uh very very slow
and steady uh let's go uh to the ladies
section just a second for the game
between because we never really got to
it that much was the game of Talia and
Jennifer after the move Rook E1
we did not see Jennifer play the move H6
because this is where white gets well
let's say a preponderance of the central
squares instead I know Natalia likes
this type of positions right yeah I
remember your showed some lines where
she wants to advance all her pawns
especially for pawns attack she likes
that very much okay uh Knight E4 and
that's not considered well that I want
to say that falls in line with whatever
it is that White's trying to achieve
after 94 Bishop takes E7 Queen e takes
E7 usually there's a knight on C3
so Queen C2 is played and uh F5 or
Knight takes E3 and Bishop E4 here there
is a difference and the difference is
this move 92. okay so you're basically
saying I've got a pin along this
diagonal it helps black that a7a5 is is
in the in the situation Knight takes D2
Bishop takes B7 The Rook would be
trapped on A8 with the if not for the
move a7a5 after Rook A7 white is
basically trying to say okay uh we'll
get a situation where it's Bishop versus
knight and again I'll have more space in
the center okay none of this happened
because Jennifer played a movie again
you're not really supposed to play like
this after F5 Knight takes E4 F takes E4
the position after Knight C3 is
considered favorable for white
simply because this Pawn on e4 is more
vulnerable than the pawn on F2 it's
really that simple black has opened up
the half half open f file but the pawn
on e4 is a little bit harder to attack
so for example yes of course this is the
move which you would like to play to
support the bone exactly uh what else
are you going to do I'm going to go F3
idea yes okay
you're probably going to have to take I
don't want to take with the bond or with
the with the problem because in this
case you create another pin and then the
idea is that I I have ideas of Queen
take C4 Queen takes E6 Bishop H3 in some
cases as well as D5 I'm going to win
back the pawn and usually when I do win
back the pawn the the blacks Queen side
pieces yes are sitting at home
this is not good it's not it's it's
supposed to be better for white I
remember this from well quite uh many
many
um years ago I don't know if the engines
have revived the position or shown that
it's not that bad but my first take is
that Talia after Knight C3 will get an
advantage let's just check in with Arena
and once again before we do that the
standings
there's a Arena crust is on the first
position and Jennifer you plays against
Thalia and in case if one of them will
win this game they actually can be can
even replace we read Arena if you lose
this against so everything is still
possible Arena can still lose her title
even though she's leading right uh Saleh
has chances to win the championship
Jennifer has chances to win the
championship exactly and of course
Serena in case of draw will enjoy the mo
the fact that you in the worst case
scenario will play the playoffs she's in
the situation like that but she will be
in the same situation yeah like a drug
clinches her minimum of a playoff yes
whereas a win clinches her the the title
No playoffs nothing nothing but this is
one thing that she said yesterday in her
interview and it lingers uh on my mind
because she said that if you want to win
this event you have to take matters in
your own hands clear the obstacles and
she did that yesterday and I think she's
trying to do the that as well today in
this game against Anna zutansky I don't
think she's looking for a draw right now
but I think she's looking for a complex
battle put some pressure on Anna and it
has been struggling with especially her
time management and uh this tournament
she has had quite some success with the
white pieces not so much with the black
pieces she's been feeling the pressure
so I think Irena Crush right now he's
trying to finish the tournament right
here and right now wow okay maybe maybe
it's also possible but just I want to
tell you that in case if she makes straw
she will be in top two and then she will
that's a guarantee it's important also
perhaps for the qualification of the
world maybe even if she may even if she
loses and the other player wins she will
be on the second position in any case
right so
except if she loses and girls make a
draw right then they have time for the
first place three of them right they
play the players and you can be still
certainly that's right
there is to be out of World Cup yes
exactly
I'm a little bit surprised by what I'm
seeing after Knight F3 there was no
Knight H5 by Anna note usually speaking
in these types of Queen's Gambit
declined carlsbad's structures black is
looking for trades whether it be the
move Knight H5 or 94. uh Anna played the
move Knight to f8
normally Everybody Plays Queen C2 here
after Knight f8 but the move Knight E5
helps black find those trades that she's
looking for she played the move at night
on F6 to D7 which is a kind of a
confounding move because it looks
strange to to to retreat with the Knight
but the thanks to the fact that this
bishop is under attack the Knight is
under attack black guarantees herself
that there will be trade of pieces and
these trades really do help we see the
move Knight coming back to uh
for the moment yeah and we would expect
something like night E6 or Knight F6
probably Knight F6 actually now that I
think about it because again from
Black's point of view she's looking for
trades and Bishop G4 would certainly be
on her agenda I found the draw 95 97.
very professional
you're learning from the desk
Lanier Dominguez yes yes yes I know how
to dance if you want to make a drawer
exactly
seriously a lady who's really caught my
eye throughout this whole tournament
Alice Lee and what she did against Arena
crash playing you know for the win at
all costs that was really inspiring
let's see how she's doing against Megan
Lee who could have had the tournament of
her life and was having the tournament
of her life for quite a number of rounds
it looks like we've got a Dutch uh
Stonewall uh on our board wow G5 Megan
uh she's
going all out on all in on the attack uh
G5 uh basically uh seeking to chase this
Knight away from uh King side defense I
think she lost three games in a row
maybe more maybe four or something like
that it's it's really tough when you
have such a great event you think you
will be really finishing on the really
great note yes and then you start losing
and you never stop you know yeah you you
go in the spin cycle no I I once in my
career lost uh you know one game I
shouldn't have I was like really angry
the next game I was so angry I I will
beat whoever I play and I overstab I
overpressed lost and then I said okay
that that's too much I lost two games in
a row I'll make a draw on the third and
was comprehensively outplayed I lost
three games in a row and I thought the
world had ended you know like the rules
of physics had changed and nobody told
me
and nothing can make your mood better
right I mean like nothing exists in this
world like the sun is not shining the
weather is bad you don't care about food
at this moment it's food is tasteless it
is very very straight four four losses
never happened in my career three was
painful enough uh really really tough
happened in my other though so I can
imagine
yeah no it's quite painful but Megan is
putting a challenge to her young
opponent Alice and saying okay how do
you we all know you can attack Alice how
do you like it when you're being
attacked what what are your defensive
skills looking like we'll keep an eye on
this one and over to you Christian what
caught your eye and we've been talking
about losses and how difficult
psychologically they are and even linear
he came here in the studio and he was
like I'm not sleeping well right with so
much pressure imagine if you have some
losses in your background I mean Hans
talked about it as well he said I
couldn't sleep due to the fact that I
was losing games so I tried to get some
better sleep by winning games and this
is exactly what he did now let's take a
look he won three in a row guys and
right now he's facing a Wonder let's see
what happened in this one Queen to it to
a very interesting approach against the
French obviously not the main lines with
D4 and uh what not but Queen to E2 C5
and now we're actually transitioning
into some sort of a sicilian right
Sicilian with the move Queen to E2 which
is considered to be quite good for a
black G3 hinting at the fact that I'm
going to fiance to the bishop on the
long diagonal so black responds with
this move E5 closing up this potential
uh diagonal just an example by the way
yes if 60 played then E6 and E5 even
even as such yes Queen to E2 is not a
very dangerous line so you can lose some
tempies and still be fine as black it's
not the Knight of Knight to C2 D5 D3
h6a3d is a position currently that we
have I want to point out the fact that
Hans only has one hour and one minute
against one hour and 20 minutes so
definitely a wonder is uh feeling good
about his position but guys in case
you've missed it yesterday we've had a
lot of fun here in this video
graphic artists look like they're having
some fun too let's talk about what
happened yesterday check this out boom
okay what are you doing there why are
you taking my king oh my God the king
the crown fell off your king is broken
what's wrong
[Laughter]
should we glue it should we should we
should we put
it
like what forever like fire water it's
okay it's okay look you're King look if
we put the if we put the peg back a
hands look the bag is falling out man oh
no he lifted up my king he can't lift up
my king but it's broken why is he
smiling
hey Frank
uh what's for dinner guys what's for
dinner Frankie's trying to I think you
said calm down guys
and then Fabi responded to all of this
the disrespected just reached its peak
decapitated
yeah oh that was just so fun that was
what provoked you to just discover and
there's the parking lot discussion Yes
actually they spent 15 minutes talking
about the game and it looked friendly
even though everybody was ready for any
kind of
they spent a lot of time discussing
yeah so we actually witnessed another
King's Gambit version yesterday yeah but
it was Kingsgate right
Kingsgate Blue Gate
it's all very strange I mean uh but now
we know all kings are fine yes
everything is fixed they're all glued
together inside the information from
right oh
um what a situation that was one of the
weirdest thing that I've seen in my
chest career no I've never witnessed
anything like that no I saw this
situation in London when the king fell
down so but still it was something which
like you imagine you can imagine just I
remember something completely normal but
it was it looked a little bit funny it
was one of these World Cup uh
competitions and it was between uh
levona Rooney and then the Carla
Nakamura and akaru just grabbed his King
and like this was moving it then
realized it's a blunder pulled his King
back took his hand off and was sitting
there thinking and Levon happily
informed him hey man that was a touch
movie
by King but it was like one of those
where you move your king and you realize
that it's like losing it exactly this
tournament in Moscow
2016 yes now I remember yeah so actually
yesterday sometimes I can't remember
there you go there you go that was a
crazy moment yeah which round number but
but what is what this was important that
it was also very emotional moment
because like it seems like Hikaru wanted
to play with something else because he
realized that it's lost and uh yeah I
mean that was still emotional situation
and Leon just explained that you it's a
basic rule and people touch your king
you have to move the king you have to
move it so yeah and by the way this is a
wonderful moment to reach out to our
audience and say we hope you've enjoyed
our coverage our broadcast of these U.S
championships and we've certainly
enjoyed your questions and you're
welcome to question Anastasia Christian
or myself how can the audience
participate in the discussion you just
follow our social media accounts
especially Twitter account of Saint
Louis chess club and please ask your
questions using this hashtag on the
screen U.S chess Champs and we do have a
question Anastasia let me say that from
krishnizzi okay so there is a question
for all three commentators if you could
go back in the time and to be a live
commentator then you just gaming history
which game would you pick and why why oh
what um I was watching the Bobby Fischer
Boris basket 1972 matches with Shelby
Lyman Shelby Lyman was the commentator
on the PBS and the the shows you were
gripping because chess was on TV for the
first time it's an entire history and it
almost felt to me like I would like to
have been there there in the series I
mean I was a very very starting player
it was a beginning at that that time so
I would be maybe a Class E player I mean
just Elementary if you will not there
but
I was excited by the commentary and I
would have enjoyed to be a part of part
of that show that was something special
uh and I know I remember being a part of
the deep blue Gary Kasparov matches the
two matches that were played in
Philadelphia as well as in New York and
that was electrifying uh the buzz the
interest in Man versus computer was
great still not as great as Fisher
spassky is like the whole world stopped
for that match wow
I really don't keep thinking about it
like perhaps maybe the match between
carb of course no will be really
interesting
and also I'm thinking about maybe some
of the linaris events you know always
everybody when casparo was in his prime
that video then it was so big fights I
think it will be really interesting to
be are commentator during this event
what about Christians for me has to be
Fisher spasky
um game one so much tension in the build
up to that game and then he plays Bishop
takes H2
I mean fortnite H5 imagine being a
commentator for uh that one Buzz around
that whole situation uh and you don't
even need the engines to understand why
Bishop takes it it's such a ridiculous
move so yeah that was just a moment in
time for sure absolutely and also I was
thinking uh strangely enough I don't
even know how it got to happen it was
like somehow I was in Bermuda I was
playing a match against Mickey Adams and
Yvette my wife she was in contact with
her dad
in uh vaikonze
and they were having she's on her
smartphone so they were having a
conversation back and forth and somehow
I got involved in the conversation and
it was a game Gary Kasparov was white in
vikon Zay against vessel and topolov
where Gary sacrificed the house and
chased vesseline's King all the way up
the board and down the board to D1 and
Jan Yvette's father was showing us the
moves and what was going on and I was
like I would like to be there that was
like a really really exciting game it
was called the pearl of iconzay I
remember about a funny story I think it
happened during the match yes in Sofia
when um topalov played against vishana
they were doing the commenters at the
time in Bulgarian television and I
remember there was a rule that they
couldn't really say that visaline is in
the bad position ah this is this is
challenging like right so for example
with Celine is a piece down so they
should have to say what an interesting
sacrifice he just made let's check it it
looks really great and things like that
you know so because okay he was he's
like a hero of the country he plays this
world championship match and it was a
little bit different approach to the
commentaries you know exactly I mean I
was always thinking how you could
actually find this kind of words to
describe the position right so not to
make it's so painful for the audience
right now you reminded me you triggered
memory Nikolai menev my trainer from
Bulgaria I came to the United States
defected to the United States if you
will and he was the a top player for
Bulgaria and he was doing commentary on
I think it was uh
Petrosian spassky
and he was reading out on Bulgarian
television the moves of the game and
they gave him a printout and it was from
Tass the Soviet news agency and he
looked at the sheet oh I'm sorry a
mistake on the notation by the task new
news agency this is an illegal move I'm
sure they meant this move and he just
continued and everything was fine he was
fired the next day from Bulgarian
television because he said the Tas news
agency had made a mistake in the move
order
tasks okay never makes a mistake
[Laughter]
so and no move order mistakes for you
Christian
actually you'll be fired yes what do you
have for us I'm looking at this game uh
big game of course the one between Talia
and Jennifer you and this is what
transpired Knight to C3 we were
mentioning yes this sequence of moves
and we're saying that white is doing
really well in the position right D5
take on D5 which by the way was uh the
best move but right now yes it was but
right now she had to start with the move
F3 and white was the best move because
if you start with the move F3 I can take
on C4 you take on e4 and now I have
enough time to focus on your D4 pawn and
put enough pressure with Knight to C6
Rook to d8 and then if you go uh E3 I go
E5 and play those type of positions
which seem to be quite fine for black
especially that after Knight to C6 the
Knight is coming potentially to D3 via
B4 Knight B4 Knight to D3 especially
once you play the move E3 E5 D5 and
attack my knight so this would have
given black enough compensation but
check this out ctxd5e takes D5 now if
you play the move F3 this is a
completely different situation you
cannot get this Pawn from D5 to C4
because there's no more pawns to be had
on that side and that means your Bishop
stays closed for the remainder of the
game or at least until I pick up one of
your pawns unless you allow me to take
on e4 and that's going to give you a
forever weakness only for you don't want
to see that on the board so this
position is considered to be quite good
for white instead of that she started
with a move Queen to B3 but now this
opens up discussion what if I go Queen
to B4 what do you do now if you drop
back to C2 then I just pick up the pawn
on D4 right so that's not an option in
the position not only that but once I
take on D4 you don't have time to go
Knight B5 because if Queen takes F2 and
this is the big difference in fact if
you start off with F3 and black goes E3
now you can go Queen B3 and against
Queen before you just drop back because
Queen takes D4 doesn't work anymore
Knight to B5 you're going to lose C7 and
actually this one is looking really bad
for uh black so small details in the
position that make all the difference
right now and by the way Jennifer is
really speeding through uh this game one
hour and 17 minutes against 54 minutes
for Talia and another big discrepancy in
the time situation is in this game
between Irena crush the big game between
Irena crush and anastasi 47 minutes for
Anna 1 hour and 23 minutes for Irina
right now building a very nice time
cushion uh Queen to C2 hinting at the
fact that sure I dropped my pieces back
knight from E5 came back to F3 but I
think I'm ready to go long Castle you
have to be worried about that as black
and how are you going to to make your
own short Castle on this side you have
to create some weaknesses you can go G6
but that will allow me to go h4h5 and
Target the hook the newly created hook
on G6 if you play H6 the same thing is
going to apply I'm going to find the
PATH towards that hook on H6 I'm going
to go long Castle then G4 H4 G5 and once
again the question is where do you put
your kick it's not an easy position and
that means that Anna is going to be
spending a lot of time to find safety in
the position for her King so
I'm looking at the position I'm seeing
Irena focused and determined to win this
game and clinch title look at her it's
not her move and she's at the board
sitting thinking plotting her next move
I'm looking at the position and I'm it's
caused me to smile because it's
transposed into the variation I spoke
about earlier right here in this moment
I was speaking about this situation of
Knight H5 and the idea of Knight H5
Bishop takes E7 Queen takes E7 Queen C2
Knight F4 the cross up White's plans of
castling long now funnily enough in the
game what happened was after Knight F3
Knight f8 check it out
we have
exactly the same position yes
but in a completely different move order
we get Knight F4 because of exactly what
Christian was talking about if I play
the move H6 I'm creating a weakness on
the king's side that after long castles
white might be able to exploit by
playing G4 H4 G5 and I've made a Target
if you will so after Knight F4 castles
Knight takes D3 Queen takes D3 there's
no I haven't Advanced my King Pawn
Shield so that the moves G4 H4 G5 H5 are
less effective of course when there is
no target yes exactly that it's better
not to push your points right but I do
think Knight F4 is the way for Anna to
go and if I have to play G6 in in the
current position if I end up playing the
moves G6 and or H6 I prefer white for
the reasons that Christians but at some
point you will have to play those moves
no matter what you do because against
Knight F4 yeah see if she goes for it
and she went for it Knight to F4 is on
the board right I can go [ __ ] before
Bishop of one and then do three forward
no no then I go long Castle
and then you have to drop back with a
knight and then I go Bishop G3 again
Bishop D3 again okay yeah if you put it
there then I have ideas of H4 as well
well here in this but I've played these
positions essentially all my life
I remember
um maybe one of my best games of my
career I was on the black side against
uh yurun picket picket was a top Dutch
Grand Master at the time and uh in the
world's top ten and I have one on the
black side but one of the things that
you try to do as black again in these
types of positions trade pieces and this
move Bishop G4
um you know fits in with that hole but
the idea is just for what Christians
Christian said you put your King on the
king side when White's King is on the
queen side you can expect H3 G4 and
you're going to get yourself attacked
and you have to be actually careful
night after for on the board and we'll
keep an eye on that again we're just
going to check in with telia because I
wanted to ask you Christian about this
move Queen B4 and again it's not a move
that I really want to play it's right
yes but suppose I do capture on B4 for
just a moment Queen takes B4 a takes B4
play the move Knight B5 and I'm looking
I'm trying to encourage you to play C6
so I can go Knight D6 and maybe my
knight gets caught in a vice over there
I have to be very careful yeah C6 is one
option maybe even C5 in the position
C5 in the position and I'll try to go
Knight C6 and develop the pieces faster
but C6 is a perfectly playable move as
well is it because 76
and I was going to go Bishop H3 so now
you're trying to do
come back well I was trying to actually
you know uh and also this night for the
moment let's go Rook F6 now right that
was the move I was hoping you were going
to do I was going to go night here and
now we don't make a draw wow and Bishop
of six you don't want to make a drop so
Rook Cafe well what what
did Bobby Fischer say in uh Pawn
sacrifice I don't want no stink and draw
Knight C7 okay seven okay seven okay
that is one bailout
[Laughter]
it's a different ball game after Queen
takes uh B4 and uh I don't I don't know
how deeply the ladies are looking
actually thinking about this idea when
you put your knight on D6 and you were
threatening Bishop Basics maybe at the
end of this variation like this one I
mean maybe you can catch the bishop I
mean yes it's very funny like Bishop
verse six and for example you play this
bishop H3 okay can they provoke you
maybe even to peruke seven something
like this like even rookie seven
actually even not it's not provoking you
it's actually defensive seven square
right very clever inadvertently those
are like a really good move my idea was
like you play Bishop six you take the
Rook on F7 yes and then I played G6 and
try to catch your Bishop something like
that but probably now I'm but you've
already defended
that was very clever yeah and you messed
me up by I uh by making those good moves
again I I still want you to be wandered
for commentators but uh how are we doing
our good friends at Q Boutique would
like to inform the good people watching
our show that there's a special today
what is it yes we have uh 1972 Fishers
past it's very very nice it's really
nice no no no I'm sorry I I got the
booklet this book this is from the
booklet that's being shown at the world
chest Hall of Fame now a magnet yes now
we have a magnet didn't it here's your
chance to collect souvenirs from the
World Chess Hall of Fame newest
exhibition and we visited the lecture
yesterday a 1972 Fishers basket the
Magic's origin and influence this two
inch by three inch refrigerator magnets
features images of Bobby Fisher and
Boris past Kim they are available in
kubutik and I will tell you a funny
story about this like I got one magnet
for myself yesterday and then Lenny was
Leonard who is the photographer here the
official photographer he was asked if he
wants a magnet and he said I don't have
a refrigerator
because he's he's traveling all the time
yes he doesn't have his refrigerator
he's never home he doesn't really want
and time for a commercial we'll see on
the other side of our break
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the World Chess Hall of Fame in St Louis
is nothing you'd expect and everything
you love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the World
Chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
we're the Corey family Welcome to our
show
[Music]
you guys
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so welcome back we have the last round
of the U.S championships and the arena
crash is still leading those eight and
half points we don't have results so far
Jennifer you plays against Talia
Cervantes both of them have wait points
and have and chances to catch the arena
in the first position absolutely and in
the opens standings we do have some
games completed already exactly Fabiano
caruana has already finished his game
against Lebanon as well as linear
Dominguez made a draw against Sam
Shanklin what it means for our standings
it means that only Ray Robson can catch
Fabiano in the first place and then
we'll have a playoff should he win today
against a Jeffrey Zhang who has been
undefeated as has Rey and their position
seems very balanced at this moment as we
jump into play and we'll pick up with
Ray Robson what do I mean by balance
well this is one of those Queens Gambit
accepted positions where we talk about
Pawn structure for a moment we talk
about Black's king-site Pawn structure
White's king-site Pawn structure and we
say four on the king side versus two
four and two versus four and two and
these are very balanced positions
oftentimes what we'll see is this bishop
is on a very very good open diagonal
black would therefore like to trade the
bishop on that very good diagonal there
are two open files which the Rooks want
to possess and the Rooks will get traded
on the open files so these open
diagonals open files we'll see lots of
Trades and we've seen a lot of draws
from these positions and at this moment
this last move by Jeffrey is a clear
indication of what he's trying to do if
it was black to move I have no doubts
that Jeffrey would play the movie Bishop
of six and say go ahead let's trade and
then starts all of these trades and
usually it's very very balanced so at
the moment Ray I want to say at the
moment Bobby's sitting very pretty he's
and he's in the Dugout saying okay you
know go ahead come on Jeffrey make a
draw and Christian so how can we uh how
can you anticipate that move Bishop to
F6 what move should you make here
perhaps B4
B4 tried to take the C5 square and in
case you go Bishop F6 we exchange that
your knight goes away from the C5 square
and then I go Knight B3 and try to go to
C5 right how big of an edge is this
is it an edge at all I think it's pretty
darn balanced still I mean I I can
imagine that uh White Rey would say okay
I don't have much I'll uh but I'll play
for B4 because at least it does give me
something to do he has to right and also
Knight D7 hints at the fact that maybe
I'll be thinking about putting that
Knight to C5 activate it like that so B4
seems to be checking a lot of boxes
right in the position now the question
is
if you do go B4 right can I play A5 yeah
I just simplify absolutely everything
yeah so if I take well you'll just take
on B4 and as you just said simplify
everything so I have to I think you have
to take on A5 yes and then if Knight
takes if Knight takes you take on B5 as
well okay
and although I haven't appreciate
there's a a traffic jam I do have A5
pardon me A3 A4 is a way of defending
the bishop yeah so actually let's
continue for a second please let's go
Knight E5
let's go night sure where Knight E5 Eve
what Knight E5 yes I'm just trying to
find some tactics
now so you have to take on we have to
take on it right all right then you take
on well he's taking on B2 I think he is
his idea maybe
but I I don't think so because well you
have to take with the queen on F3 back
okay so what would you like me to do
okay
maybe well then I take on B2 I'm a
partner right and that that's my
question do you have
um can you hold on to your Pawn like I
will take only eight and then
I'm so excited I'm I'm thrilled you
finally got a point
I don't have too much to you know going
on at the moment it's a very very slow
Wednesday
here in the Central West End but I I got
upon Queen B3 I don't know you might be
getting yourself in a little bit of
trouble you're trying to you're trying
to get me I'm trying to hurt you you're
trying to get me and now Queen before
right somehow I'm still surviving yeah
before yeah you're Queen C4 Queen a
queen C4 Queen C4 you still have Queen
Beetle ideas yeah yeah yeah no
it's it's something that I don't want to
see on the board that's for sure
Anastasia well she's getting excited and
she said Bishop G7 before he's on the
board
okay look it makes a lot of sense sure
but I think this idea of A5 what you're
suggesting it's something that I can
maybe
aspire to after I traded the Bishops for
example pardon me after Knight B3 now
can I uh play A5 because a moment ago my
night was on D7 and it was in the way of
the bishop yes right that was just a
moment ago now if you take take all
right well the the the pawn is covered
all right
and it sounds like we've got a very
special guest in studio we we should
have kept the doors locked around we
should have locked the doors yes but we
do have rexing field with us the founder
of the Saint Louis chess club first of
all Rex welcome to the show thank you
how do you feel about this year's EOS
Championship well you know I I knew we
were going to have a chess tournament I
didn't know we were going to have a
circus yes yes
this is just amazing especially
yesterday uh did you watch what
occurring happened yeah it's just crazy
what is your take on that
Well we'd have to hear the dialogue you
know what was really going on yeah
people were making inferences about what
was said and it turns out to be wrong
right Sam wasn't challenging him to a
fight he was just trying to get the
piece glue yeah so uh but the whole
thing is bizarre touching an opponent's
piece taking it off the board that's
never happened never history of Chess
they don't even have a rule on that
that's how rare it is we don't need a
rule on this that'll never happen you
know so
yeah they're showing it again this is
gonna that's gonna make the replays for
a long time it will yes so he picks it
up and yeah just an incredible scene
yesterday at the club Rex how about the
chess what players impressed you the
most in these tournament so far well I
have to confess I'm impressed by Irina
Irina by Fabiano both sitting on top of
of the pack and the pack is a group of
very good chess players on both sides so
it's no easy feat to do what they've
done and we'll just see if they can
complete what they're doing I was a
little surprised by fabi's early draw I
heard his interview and I just have to
take him at his work that a draw was
good for him and so I guess he thought
that was okay even though it could have
consequences and we don't want to
speculate but we do think that it's also
a big day for a Levon that is actually
what Fabiano was saying what's his big
day perhaps uh a baby oh so that's what
everybody know it's not being born today
it might be today yes oh my goodness
we don't want to speculate but we assume
that that's what Fabiano meant with what
he said yeah that's that's useful
information for the next time I'm
playing somebody who's about to have a
baby
absolutely Rex uh the club is expanding
in the next year talk to us know that a
little bit yeah how is that going it's
going from 6 000 to 30 000 square feet
and how's it going it's going
expensively
well luckily we have you it'll be nice
when it's completed I mean the plans are
great it's going to be a marvelous place
for playing and we don't have to worry
about expansion after that and we'll
have a facility where we can put on our
own big tournaments you know now we're
limited to 100 or 100 plus but I think
then we'll be able to go over 200 people
on a big tournament we do have
Scholastic tournaments like that those
are very important in our venue of
things and absolutely crucial to our
mission here at the same Louis chess
club also the USGS Federation moved to
St Louis recently how important is that
to the growth of the Syrian chess here
well I was happy to see it and I don't
know how much it will stimulate growth
but I think that people will notice it
certainly those tens of thousands of
members who have their membership with
the USCF and they have to pay their
annual fee they'll notice that they're
sending it now to St Louis and not to
somewhere in Tennessee
and so as I say you know today the USCF
tomorrow free day absolutely absolutely
guys any questions yeah well first of
all Rex uh good to see you very nice to
see you on show
um want to see you more actively on the
show but I got a lot of questions about
the sink fill cup and Magnus Carlson's
walking out and those questions all
related to you
how were you impacted by Magnus workout
walking out and did this offend you or
make you think why am I sponsoring chess
or
give us something I never I never asked
myself the last question I never doubted
why I'm doing this I know why I'm doing
it I'm crazy okay we got that we got
that part yeah but I thought about it
and I think
what I said is the more distant you get
from this event the more it looks bad
for Magnus I think
uh what happened was
well it's not clear that anything did
happen other than Magnus withdrawing
from the tournament and I don't see that
as a solution to anything and I don't I
haven't spoken to him I didn't speak to
him that day or anytime thereafter but I
it wouldn't surprise me if he's
questioning himself about why he did
what he did okay but as far as your
commitment to chess that was no way
um disturbed by what took place
as far as your commitment just Yasser is
asking that was not a disturbance no no
not that wouldn't change it really I
mean you're used to weird things going
on
I mean look look at the commentators we
bring in the last month has been just
simply crazy it really has been I hope
you guys have been getting some rest
we've been having a lot of fun for the
wicked over here
you have a question for Rex yeah we have
13 Rounds of these championships do you
prefer this format to have as many
rounds as possible uh I mean are you
enjoying this format this year it's I
think this is like um usually we have 12
players like 12 players playing catch-up
because of the covet uh Christian do you
feel any difference a bit longer but I
have to say I've always observed in
myself that I enjoy these tournaments as
they go on as they get closer to the end
and that's when the tension is building
and there's going to be at some point
some resolution of it a resolution you
like or maybe one you don't like but
definitely in this one it seems like you
uh picked the right horses oh my
goodness I mean both of them you know in
the women's and the reg and the open uh
coming down to the Final Round Here both
to face playoffs Rex thank you very much
for uh what you're doing for chess and
for chess here in St Louis as well yeah
and thanks to the three of you as I say
oh it pains me to say this yesterday but
I gotta say it you are the three
greatest commentator in the world thank
you thank you we love you too Rex uh
very very very nice uh indeed
um by the way just as we were doing an
interview uh oh Jeffrey made a move that
was really confounding uh that after the
move B3 B4 we kind of understood what
what Ray was doing Ray was trying to
stop Knight C5 maybe on a good day he
would take possession of the square with
moves like Knight B3 Knight C5 really we
thought B4 was aimed to get against
Bishop F6 and we thought Bishop 6 let's
go from there
E5 we didn't even check this move right
not at all E5 now that really is a kind
of a strange move because it first of
all it does weaken to very important
sensor squares both the F5 and D5
squares that's Point number one point
number two it really does seem to invite
a move like Bishop F5 now Bishop F5 not
only puts the knight in a rather awkward
pin but it it kind of starts to suggest
that that if I take the Knight The Pawn
on E5 would become suddenly vulnerable
so G6 moves are not possible at this
moment right like Bishop F5 to six you
just take the Knight and take the pawn
right yes wow that's precisely well it
is a pawn I mean it's not the end of the
world but okay you know I I don't know
if the blue is with a Bono that's what
my practice has done
I mean just just just saying what have I
learned after uh so many years a career
of Chess uh it's older you become more
you value the post exactly that's kind
of the way it goes now Bishop F5 isn't
the only movie either it just asks the
question I want to ask black I want to
ask Jeffrey is what is your very next
move as black you've just played the
movie five maybe you have six Bishop F7
this was the only thing okay that's also
a kind of uh F6 because now you've well
of course you come like it's not like I
really want to do such moves like but
I'm trying to understand maybe he wanted
to activate his bishop and put it on the
seven or I don't know the six which by
the way if you do you you know I would I
would make the argument that maybe you
should just get to it right okay another
thing again after this move E5 is kind
of what I said to you is go ahead and
make another move just you know like
you can start to see that well something
is not really jiving very well I don't
like those species that together with
these pins so for example I continue
Bishop F7
Bishop F7 and let me start to get
aggressive yeah so mighty for right I'm
almost I almost yeah demanding that you
go to D5 F5 and E4 and accept a a peace
sacrifice now should I be play like this
perhaps not but on the other hand it's
your moves you need to make some moves
not your moves but but it's the it it's
the position that is provoking I start
looking another move for example before
like asking questions immediately like
where is this night goes on this okay it
goes back keep in mind that this Knight
is a little bit vulnerable
so I have to take with the night now
because otherwise you will simply Bishop
takes H7 check so yeah and you know once
again uh asking questions asking the
sort of questions that well maybe black
doesn't want now again I'm thinking the
move E5 Drive is an overreach but if
that is true Christian if E5 by by
Jeffrey is accepted by myself
evaluation is definitely not recommended
by the machine we're not completely
losing by any stretch of the imagination
but you are giving quite a lot of
chances and actually right now it's plus
one point one whole point I'm amazed
before is one of the moves Rook fd1 the
very simple Rook fd1 is also another one
of the moves it just doesn't seem like
this was from a strategical perspective
a good move Knight to E4 Knight C3
Knight D5 is also an option now that you
just played the movie E5 and you no
longer have control over the D5 square
and how are you going to continue as
black right if you want to be able to
move your knights around you have to
create even more weaknesses and play
this move F6 solidify uh the pawn on E5
but Now with an open King like this I
have Rook fd1 you have some weaknesses
on the right squares that I can take
advantage of by playing the move Knight
to H4 and targeting those light squares
it's not looking good it's starting to
look like a very difficult defensive
task for black and you don't have a lot
of counter chances again we were looking
so many times at ideas of A5 at some
point that's what you probably have to
get going in the position in order to
simplify the position on the queen side
exchange this uh two pairs of Pawns and
then potentially get it closer to a
simplified version of what we have right
now get closer to equality we don't have
a move by Ray right now but how much
time you guys actually very because I
think this can be a one of the factors
always and race games but that's the
thing he's actually ahead on time for
the first time 54 minutes and I think
this was something that he actually
wanted to do from the beginning of the
game that's why he recently thought
about this matchup as going down to the
wire and he did not want to be in a spot
where with the title on the line he's
going to be playing on increment right I
think this was a very important decision
that Rey made before he even came to the
game yes and he was late if you remember
so yeah he decided okay I will be late
this is the only thing I do wrong today
yes yes
very conscious decision and very
professional decision by Ray Robson
right now and putting some serious
pressure against Jeffrey wow that's
really funny um I'm just turned into the
ladies game and uh
so let's check the latest game mode uh
Jennifer uh Thalia plays against
Jennifer yes this game you mean and what
do we have yes after all exchange we
have Queens left the board already yes
after Queen takes before the variations
we were checking
um I mean this is the current position
yeah this was the line that I wanted yes
Queen B4 no no it's it was the on our
analysis board so no Queen before yes it
takes a takes B4 and then we were
chicken Knight B5 yes so it didn't
happen in the game as I understood why
it didn't take on before he did she did
let me see this is yes she did not I
apologize yes so the current position is
different like she didn't think she
played something Rook D1 yes protecting
the pawn on D4
so keeping in mind that you can still do
it maybe next time night before Knight
A6 was played and Rook C1 okay so she
didn't go for that one she says okay you
can take the queen you can exchange but
on my terms I like this phrase yourself
exactly very nice um on my terms but
well somehow
um Jennifer will land on her feet after
these uh trades because I can see that
this Knight is actually on a pretty
decent Square the night on B4 first of
all it can't be uh kicked by the move A3
it defends the pawn on D5 so I would say
all things considered Jennifer will come
out of this opening more or less feeling
that she's in a good shape what's
happening in Arena's game the clocks
once more I'm always afraid whenever I
look at Anna zatonski games I'm always
afraid to look at her clock because I
just think Anna is going to be in uh
some kind of a tank and she likes to
play in time travel don't ask me why she
likes it yeah but you know her so well
yes sir you know know her so well you
were her Captain yes I mean was it the
2016 yes Olympia in Baku correct and
trust me being the captain of the U.S
women's team uh
years of my life
I'm so nervous but they played really
well yes they did they did and one of
the things that really came across
unbelievably well for me after that
Olympiad was how how much the ladies
really enjoy playing chess and they just
want more opportunities they want more
Cairns cops exactly to play in so that
they can hone their craft and they work
really really hard let's see what
happened when we left it we had a night
on F4 the bishop did drop back to F1
Anna said okay Knight B6 almost a kind
of
um an intimation that she is ready to go
Bishop E6 and Castle why the Knight on
B6 kind of helps protect the king okay
so Knight B6 castles because exactly Yes
h2h3 again one of those moves that white
more or less wants to stop but she G4
and as I would as I've been explaining
that it's in Black's interest to try to
trade or Force the trade of pieces the
move Knight H4 is rather clever because
it also Intimates that hey I've got this
um F5 Square now defended and you'll
have to play Bishop to D3 and I'll trade
more minor pieces and then once I've
castled I'm fine so everyone just play
Bishop D3 and leave this pawn and
protect don't you too
or it's too optimistic
I can see we're gonna need more training
no I
I think Bishop D3 is okay like I'm just
maybe you can so you don't take energy
too because you trust me yeah I trust
you yes I started to trust you but on
the other hand I don't know double pawns
maybe the pawn on H3 is a little bit
weak
um what what are you going to do uh your
Anastasia you're going to play at four
or five or are you going to go E4 yeah
it doesn't look good we should try
something like F4 but F4 but yeah I mean
it's not but if you do like uh playing
Bishop to D3 take the Knight first yes
okay keep your Pawn structure intact and
you know you just go and you play a
position like this if you start to go B4
B5 well I admire your
your attacking uh uh desires speaking
that's probably what she's going to go
for now to be honest it's all about the
time right 25 minutes for Anna still 25
moves to go in the position okay this is
going to go down to the wire in terms of
her time Spencer because we know she's
pretty much addicted right time trouble
situations you mentioned it she'll
actually she likes it I'm not sure you
like it actually she does I just said
this to you no of course today if she
likes it because I think for example I'm
always in the time travel I really hate
it but I'm but still it just you know
happens but it's like Richard right yes
I don't think he really enjoys it when
he has two minutes foreign
it's like it gets them going like you
know linear making moves with one second
on his drive a completely drunk position
that you can never win or lose right
um
it's not exciting it is and it's really
exciting for the rest of the world but I
mean you really don't want to play with
once again I am telling you when I was
Victor coachne second I mean it was hard
at Central I mean it was just he would
go down I'm not kidding he'd have like
two minutes for
13 moves and he did he had no idea when
he made the time control or not so
sometimes he had this two minutes for 13
moves and then he played 27 moves and
he'd still be paid I guess because
before he didn't have increments you
didn't write your moves you could
sometimes
check marks to be sure that maybe you
will pay attention and notice it's 40
moves but you are still not sure maybe
you made the mistake so you want to play
a couple of moves to be sure extra right
and then yes who knows what position you
will end up at the end of the day I just
wanted to say uh Alice Lee because uh
when we had left it we had left at this
point and Megan is saying to Alice look
I've seen your games I know that you
enjoy playing you enjoy attacking I want
to see how you enjoy defending uh G2 G3
on the board now this was some time ago
and age five so these last I want to say
two moves by Alice G3 and now her 13th
move has cost her some time well what is
the current uh
times for the 40 minutes for Alice one
hour and one minute for Megan Lee so I
mean we've seen Alice play a lot quicker
than this especially her first dozen
moves well I mean my my moves as black
are very easy
but we don't
know
it's very easy and also I can see that
E5 square is the most important square
right there's nothing subtle about my
game right now right so H4 take Queen H6
G4 Checkmate exactly that's the plan but
that's the plan HD G4 Checkmate if it
doesn't work I overextend the
overextended a bit yeah yeah no but also
see this E5 sometimes you can still
blend open the bishop in case of right
but at the moment just I don't know how
she will defend against it me either me
either you need to play this if I were
to play the move H4 I I'm not even sure
yeah I was I was about to say I'm not
even sure I like the outcome of this
which is the best thing that could
happen to me I've so to speak stopped
the king side from being open but I'm
not even sure I want that right but the
thing I'm really uh terrified of is what
happens if you take if you start
targeting this Pawn by you know
threatening
exactly and I just rewrite the way right
no I believe you I mean
yeah yep
H4 I I hear no I mean Anastasia I get it
I mean uh I'm terrified
I mean I feel I feel like I I could just
the one thing I have going for me is
fortunately I can use your Pawn the pawn
on H4 is a shield right I mean I I can
step onto the H file without fearing a
check but you're right you've got two
pawns and you've got a raging attack uh
for Alice she's probably thinking
exactly the same thoughts how I'm
supposed to defend them and why
do I have to
why am I in the situation where I'm in
trouble and I feel you know my opponent
yeah exactly like I'm supposed to I'm
white I'm supposed to have an advantage
not not a disadvantage and you can see
that she's she's not happy and she
shouldn't be happy uh Christian
absolutely and I don't think Talia is
happy either with the white pieces
against Jenny for you in this end game
um as we see we did get into that end
game Queen to B4 rookie D1 okay
um let me just get back to that position
rookie D1 Knight to A6 maybe you could
have taken on B3 first but it doesn't
really change that much Queen takes B3
take on B3 and Rook 88 this is the
position that we currently have on the
board and I'm looking at it and I'm
trying to understand what White's plan
is because I know what Black's plan is
most likely I'm going to try to put a
lot of pressure on your F2 Pawn I can go
things such as Rook to F7 followed by
root 2 f8 I can also think about uh
extending on the king side going G5 H5
get the king behind the pawns on G6 and
just simply improve my position slowly
but surely at the same time what is
white doing in the position where is she
attacking it's a B5 that's going to be
easily defended with either C6 or Rook
to F7 and both of them lead to the same
outcome you're going to have to drop
back with the Knight and then I go
Knight to B4 right and then my Bishop
can move around because my knight
defends the pawn on C6 it's exactly so
it just seems like black has an easier
play in the position and that's very
good news for Jennifer you and maybe
also good news for Irina Crush because
as I'm saying that black is better I'm
not 100 sure how much better right and
if she's not that much better then most
likely this game will end in a drop
because white doesn't have as many
weaknesses either right you have a
damaged Pawn structure these double
pawns on the B file but outside of that
you don't have any other weaknesses
right in the position it's very
difficult to get to this Pawn so still a
lot to play for in this one I have to
say black is most likely slightly better
in the position she will try to put some
pressure on her opponent on Talia who
has just been surging in this event in
the last five rounds five games five
wins in uh in a row and just an
incredible player all around but right
now she's not feeling good in this
position absolutely again we're going to
keep a very close eye on this one and as
we've been mentioning from the very very
top of the show it's the Ray Robson show
can Rey win and force a playoff it's
really that simple a draw for Ray is
really a great result let's be very
clear a clear second
qualifying very nice 45
000 thank you very much I mean it's a
good day it's a good day but could it be
a day of dreams come true or not I mean
because he told us what his three great
goals in life had been which was number
one win a medal playing for the United
States Olympic team that's that's a nice
number two getting a 2700 and becoming
an elite player number three winning a
U.S Championship now he won ago he won a
medal playing for the U.S Olympic team
so that's number one he got the 2700
rating here at this tournament he passed
2700 for the first time go Ray Ray and
now potential potential to fight for U.S
Championship it would be quite the
trifecta of dreams come true for this
very deserving uh young man and let's
see which dreams you had let's say did
you have similar goals like I want to
become this this like world champion I
don't know what kind of dreams did you
have or maybe you still have
well uh to be the best chat chess
podcaster out there
did the great thing in life I mean I
have no further dreams with that no I'm
sorry to say I I didn't I I became the
world junior Champion my dream was to
play for the world championship that was
it I mean at a certain point you know it
wasn't about that was it that was
playing football championship so dreams
like to grow the tree to build the house
to make sure like your daughter is
married proper man this kind of normal
dreams people still have them in this
event or but it's only about podcasts
world championship title uh yeah that
was it I mean for me I was just thinking
that uh I wanted that just by the way
just want to make sure this these were
dreams of Greek men you know normally
they have this kind of topic what you
have to achieve in life like to grow the
trees I don't know all of these people I
like to build the house and make sure
that your daughter is married you know
this is a good very important
it just means that this is a kind of
normal compared to what I what we hear
here right I mean all just players they
of course have to put some goals in
front in order to try to achieve them
for sure we're taught like this
I I remember the goals of the dear
friend Larry header he's a master from
Seattle and Larry went to law school yes
became an attorney and his goal in life
was to practice the law to change the
world in a positive way he ended up
having three sons and he told me his
goal in life at that point was that all
would be potty trained
masks that the kids would be potty
trained his goals kept going down and
down and down okay let's see what we had
after E5 well I must say that this was
the first move that popped into my head
Ray Robson played the move Bishop F5 why
because after the move E6 E5 you want to
jump on the light squares now Christian
was actually saying another interesting
way of jumping on the light squares was
to playing Knight E4 but that would you
know I'd have to start thinking about
well can I can I play some crazy
variations with sacrifices I'm looking
at Rook takes A6 and all kinds of stuff
too complicated for my uh taste but
Bishop F5 is what he did and I liked it
complicated for uh race days as well F7
F6 kind of what you were saying well
what you're gonna do you gotta put the
bishop you are in a pin you you defended
upon E5 now Ray said look now I know
exactly what I'm doing I'm playing
Knight to E4 but also Christian
mentioned one idea when the night was
coming to H
4 I would love to have a knight on F5
yeah I think that would be a dream talk
about dreams come true but okay I mean
from White's point of view he hasn't
maximized his achievements either he's
still looking at moves like Rook D1
Knight C5 Bishop E6 check there are a
lot of issues and for that reason I
think uh black has to do something very
quickly and actually he just made the
move defensively I think it was Knight
B8 right yeah Knight C6 came back to be
by the way uh I
when I was young I was 15 years old I
was going to school and I couldn't play
in the Vancouver British Columbia
Championship it was this two-week event
and I couldn't afford it from school but
I had this weekend and I went and Paul
caress
I was playing in Vancouver and it was
the last event he played in before he
passed so you saw him yeah I saw him
right and I saw him and I was watching
like a hawk in the playing Hall and Paul
had this very beautiful way of moving
the pieces he did it with such I want to
say gentle deliberation and he he kept
the P he grabbed the piece he put it on
the Square he made sure it was there and
gently pressed the clock I went home to
practice
the way he moved the priests because
even if I couldn't make as good moves I
wanted to play like Paul korres if you
notice just uh Jeffrey has this kind of
language
like lazy boys like if on the video
there you just saw him play Knight C6 to
V8 but he does it in almost a kind of a
lazy right yes unfortunately that's
actually cost him big time at the
Americans right he did that a few
seconds on his clock I was like Jeffrey
what are you doing just played the move
faster just play it right faster against
Fabiano in the first match it cost him
the match and Fabi went on to win the
America's Cup but nice thing like this
since he was like 10 years of age this
is having this very slow style
deliberate he shows a character maybe
also in the way right exactly there are
very nice photos sometimes we can you
can do and here we go let's just see
this is not the Paul cares
but you know you kind of reach out you
kind of slide and glide and he keeps his
hand yes for some time actually it's a
good idea maybe sometimes you made a bad
move you can bring it back just to be
sure to change your mind sorry he uses
all his fingers he's just like the whole
land the whole hand just like this
usually I do it with three yeah three
fingers right pick it up like this
now you start thinking about it the
whole hand this is uh having the piece
this is the Continental grip which grip
do you start to think about like how do
you move the pieces yes this is a
retreating move was it a good move uh
best move in the position best according
to the engines yes according to the
engines this was the best move in the
position and why was it necessary then
while it wasn't necessary no you you
just have to find the plan in the
position and we've discussed uh the
plans available for black and probably
the best one is to exchange the Rooks
right is to find a way to exchange the
Rooks what's the best way to do that via
the C file most likely so Knight to see
it makes a lot of sense uh from that
perspective also after this move Bishop
to F5 you've established a very
dangerous pin on this Knight on D7 right
after Knight to B8 I released the
tension because right now maybe I can
play the move Bishop to F7 I just played
the movie
weaker my uh G8 A2 diagonal and now I
can just simply Play Bishop F7 not only
that but I have ideas of Bishop F7
Bishop C4 maybe I get on the offensive
maybe I get to create at least a couple
of threats in the position so I like
this move Knight to ba I also like it so
much because it's really the great
example of over protection we had so
much love Yasser about it yes this is
what what's her Love's names
no yes or doesn't love them yes sir
hates Nim's eventually hello everybody
uh no we were having this discussion
last night at the dinner table and I
thought it was actually quite kind of
funny because there are people who
really you know praise nimsovich to the
to the skies and say he's a marvelous
and I'm not one of those individuals uh
now having said that we were kind of
note comparing and that was that what
that was all about by the way Ray played
rather quickly like he's as if he
spotted this move a night coming back to
B8 he played quickly Knight C3 and he's
saying you know I do want to play on the
light squares but also as as attractive
as where it was E4 even more attractive
would be D5 in that case I would be
forking the queen as well as the bishop
and very quickly Jeffrey said yeah I see
that too I've got to protect the square
D5 as Christian was mentioning Bishop C
4 on on Black's agenda and we're
expecting something like Rook fd1 yeah
yeah excuse me
thank you uh dorsa for that but Rook D1
right just to get out of the um yeah
skewer
um let's see and
and also by the way what you were saying
Jeffrey was going to try to trade Rooks
as fast as out of that pin by leaving
the the Rooks on the board okay everyone
is on the board right and also this
whole maneuver for what it's worth I
just just keep it in mind that white
would like to see some more Pawn
weaknesses developing at some point you
know you start thinking
how do I provoke the move G7 G6 and
again this is such an important game we
have to keep our eye on it I want to go
back to a wonders game for just a moment
because I thought that position was
actually working out very well for a
Wonder
we saw this chigorean French defense and
it seemed to me like Hans
was playing it in a king's Indian kind
of way like he said that he was
reverting to his roots earlier in the
tournament and playing a king's Indian
well he's got a king's Indian reversed
but at the other hand if you look at the
position from Black's point of view
black has a very nice grip in the center
more than his fair share of the center
and with this move F7 F6 he says you
know what I really don't think yes your
threats on the king side are severe I've
got a lot of Kings site protection and
on a good day I want to play Rook B8 and
B5 and crash through
on the queen side what are you going to
do about it well Han said
I really want to play F5
sometimes no and even Knight takes G6
and F5 but definitely follow it up with
F5 and a Wonder said well do your worse
I want to play the move G5 now if you
play F5 yes Bishop drops back and where
is your knight going to go Unite it's a
sacrifice you can go to G6 but if you go
back well it's going to be very very
hard for white in these positions to
break through so I'm not a big fan of
what you have to play now that you
follow me
you start to think am I going to
sacrifice this Pawn now then we'll take
on G5 but right at the beef shop so so
you get some squares and the question is
is it enough exactly if my knight was on
the D2 square and I could play Bishop
Shack at 94.
then I'm not feeling so bad being a pawn
down because the extra Pawn is the Pawn
on E5 here
I don't think I have a sufficient uh
compensation but at the moment uh I'm
saying if I'm in Han shoes I'm
I'm feeling like I've got to do
something not necessarily desperate but
I feel like I got to do something right
now
um so we'll keep an eye on this maybe
Ninth at five maybe oh this is what yeah
this is what we're just like but because
what is an alternative like can you play
Knight F3 right we can play Knight F3
but then you start have to just feels
slow yeah I agree with you but that
really if you don't want to give up upon
what is the other move like do I want to
take it and I'm going to play Knight G6
and then the night if
it's still a very it's very complicated
position
that the standard exactly uh Christian
you've got the game between Jennifer and
Talia on your board what's going on in
that let's see what uh what's happening
in this one so I think we left it after
Rook 88 and Talia decided and she
spotted this idea tried to soften up the
structure on the queen side for black
with the move Knight B5 C6 was played
Knight to C3 why did you uh Force this
move C6 well because I want to go Knight
to A4 and I have a dream that you're
going to be uh playing B5 and allow me
to get a knight to C5 that's my dream
right I get my knight to C5 then I start
attacking you on the a file and you have
huge problems with your weakness on A5
the problem is
Jennifer found this idea Knight to B4
and now if you play Knight to A4 I'm not
forced to go B5 I can first start with
this move Bishop to A6 attacks the pawn
on E2 if you trade and I take on E2
you're going to have huge problems due
to the fact that right this D3 square is
all mine right now I have so much
control over it and that's going to
allow me to transition my knight via D3
attack the pawn on F2 attack the pawn on
D2 this one is not looking good for
white so you have to defend only two
maybe Rook to D2 but now I can just
simply go Rook to B8 oh I'm not playing
the move B5 once again my knight is
defending the pawn on C6 all my pieces
are pretty much nicely protected and
placed in the position I maximized uh my
position as black and it's looking
really good what are you going to do as
white is the big question and I don't
see a clear answer yeah without F2 F3 uh
coming uh
White doesn't have too many active plans
in that position yeah the way we have a
question from social media okay with our
panel here it comes this is from dagger
the Cabrera so the question is after
yesterday's events I have to ask why do
so many GMS fiddle with pieces while
thinking have you seen any other strange
or common habits among gyms thank you so
much request a question it's a great
question I think it's an incredibly
incredibly bad habit just a terrible
terrible habit I think the worst is
Boris gelfand Boris
fiddling and he did it his whole career
I don't understand why his trainers
didn't jump on him and say stop it cut
it out I find it distracting and anytime
you're doing something that distracts
the players that's a No-No you shouldn't
be doing it secondly I really think that
it injures yourself in the sense that
it's sort of like you need something to
keep yourself occupied it's like chewing
gum or something there's just things
that you don't do that is one of them
uh the as bad as that is and I don't
mind if you're like underneath the table
the worst one I love the cross pens I
think the cross pens are absolutely the
best pens to use at the board because
it's a Twist it's a silent thing you can
turn the worst are the clickers yes
some players can be obsessed with this
idea
gosh they just keep clicking until their
heart's content and that's the worst
it's really difficult to bring your own
pants uh to the plate it's forbidden and
the organizers that use our pens or go
home it's like what yes no no you cannot
do it anymore so normally organizers
they provide their own pants without
maybe this yeah but that's where I like
to trick them too I say okay I'll use
your pen just make sure it's a cross pen
they're going to find out how expensive
any annoying habits from your opponents
yes so like maybe when you move your
something what we discussed before a few
minutes legs and you shake and the whole
table table is shaking the other tables
also and like everybody is at the end in
this Rita movement I think I also had it
sometimes you know especially when the
situation was getting really crazy on
the board your you get accepted
as well
is pretty bad it's bad but the thing is
with this very stable boards that we
have and tables that we have at the St
Louis chess club you don't actually feel
it too much okay
um a big problem is when my opponents
eat at the board oh that's terrible it's
the worst especially if it's uh like a
full lunch and it actually starts
smelling and they keep eating and
chewing there it is horrendous I'm like
look dude
what else can be like sometimes
snacking is fine look snack on uh some
protein bars or some grapes or something
like that like your tea no problem I
remember when you started eating your
whole lunch she's five o'clock and it's
time to eat lunch I remember the a very
very strong player Grandmaster andras
adorian I think he was twice candidates
and I played him in a number of times
and Andra somehow he went to Asia
and there's this Tiger Bomb now the
Tiger Bomb is really kind of this an old
Jesus it's good for the muscles and it
stimulates but it's incredibly strong at
the board now he would like to put it on
his forehead and then he'd lean into the
board and you got this Tiger Bomb smell
coming from the other side of the board
and it to say it was off-putting is to
put it mild
that used to do that or many Chinese
players used to do this I remember this
used events I took part also like in the
world championships a few times and uh
yeah I mean
it is and tiger bombs especially on his
forehead that's exactly what he was at
one point they would open this bottles
and started moving and the smell was
everywhere the whole area right actually
I'm fine with this smell but some people
can be really annoyed right so it was
it's a good point actually the Tiger
Bomb there was one other again strange
easily enough it involves Andres adorian
and he was playing a bit against Villa
mirovic and it was one of those moments
in the Chess Hall where you're just on
the edge of being too warm or on the
edge of being too cold and Andres was
wearing the sweater
and he started with a sweater he took it
off yes put it back on took it off put
it back on this occurred so many times
that the Vellum average was getting
upset Andres had walked away he'd left a
he'd walked away from the tournament
Hall and velomeric had taken the sweater
and thrown it out the window oh my God
and was like looking for a sweater and
he looked at the LA merovich accusingly
like you stole my sweater and really
pointed to the window it's out the
window at least Sam didn't do this
yesterday he killed the king he could
throw it out the window yeah hey we got
action uh folks let's jump to the game
of a Wonder Liang and Hans Neiman for a
moment because we were exactly this
moment and we were saying uh well I'm
not saying it's desperate but it's time
to go Knight F5 because I don't like the
alternatives for white I think that Hans
kind of put himself in this situation
so he took on G5 and he opened up a
discovered attack let's take it and look
at this bishop takes G5 this is nice so
if he takes with the pawn I see one
check
yeah and we've got to go King h a king
H7 another check I gotta go Bishop F6
yeah
right now at certain moment you can
start to think about takes in Bishop E4
right maybe this is the time
or do you have something else I don't
think so okay can we go back for a
second so can I start with King h8
oh excuse me uh because and Bishop H7
also right okay I think you can take on
F5 right okay it's possible also yes you
can take an i5 and then Queen H5 and I
was wondering how that position is I
take you go Queen H5 I go Beach page six
and I have Queen H7 but at least you
took that ah but you can just simply
take a bishop before yeah that's losing
let's explain to uh Christian what we
can do
yes yes uh so that the audio okay so
hold on so what what does it mean we've
got Bishop takes G5 on the board and
this came as a a bit of a shock to a
wonder he's he's under no obligation to
take I mean he's got crazy moves like E4
E5 E4 as a way of you know throwing a
spanner in White's play but once more
can we just take a look at this takes
check right
okay it's clear you can play this this
yes yeah this I this has got to be good
for white because G4 and this bishop is
just great so okay it means actually
that a Wonder cannot recap it cannot
capture and he's just got to accept that
well we've traded upon you you you you
you gave up your F Pawn I gave up my G
Pawn
um
let's see uh I've just play Queen D7
is trying to defend against all those
ideas so and I can meet Bishop check
with Bishop E6 now you could just drop
back and say okay bishop and my idea
actually had been to play Bishop G4
and somehow the because
Bishop D5 so I have to play Maybe Queen
E4 uh now okay Rook F1 maybe first to
take on the Fate maybe I don't know yet
but you're right the one the move I did
want you to play by the way
I was gonna go E4 yes and then 95 uh 95
but now gosh darn it I I blundered okay
I forgot about Queen D5 check I thought
I was trapping the queen there yes um
all right another move instead of Queen
D7 imagine I played E4 okay E4 so if
it's my turn I want to play E3 or take
the bishop exactly so probably but ah
okay that's
challenging very because let's say if I
move the bishop you take on this three
I'm not sure I like it but if I move it
on the floor okay that's the tempo
absolutely I like that move but you can
still take on this three no yes oh is my
idea
so what I have to do here well I mean
double edge you you also got a check
that you can throw in as well uh
crazy position but but it's getting
really interesting
wow
uh as this a 13th round is heating up
let's just take a quick look at our
standings before we go on break uh
Anastasia the honors for the ladies so
Irina Crush was eight and half points is
leading the tournament right now look at
the last round but she plays with Anna
zatoski so we'll see how it finish how
they finish the game and Jennifer you
shares the second position with Thalia
Cervantes and both girls played against
each other and in the open section we do
have some results two quick draws
Dominguez finished his game versus Sam
shankland right so um
linear cannot catch Fabi anymore but Ray
Robson still keeps chances in case if he
wins his game against uh
Jeffrey drunk in this case he will catch
Fabiano Caron and we'll have a playoff
playoff tomorrow yes and we're going to
see you all on the other side of the
bridge
thank you
can you hear it
it's the sound of Hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized Health
Care
[Music]
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Fabiano made her early draw against
Lavon aronian and every all the eyes are
therefore moved to uh the game between
Ray Robson because Rey has the potential
of forcing a playoff but the way he's
got to do that is he's got to win
against Jeffrey Zhang Lanier Dominguez
also made a quick draw he's in the
Dugout he's got a very nice undefeated
unblemished result and here it is you
see Ray Robson with the white pieces up
against Jeffrey and only appoints
separates him and a layoff and what is
the situation between the two Christian
I see that a lot of things have happened
actually yeah Ray has won the two
Bishops a lot of things have happened
check this out so okay this is what uh
he played after the move Queen 27. I
think this is where we left it yeah
perhaps after Rook fd1 G6 Bishop to E4
Queen 287 a very good move by Jeffrey
makes a lot of sense you want to free
this Square for the B6 Square for Knight
Knight to B6 Knight to C4 is a big
threat in the position if I manage to
get the Knight to C4 blacks is going to
be perfectly fine not only that but I
also free up the D file so that I can
start exchanging the Rooks as we were
anticipating that Jeffrey would like to
do so Knight to D5 came still Knight to
B6 and now this move Rook to C7 a very
nice tactical sequence not sure how
efficient it is in the position Rook
takes E7 Knight takes C7 Rook takes E7
Rook takes d8 and King to G7 this is the
current position we have on the board
but we know what's next for Jeff every
and he knows it as well he's going to
play Rook to D7 and he's going to try to
exchange the last pair of Rooks if you
manage to do that he's not going to have
any problems left in the position so I'm
looking at it I see Rook to D7 are
coming if you have to play moves such as
Rook to D1 to get back I'm just simply
going to follow it up with Rook to D7
follow that up with Knight to C4
I I don't think there's much in the
position
um Fabi must be looking at this game
right now at home and feeling quite good
about the outcome of the middle game
exactly rooting for Jeffrey to draw the
game turning our attention to the ladies
for a moment we have this all-important
game going on between Talia and Jennifer
both ladies looking for a result there
of course if one can win an arena only
draws or loses or loses it's all good
and uh well uh it does appear to our
eyes and as Christian has mentioned him
in the earlier broadcast that well
Jennifer is out play Talia Talia comes
into today's game with a five game win
streak absolutely absolutely remarkable
but with this move Bishop F1 it's a
clear signal she's on the back foot
she's defending the pawn on E2 not
willing to trade it for the B6 pawn and
Jennifer says you know what I'll defend
the pawn I'm not even going to give your
knight a square on C5 I'm going to
defend the pawn and ask you what you're
going to do black having the healthier
Pawn structure
Talia said well what can I do king G2
may be looking to play the move F2 F3
and Jennifer says okay do your worst
play the move F3 if you like I'm going
to play G5 and maybe I'm going to take
that option away from you if I can play
the move G4 definitely Jennifer for
choice that it's by no means not even
close to decisive or anything like that
yeah he's still in this position for
white luck what consequences this move
will have exactly
um from a practical perspective
absolutely not but I will shock you with
the engine eval yeah is completely
winning
for black yes completely winning right
yes plus two close to two yes
exactly wow minus 1.5 now with the best
move minus 1.7 with the second best move
yes what is the best
F3 and then I go I can go E3 it's not
looking very easy for uh White to find
the move after E3 so to be honest F3 at
least to my eyes is a very difficult
practical decision to make right now
because you are allowing this move uh E3
if you don't do that maybe H3 in the
position for example but then I just
continue right or King G7 or H5 let's go
H5 let's just go with the most practical
and most obvious move in the position
you play G5 I might as well try to play
uh H5 and G4 and continue with my plan
right of just locking down the F2 pawn
and we were discussing this plan of
expansion for uh black long time ago and
once again it doesn't seem like white
has a good way to just sit and wait
right and she doesn't have any sort of
uh active plans in the position
this bishop is not moving it's terrible
three I take and I go Knight D3 and I'm
much better in the position you know the
the strangest thing when you said that
uh black is much better after F3 was I
was thinking that oh I get it you're
going to play rookie you don't want to
take this Pawn on e4 and invite my rook
and if you take this Pawn on B6 I
thought ah this is what uh White's
problem is you won the pawn good for you
how good is the position after I play
the move Bishop E2 I want to take this
Pawn with check I want to take this rook
and in case you're compelled to well you
can just see how quickly Black's Rooks
are going to storm into the position so
you could also play a bit before and if
I'm not mistaken after take take and
also like Bishop of one straight away oh
I see like you yeah
yes that is pretty you're right
Anastasia you're right
yeah and you don't have Rook F2 because
I take here yes and that's a nasty nasty
uh fork and look at the time as well
guys this is a big problem also she only
has uh 16 minutes left Talia there is
for uh almost 20 moves
if Jennifer wins wow
if any of the players Jennifer you or
Talia win this game and Irina crush
doesn't win her game well they're going
to force either a playoff or if Irina
loses actually win it outright so huge
game this one between Jennifer and Talia
Jennifer knows it and Jennifer still
Harbors hopes of winning the
championship well talk about a roller
coaster and you were saying that Hans
Neiman couldn't sleep and even Lanier
who is undefeated had trouble because of
the one second and Matt put yourself in
Jennifer's shoes in round 12. she's in
clear first yes she loses the game to
her closest
Rivals is by playing for what she
thought was winning yes you play a move
like Bishop A4 you think I'm winning yes
and then you lose and now if she comes
back and somehow magically manages to
win this game in Arena
does something that goes south I mean
talk about emotionally it is ups and
downs let's jump to that game of Arena
by the way when we left it we just kind
of left it at these parts we had seen
this move Knight H4 yes and we thought
okay arena is for Choice after Queen E7
King B1 G6 Rook C1 Queen B4 wow that's
that's what we'd call a billiard shot in
chess the queen was on H4 the next day
it flew across the board to the B4
Square H4 okay the queen was on H4 and
now the bone came yes okay I guess uh
Arena starting to think that well maybe
she could play H5 castles yes okay now
Arena
is actually struggling this move Knight
B1 is an indication that's all is not
well with Arena Knight B1 this
retreating move
uh does not inspire
uh confidence it might be one king B8
Knight D2 okay that's another
three Champion to bring the Knight to B3
and what is it doing there the idea
maybe was to stop C5 right stop c65 yes
because then maybe maybe on a good day
to put the Knight on C5 so I think
there's a very clear idea okay play fast
and to play against her opponent's clock
because there you go exactly because
this is what she's going for and only 14
minutes for the next 15 moves that's not
easy
actually I would like to mention
something important for the last rounds
the problem is also it's not only that
you play your own game all the time
you're checking the game of Jennifer and
Tyler trying to understand what's going
on there because in case if it's very
drawish then you have chance to offer a
draw against Sun as a toaster
no I mean you can play foreign
try to make a draw here and imagine if
you come and you see that Jennifer has
much better position it puts lots of
pressure on you again and you come back
to your board and you think okay like do
I really want to play playoffs so it's
not like you play only one game at this
moment you also thinking about something
yeah right so it's something special
about the last rounds when you it's
easier in a way to Ray Robson now that
he knows that Fabio made the draw okay
it's just like everything depends on him
either he wins or he makes a draw
exactly this Edition it's It's Tricky
like Irina knows if she loses
I think all of us have that experience
of hedging our bets so to speak like we
want to keep the game in flux where
everything can happen in case we need to
win but at the same time not to over
extend ourselves and this is a good
situation for our readers right because
she's not really risking much in the
position it's not like she created any
weaknesses in the position there is no
isolated Pawn that she's working with or
anything of that nature something long
term her position is very healthy right
right she has space Advantage
wait a minute I don't excuse me what is
that I was just talking about the
isolated Pawn right right
there's no weaknesses in the position
that she can work with by the way I
didn't understand Anna's move after the
move Knight D7 I get that Queen came to
E2 and I was thinking to myself does
Anna want to play the move C5 or not so
for example in this position after C5
takes Knight takes C5 maybe you don't
want to play this because it's not that
easy to attack the Knight you'll have to
play Bishop D7
and Knight E6 to get rid of this very
strong Knight
but I didn't understand this move Queen
E7 at all I mean I will my Queens
perfectly wild there I could imagine
White playing Rook C3 and Rook C1 and
then A3 and then dropping a knight on C5
they're on the dark Source yeah yeah but
okay if I were in black shoes Okay
imagine I just for argument's sake play
Rook C7 and you play Rook C3 and I play
Rook C8 uh I'm not really afraid of
Knight C5 I mean I'll I'll trade it I
mean maybe I'll even pick up a pawn if
you yes if you are so kind but she
played the move Queen E7
and
well
I like meditation I'll take the dark
squares Queen D2 I thought Rook C3 but
then C5 you do you do you like these
moves by Anna I Like Queenie seven okay
uh I'm not sure about C5 I just feel
like you're creating a long-term
weakness and this is exactly what Irina
wants to work with
um well there is a problem when you drop
a queen A5 Queen d8 I always see in the
position okay and I always hunt your
queen
okay well it's kind of strange I think
that the queen on C2 is not as well
placed as the queen on A5 okay
absolutely absolutely somehow Arena did
well but this is a very committal
decision CFI D takes C5 Knight takes C5
and right here I would be very attracted
to the move oh unfortunately it doesn't
work because there's Knight takes B3
with the check
yeah but then D4 no no no no no she's
going to play Knight to D4 in this case
okay and it's an isolated Palm exactly
it's Bishop
you take on D3 and I have to take on C8
I unders no I think you have to take
because take on H4 maybe you will lose
maybe that might be a problem right uh
no I'm winning oh really let's check it
out okay
now first of all remember
I don't sacrifice pawns yes we remember
so why did you give my dick okay
queen d8 huh
and I play five to win the check yes I
go now I can take this Pawn but okay
I mean you're definitely looking good
now I'm not sure about winning though
but yeah you're right it was an
overreach I didn't see Queen d8 I saw
Queen C3 with the double thread of me
but you try to continue
a hesitation yes
by the way this is your puzzle Rush
tactics for today everybody I'm
promising you that on your puzzle Rush
you'll get two points because of these
Queen checks and sacrifices
but you're right uh Queen d8 is not uh
winning so how bad is the position after
let's say 94 which was played in the
game let's say Knight takes D3 another
difficult decision that Anna has to make
Rook takes C8 and then Queen takes D3
normally this Knight on D4 is really
good right that's what I know about
Knights and Bishops if you get this
position you're really happy absolutely
yeah it cannot be kicked out never and
it's like cool I've always been taught
it's a two result game it is a two
result game and it's lucky because you
don't have Queen takes H4 right that
would be a nice tactic but my queen is
ready to cover up
1v1 it's not successful I know
you know where I feel cheated on those
puzzle rushes when when I'm supposed to
make a draw uh yeah of course and you're
looking for wins all the time
and then I have to reconcile and then
they say yeah drop and you're like no
I'm supposed to be yes normally you have
to win this position yes I don't like it
I don't like it either versus Jennifer
okay
yes I thought about it but it really
looks like you kind of accept the fact
that you're worse forever forever yes
with night on display so uh E3 came and
this is where I will be there with the
computer with a massive evaluation the
evaluation jumped and in my mind after I
saw the movie three because we're always
talking about the D3 Square here we'd
love our King to be over on the queen
side we don't know where just so that
we'd release our Rooks and we'll double
up on the f file we'll get our Pawn to
H5 even make sure that F3 never gets
played Bishop to D3 not a bad move I can
I can understand it I probably just take
myself and put a rook on F3 and say what
are you going to do Rook to D2 Rook F6
King G1 and tell you're really suffering
now no it's just not not a nice position
for her I would play G4 just kind of
shut down so that this Pawn is forever
just cannot see in this position it's
really bad one and then then bring my
king over to the queen side so really
play on one goal here for Jennifer and
for Talia I mean it's just sort of like
kind of a shocking turn of events I mean
five draws
five wins yes and now you're worse it's
like what kind of a tournament are you
playing here is some really up ups and
downs emotionally I want to jump to the
game of Alice Lee versus Megan Lee
because Alice uh was really under a
great deal of pressure right here and I
was more than curious how she was going
to handle this
pretty scary looking attack h5h4 by
Megan she played rookie one yes H4 and
Knight F1 okay I thought she might try
to set up with a bishop on G2 Knight F1
Queen H6 well it's very easy to text G3
hg3 uh Bishop B2 yes Knight F6 just
everybody's coming over to the party yes
HG FG this yeah forced here it comes
Knight takes G3 look at this move will
c65 somebody is just taking everything
there and now it's just black has
the pawn and compensation everything's
just gone terribly wrong for Alice he's
in a losing uh position now as we can
see Megan with threats of Queen and Rook
this bishop on B8 is about to be
Unleashed I can imagine a knight coming
to G-Force looks really really bad maybe
G4 or G4 I don't know maybe then 95
still she has yes that was why she put a
bishop on B2 what she's hoping to uh
yeah and again it's like these the these
Championship rounds can be like that
Alice will look back on this event you
know and say you know I had a pretty
good event you know like I learned a lot
I'm looking forward to the next U.S
Championship you lose the last round and
your your whole mood is spoiled uh she's
had some great positions I've noticed
that would be on the second the first
place right now I mean came in and said
look you know I had some great positions
I messed them up I could have gotten
extra half points here and there and I
said
clearly two winning positions right not
just like battery the winning
yes we try to remember
completely winning positions when we
started remember this exchange job yes
which is somehow she missed my yes idea
so she really had those chances like
exactly to be even higher yeah also
speaking of Tata it seems like she's
winning her game really I guess at the
end that's a good finish for her she won
against Rochelle yesterday if she wins
this one as well I think she's going to
be finishing on
what a massively complex looking
position like
whoa
whoa whoa
I really oh my goodness
that block of Pawns yeah it does exactly
D5 D4 right I mean but that's a place
was was black here and uh yeah some
houses yes she found the way to exchange
well this is this beautiful uh battery
uh is going to force Naji to do
something that she didn't want to do
either trade queens or release this pin
by playing something again not what she
wants to do she wanted to keep that PIN
Bishop takes F7 check looks good for
Tata but again let's go back to our open
section and follow our leaders Ray
Robson as secured the two Bishops so he
played actually one
Queen C7 G4 okay I I'm very uh how do
you say empathetic sympathetic uh so
sympathetic yes to this move a dual
purpose the first you know stops F5 yeah
then that's fine I mean it kind of
secures this G4 squared secondly it does
intimate that a certain moment this
bishop uh is looking greedily at the
long diagonal and you may want to play
G5 and Knight takes E5 and
um and so forth and so on so G4 but wait
a minute what what am I missing okay we
are we seeing a repetition potentially
for age six Rooks by the way H6 uh to
take away yes that idea I just mentioned
Rook C1 Queen D6 Rook D1 it could also
be that it's not a repetition and
actually he's just trying to gain some
time
because he does have 14 uh minutes for
gain a little bit of time there and then
I completely misunderstood the position
because I thought if I'm in Jeffrey's
shoes I desperately wanted to play
Knight C4 as soon as possible and this
move Rook C1 makes it possible so the
fact that Jeffrey played the move Queen
D6 and we do have this Rook D1 is is
confusing me why didn't he play Knight
C4 maybe Knight D2
92 and Knight B Knight B6 Knight D7 to
be sick tried to take on C4 Bishop takes
right and I guess he just didn't want to
play this position with uh against two
Bishops like Queen yeah but now that I
put the pawn on H six there is a little
bit and I don't have Bishop I would have
to put my knight
and then okay if that makes sense now I
do have the queen on C7 right yes that
proposes uh repetition
it does
hmm Queen is on that's the latest move
Queen to C7 when you see someone has
been played so let's see whether rape
will accept
the repetition or try to play for a win
try to change if they make a draw father
wins the tournament this is very clear
yes we might see a repetition guys Rook
C1 on the board Jeff
but for Jeffrey this would be fine
because that will help him qualify for
the World Cup yes but for Ray this
doesn't do many good this uh repetition
I mean it secures himself second second
place okay I would say still it's not so
bad he will get 45 000 but he won't get
his dream come true
but he will be in the world cup and uh
maybe he's finally ready to uh delay his
dream for one year for one year maybe
he's ready hey Carpe Diem man yes seize
the day
yeah Rook C1 uh a little bit of a
surprise so with Queen D6 could Jeffrey
make a claim or no not yet Queen D6
would be the second time and then if Ray
plays the more Rook to D1 and now it's
the time to claim the draw I see
really important moment for this
championship
because I'm curious whether
Jeffrey actually wants to play for a win
but it doesn't really make a lot of
sense for him to try to make it I'm sure
he's in top five is it 100 because it's
a Restless Soul can win today Wesley is
winning yes Wesley is winning
our defending Champion making a late
comeback
um if Rey
wants to win this game in the current
situation current position after say
queen D6 Christian what would be his
yeah how do you keep the game alive how
do you play for a win Knight D2 would
that be a move Knight D2 okay that
protects the C4 Square it's not exactly
inspiring it's not
yeah
it's the best I can do like I I all the
people in our audience just did the wave
maybe you know like a giant cheer
sometimes it's interesting you have to
maneuver your pieces before you can do
something but maybe it sounds like looks
survive later
and by the way uh Christopher whoa has
won his game against Darius with the
black pieces a good finish for a young
Christopher absolutely whoa I've seen it
was a very theoretical battle but I kind
I kind of stopped looking at it just
about here I thought this was all Theory
I'm sure we will be speaking with
Christopher about this game and
wow
okay that was it for darouch by the way
he was one of the players of course who
was going very nicely undefeated and
then it was just this collapse he had
against Sam sevion if I so he I remember
on a minus one would that be oh no but
he also lost against the Wonder
a wander and now Christopher you
and earlier against Fabiano exactly so
he's a minus two he finished the
tournament
he yeah again this is one of those what
happens in those Championship rounds
darush in my mind was having a very nice
tournament he was like looking really
good but the Finish was Dreadful after
the free day he lost all games
it means so if you lose three in a row
it was actually after the free day like
right something happened wow during the
free day something terrible happened uh
let's just uh jump into the game of a
Wonder pardon me it was Hans demon yes I
wonder Liang when when a Wonder played
the move queenies so from a wondrous
point of view when he played the move
Queen E7 he's thinking to himself well
white wants to bring this Knight back
into the play and I want to play for E5
E4 so I want after Knight F3 to meet it
with the move E4 Han said I get that but
this is the tempo this is a Tempo
against your Bishop could he take on
still on this three take on the two
yes just to follow what would what would
have happened by the way guys Queen to
D6 is on the board in in the ray game uh
Queen to D6 is it so that it looks like
at the moment right at the moment so
maybe we can see okay okay
so because if he plays Rook D1 the game
is a draw uh right now if you place Rook
D1 uh Jeffrey will promise that we've
got the uh so no no
draw there we go yes okay
so I did you hear the cry yes of course
everybody's screaming far beyond
what are you doing I will hear it in
half an hour a moment and I mostly have
coaches that like work with me with
trading sessions from support system in
your dad or like my mom and my dad for
all the support
things out absolutely and that's so
important in this type of uh very long
events when was the last time you played
such a long event and maybe 11 rounds
but I don't actually remember ever
playing a 13 round classical tournament
so it was definitely a new experience do
you want it to ice the game make a draw
or did you wanted to put some pressure
on a struggling Darius in the last few
rounds if he doesn't want to draw I'll
just play do moves
um it was
um so this was still preparation with
takes takes night before but after night
before he spent a lot of time
uh he was probably considering I guess I
was considering D5 yeah and nothing else
so I kept going material so kind of
really experience the playing with that
bar yesterday because I was like the
initiative you are a pawn of this [ __ ]
Pawn B3 after the move Thief time it
didn't seem quite necessary
um like by now I think he already only
had four minutes and it's only moves
down to his last two missed for
congratulations uh for him that you've
ever played and it's also and that first
you also make a lot of mistakes the
mistakes because they're here
dating theme yeah I definitely did not
expect it
you definitely opened the Pandora's box
but good luck good luck Christopher uh
and congratulations on this last round
win thank you you're welcome yeah
uh Arena can
um how do you say so internet title with
a Victory can she do it when we left it
we just this isolated upon the isolation
went for a position with few pieces on
the board but she's just played this
move Bishop A4 saying to White okay you
can play
B3 kicking up and down I feel there are
some tricks here maybe well tricks by
playing the move Bishop C2 what's your
take I guess Bishop she decided to keep
the knights on the board you mean right
right here remember just when uh Arena
played this move Knight before she
didn't of course take the bishop of D3
right understanding that this position
is is bad for black right so she kept
the knights and now actually it's a
different situation that white could
change this Knight on the six but again
better me too I I mean a long time ago
Arena had played the move H4 and I'm
sure she had H5 in mind and why she
didn't continue with this is a mystery
because if you do play G5 you know what
I think that pawn excuse me I got that
Arrow wrong that pawn on H7 it's just
like it's a constant Menace I want to
say that like that
she made this okay kind of diffusing she
played 94 and now be sure after Bishop
F4 definitely she doesn't want to play
B3 and then if she doesn't want to play
it what she'll move the Rook where C1
because we remember that we want to
exchange pieces here now something what
you just told me well yes okay but she
could have done it before yesterday yeah
yeah
um okay Arena still for Choice uh Talia
was had a terrible and look at that the
king walk I did this wonderful book I
really enjoyed this book that I made
with a friend of mine from Vancouver we
see Bruce Harper King walks where you
voluntarily walk a king across the board
and Jennifer's done that why because
just as we can see a few moves ago this
Rook is Tethered to the pawn on B6 you
want to release the rook and have a
lesser piece defend upon and this is
such a second position yeah it's a set
position forward but how will you break
through how are you going to win this
position so what do you do yes like okay
like 93 I will break into two King James
to maximize the position right all right
let's go H5 I think that's a very good
way of okay so we're gonna go King G2
for white we're going to go H5 yeah I
keep playing yes I just want to
understand how you I'll go H4 as well
can you help me or not oh my gosh if you
want to play G4 H3 so I don't have
exactly oh my God and then I was I
played rookie too
still like that right yeah but if you
play it like this I will play 92 94. I
don't think I'm going to go G4 okay only
okay see only H3 I don't want to
disrespect you that much
okay uh I I just feel that we're gonna
get squeezed to death in such a case
yeah but we are anyway right yes
there's no doubt about it okay so hold
on I apologize it's just going to
refresh my board to get the current
position as tally has played the move
92.
okay maybe she wants to play Knight C1
and defend this DC Square
exactly like at the moment you play
Knight D3 I play Knight C1 but it's
interesting that the Knight on C3 was
actually playing a kind of a positive
role and I understand that that
Christian wants to maximize his position
yes and then which includes C5 of course
as well
when your night
moved away from D5 it does invite
I think I will bring my king to all the
way to B5 maybe or play 93 even I may be
ready to exchange these Knights and then
I just come with my king
maybe yeah
I don't know yes no no no no I I
absolutely agree with you wholeheartedly
that you put your King on B5 then I have
to really get scared that your king is
going to break through on the king side
so essentially uh blacks breaks or H5 H4
and absolutely C6 C5 and Jennifer seems
to be I think she's going for H5 H5 is
that because of the Christopher
hover
the the the the the hand uh
understandable the the tension is so
high for these two ladies right right
they know that with a victory well at
least they secure the second place right
absolutely that's a pretty decent result
right there right but you're also
putting uh pressure on Irina crush and
you're maximizing the potential of your
tournament with a victory in this one so
huge moment for both of these young
ladies yeah absolutely and actually just
we have Christopher here and I just want
to say that he brought some spies in
this tournament not only by by his
interviews but also you remember he beat
Wesley so in the round two and in
general he's using a repetition exactly
and so it's really great actually
fighting spirit in this uh tournament
and no matter what was his the result of
the previous round he was trying to
fight in all his games and he's only 15.
yeah Andy is 15. is his first US chess
championships I mean I think he put up a
very good performance yeah and that's
according to my understanding oh no
question about it and he came in
and has answered the question what did
you learn these guys are human yes they
make mistakes and I think that that is a
real problem that a lot of Juniors have
you know they see these great names
Magnus Carls too much respect great
great great respect they forget that we
are all human and we do make mistakes I
think Christopher just so disrespectful
this Grandmaster
he actually kind of in order to keep
winning against those big names you have
to
have a bit lack of respect
exactly bust yes you have to really try
to play the against pieces at this
moment I remember a story of Edward
guefeld I just have to put it on the
board so our viewers will understand me
so Edward gofeld is playing against
Vasily Smith and the great super Soviet
finals uh Knight F3 Knight F6 and Edward
guefeld played B4
your B4 and Smith was off off the board
so he was standing at Bud vinic came to
smislav who now asked to answer the move
before and and Edward he heard Michael
bought the next say to his opponent
why do we allow these punks into our
turnips
Junior B4 how dare you wait such a
movement
some other I thought that was hilarious
uh again uh yeah well you've got to have
that attitude as a junior you've got to
say hey I'm here to win as well by the
way Arena played a move I can get I get
behind this move Rook C1 Bishop back she
makes Luft but she does it in a nice way
this bishop is coming to A2 where it
will be targeting uh Anna's isolated
pawn and Anna is stopped wow
and she's down to her put it on the
board so our viewers will understand me
so Edward gofeld is playing against
vasili smisloff and the great super
Soviet finals uh Knight F3 Knight F6 and
Edward guefeld played B4
B4
and Smith was off off the board so he
was standing and bought vinic came to
smislav who now asked to answer the move
before and and Edward heard Michael
bought the next say to his opponent
why do we allow these punks into our
eternity
Junior B4 how dare you wait I'm such a
move today
I thought that was hilarious uh again uh
yeah well you've got to have that
attitude as a junior you've got to say
hey I'm here to win as well by the way
Arena played a move I can go I get
behind this move Rook C1 Bishop back she
makes Luft but she does it in a nice way
this bishop is coming to A2 where it
will be targeting
Anna's ice make a beeline to the D6
Square
six was played Queen F oh excuse me I'm
going to be six queen of six uh Queen B6
Queen F6 and A6 A7 A6 correct make a
lift for uh the king now I've been kind
of thumping for this move H5 for quite
some time maybe it's time to play I
think it is right now the question
also maybe bishop D5 I like it and
perhaps a good idea if you go H5 maybe I
can go D4
D4 can I can I break like that
um well
you just take on these things maybe
that's why she played A6 because G4 was
not possible before probably
I'm sorry lines maybe there were some
checks yeah yeah help me out here what
first of all what move number is this
this is move 39 so 39. well you have to
go into the time control and is time an
issue for arena
Okay so
sorry
um Anastasia you like the move Rook D1
and I wanted to ask you idea the idea is
to take on D5 maybe in some variations
using the fact the fact that Queen is uh
the bishop spinned right yes so like
let's say I make a bad move and you
could play it says
it is a nice it is a nice pin and if you
take Bishop takes D5 and you're a happy
camper yes and there are no chicks
nothing okay now we're fine now yes
you're very happy yes so after Rook D1
I probably you have to put in your seven
maybe protecting the queen so that
Bishop takes D5 is no longer a threat so
can I play now like Rook D4 with the
idea before sometimes also maybe and
queen E7 if I'm allowed if not just kind
of put my room it's sort of like you're
kind of pro probing around like you say
you get Queenie sun and you've got these
nasty little tickling Blues where maybe
you're putting me in
so that Bishop takes D5 is no longer a
threat so can I play now like Rook D4
with the idea before sometimes also
maybe and queen E7 if I'm allowed if not
just kind of put my room it's sort of
like you're kind of probing around like
you say you get Queeny sound and you've
got these nasty little tickling news
where maybe you're putting me in a very
awkward position for Anna you know she's
just on the back foot she's defending
defending defending it's not a it's not
nice uh to be in but she made that
decision herself that isolated Queen
Pawn she plays C5 yeah yeah but okay uh
one more move to go sorry let me just
catch up also on the Talia Jennifer you
game oh Talia is Boston
uh big time I was just going to say just
take a visual of all of the pieces and
the pawn is hanging the Rooks are ideal
she's gotten in C5 you know what the
problem is no you cannot go even King H3
why why can't I go King H3 because of
rock takes G3 oh this was nice that's
embarrassing of course that that does it
so that was why Talia had to play Rook H
wow Rook H1 Knight D3 this is the this
is what hurts 93 maybe you take on D3 so
not yet Knight D3 okay well uh you no
we're not losing this that's not you
could be winning
is that this could be a winning a rook
ending because the pawn on G3 but there
should be something oh okay you want
something even nicer than that yes maybe
what uh Anastasia offered earlier just
bring your king to B5 and then put your
name D6 King David six okay
looks good too nobody likes my plans
it's the commentator's curse the moment
you offer a really really good idea
nobody you know Applause for what is I
think it's a great fact I think that was
exactly what I was thinking too trying
to get on your good side after all the
poking about nimsovich gotta defend my
ribs you know the thing is that white
cannot play any single move in the
position right yes exactly it's sort of
like almost yes our producer loves you
uh yeah I found the way to use this word
yeah nice uh no for Talia this is
terrible again Arena uh is enjoying her
position let's say let's go back to the
Ray Robson game because
wow uh I mean this game just swung huge
and well Ray took the exchange So
materially speaking
rook and pawn versus two minor pieces
but a huge difference in the position
suddenly Black's King got really nicely
protected White's King didn't the best
move in the position G4 G2
can't do it and in fact the pawn on H3
is now really really tender and I would
say in a practical game I would much
rather have Black's position and Rayne
knows it too I mean so now actually he's
fighting for a draw correct yes that's
exactly what's happened yeah yeah what
to do it's it's chess is so difficult
one move
one square away from the best move Queen
the whole tournament is not necessarily
a bat tournament right now destroyed or
anything of that nature but you lost so
much in this one mistake especially if
he loses this one if he loses this one
then I think Jeffrey catches on to him
yes yes and they're going to share he's
not even going to catch this actually
he's going to take second tight to
Fourth I think well at this moment
Lanier is a happy linear yeah he's in
second he's in second with Ray with it
was very used with Ray yeah because he
he called him already seven and a half
points Jeffrey is going to catch him so
if Jeffrey wins yes in this case he will
have seven and a half Wesley if he wins
catches him wow exactly and I wonder if
he draws catches him
all the way to six yes tied for six oh
my goodness you kind of lose smiling
about 15 000.
you don't want to talk to your
accountant anymore
Doug is going to say hey Ray you know
that bad
you know like the good news is you don't
have to pay so much in tax the bad news
is you don't you don't have to pay so
much in tax you know oh boy uh Queen A1
versus queen B1 Queen B1 mistake
allowing the move F5 with a double
attack against the bishop honey for the
night on H4 how do you put it had he put
his Queen on the long diagonal then of
course F5 just runs smack into Queen
takes
E5 check and therefore there would have
been no F5 then slowly slowly Ray could
have played for King G2 King G3 Queen B1
big Advantage Rey uh Queen B1 question
mark and Advantage Jeffrey Jeffrey in
one move in one move
chest is cruel chess is cruel and then
he died
[Laughter]
uh well all right we're trying to keep
it light here round 13 yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh let's jump to the ladies
one more time and you're King A7 to stop
Bishop A2 so Arena's putting all of her
energy into this isolated pawn and after
the move King A7
yes it's not uh it's not hanging anymore
like Bishop D5 so Queen is seven I
thought about the small work z7 was
probably well tried yeah it just came
out yeah so how do we how do we have to
get to that H7 point exactly exactly now
if we go immediately after well H5 so
that was why I was kind of uh consistent
yeah like like do it uh do something
like this here okay so go H5 for just a
second uh I just wanted to say there was
one other point though Queen E5 I I may
very well be threatening to take this uh
I wanted to say that in this position
you're this ending position the king is
not as quickly coming to the D6 Square
which makes me stop and think you know
can I play Rook D4 E4 you know what I'm
saying sorry Christian please and
actually at that point I think it comes
just in time
if you go Rook D4 King b60 for King C6
and finally I defended my did did
Black's King make it just in time right
right so maybe you can prepare this
queen trade with having The Rook already
on D4 okay somehow okay so we start with
say Rook D4 we go H5 for whatever
reasons we go Queen E5 and this is where
life is good yes
even this is not clear right I go King
B6 yeah it's not game over it's not game
over but there's something to work with
exactly right I mean if I will take
maybe I think Rook C4 maybe for you
actually take on D5 it's really pretty
right uh
take here and there is root d8 from d8
but what is this position
you have some good chances
very very nice winning so actually H5
was about in my position
at the time it was a good idea oh
yeah yeah very complex still but at
least Anna has to be relieved she made
time control okay that's good
and in the huge game between Talia and
Jennifer Jennifer well she's just played
this this last move Knight C6 and Talia
is just really really in his
awful awful bind
[Music]
um
hmm
I'm just trying to think if I'm In Her
Shoes I
I'm not happy of course but
I
but I can't afford to go material down
I'm
um
yeah can this tree Maybe
King H3 well
help me out because if I'm I'm afraid if
I move my Rook I'm just going to get hit
with D5 D4 and uh well I'm just kidding
before yes maybe I can sacrifice wait a
second that they come before you
sacrifice and then Ruby four
okay that's
um and difficult if I would check so you
go here and I see the idea if I take
only four you will take on G3 first yes
okay I'm not going to the strap
that's a nice one yes
so what can I do so like Group D no but
it looks lost yes
it's an exchange it's an exchange and
let's say there is not really we don't
have a compensation yeah I don't feel it
either yeah I don't feel it either yes
but okay uh yes yes exactly it's
interesting if white still can because
if you don't take on D4 this position
looks just
portable exactly slowly slowly uh black
is going to take over the game this
night of disabled will not survive right
so Queen E5 actually in uh a really nice
game he's a reward
sorry let me just do it this way
okay Queen E5 she did play not Rook D4
not true before first I would assume
maybe Rook to D4 she was maybe worried
about ideas that we're going to C8
if you take on D5 Rook C1 just finishes
the game actually yeah yeah no no we
don't want this
we don't take
but this is how you can that would be an
oopsie
discover check
how would we use to Daisy okay she
didn't play Rook to D4 Irina in fact
played Queen to E5
and again uh just a a two result game is
what I'm seeing here I mean uh White uh
should win this game probably I'm gonna
say
three four times out of ten and the
other times should be a draw
yes and how many minutes did Ray think
because I mean it's been a while and
nothing has changed in that position yes
and actually it's moved 30 only right no
no it's it's more 40. they just made
more time
for only seven minutes okay that's not
that bad
sorry I have it on my board King G2 but
this is the analysis and there we have
it
and it's so difficult psychologically
right because you've been playing for a
win this whole game you've been playing
with one goal in mind and that is to
force the playoffs right right now you
have to readjust your mindset completely
180. and now now you're playing for a
draw you're trying to survive in the
position right and you think also why
didn't they take this repetition
exactly it's a goal right what's wrong
with me why I'm always trying to yeah
that acid turmoil that's really crazy
and how should Rey best defend this
position should he be playing Queen E4
should he be playing maybe King G2 Queen
D3 I don't know it's difficult I mean it
really is very very difficult Queen D3
would provoke Knight F6 I guess and
create some counter chances yeah Knight
F6 and now E4 E4 in order to defend the
H3 Pawn
and I guess squares at the center as
well H5 Rook C7 yeah H5 is an idea but
also you have to start worrying about
ideas of Knight H7 Knight G5 Knight E6
Knight F4
um two pieces are two pieces
there are sometimes Queen D5 ideas yes
yes no absolutely it's uh well once you
Rook is it yes exactly seven and if
Knight wants to move so H5 Rook C7 so
ideas of Queen B3 it's not like you can
just crush me nicely yes industry yes
will be uh unpleasant and if you go
Knight to here Knight to G5 maybe I can
make a counter strike against the pawn
but after after this uh time control has
reached maybe it's time to take a break
and once more encourage our audience to
channel a challenge yes panel uh it'd be
maybe your last chance unless we get
some playoffs but in the meanwhile we'll
see on the other side of the brain
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
and we are here for this last round of
the USGS championships Fabiano Caravan
is on the first place with eight and a
half points in New York Dominguez with
seven and a half points both of them
finish their games by the way exactly
Andre Robson is still playing as you can
see against uh Jeffrey Jean and Wesley
stories also keeps playing at the moment
so um I wonder link just made a draw
with Hans Neiman nice and I've also been
told that Tata has a won her game so a
nice way to finish her tournament a huge
game going on between Ray Robson and
Jeffrey and we just left it at the
moment with the move King G2 and we
really think that it's even though it's
materially balanced Rook versus Bishop
Knight rookampon versus bishop and
Knight we do feel that after this move
H5 well rather just the two Bishops
versus The Rook is very terrible for
Jeffrey okay this one is looking good
for Jeffrey yeah exactly but back over
to you Christian because we have guests
not yet oh I'm sorry I thought we were
going to get uh uh we got some chess to
go
yes so first of all after H5 let's look
at what Ray is facing I mean his King is
simply more vulnerable than Black's King
and this bishop is ready to uh go check
depending on how you play for example
after the move H5 let's say you want to
take it yes okay now a moment ago if I
played Bishop Jack you were ready to
match meet me with the move E4
Jack there's no more
and suddenly your king this is what I
meant about uh uh whites pardon me
blacks whites King being exposed uh you
can't you're gonna have to move your
king but yeah
where I go yeah you can't leave F2
hanging that's amazing and H3 also it's
hanging if I move to G1 yes
this is this one yes yes if you move to
G1 this is what I meant why the bishop
why the white king is more vulnerable
after age five so what do we need to
play after age five more like can I have
to defend the G4 Pawn somehow so right
24 yeah 24 years so that is if Knight F6
I have Queen E5 at least at least yes
okay I'll take on G4 you could still
take on G4 of course and you still have
those similar threats as you did a
moment ago including Bishop D5 and
that's the big problem right now if you
take on G4 I don't even have to
recapture back I can go Bishop D5 first
don't like it right and you go F3 I I go
Queen takes G4 then okay and also the
Rook is also it's it's finito it's all
good
oops oh that's some nice geometry right
yes King F2 94.
a nice block of uh pieces
I'll have to go King here but uh still
it feels like uh Rey is definitely in
big big trouble raising trouble uh what
about our ladies
our ladies are you know still as
Jennifer Jennifer is making some strides
in her game she's just played the move
D5 D4 and that's a huge move because
eventually this Pawn on you don't want
to do it but you can understand that
this Rook will suddenly have great life
in this move F2 well okay yeah
yeah it's it's starting to get really
really bad you know what the funny part
is yes about this position is that Talia
is having her best position in like 30
moves yes really yes it was so bad
sometimes ago bad but right now she has
some chances if she finds this move Rook
C3
okay
right Rook C3 yeah okay that's after
this move it's a bit of a funny move yes
but I do have some a half of a threat
that is to take on D4 right and then
open up the rook and trade the Rooks off
and actually just win a pawn like that
so you have to be a bit careful after C3
you have to find it it takes D4 yes yes
I have to say I've seen some funny moves
in my life like really really peculiar
but that one has to be up there in terms
of moves I and the problem for black is
that you cannot play D3 you would love
to play D3 what can I just take on D3
yes of course because now I have three
okay takes F3 actually I can and then
this is definitely yeah this is
definitely the best for a win now yeah
exactly right this is the definitely the
best position that Talia would have had
for some time Rook C3 again that move I
mean it's just beautiful in a way right
right so if she finds this move I'm sure
Jennifer will be a little bit confused
at least yes yeah well I'm just going to
be upset then she could drop her Rook
back I mean the threat that you wanted
to take uh and to take on F3 I just get
my Rook out of Dodge that can't be that
bad uh either yes
all right and again the game of Anna
well there I mean it's all about how
white is going to make progress for the
progress it's got to be based on the
little incremental slow slow moves you
know you just improve here you improve
there and for Ana it's going to be very
difficult she's got to worry about
threats of H5 maybe she even has to
worry in these positions of threats of
E4
and now I think Christian is ready to to
take on his guest Christian over to you
we are indeed with a Wonder Liang a
Wonder first of all congratulations a
very tense finish for you in this game
against Hans but a successful campaign
here at the USA championships yeah I
think the tournament overall went
um really well um by my standards and I
think I started out with this loss
against elshon in round two but after
that I went undefeated
um plus three with white so yeah really
way more than anything I could have
expected
um going in I just kind of want to
finish in the middle of the pack like
maybe with an even score but but yeah
somehow my opponents kept giving me
these chances and I didn't even like
take all of them but yeah I mean what I
had was was my best US championships
ever and like I don't know it's just
really quite surreal at this moment and
how is uh homework going on now on there
did you catch up with your schoolwork
um no where we had quite a bit but yeah
we can talk about that at a future time
right now I'd rather really rather not
think about it no confessions
absolutely but your professors must be
quite happy with uh the way you have
performed here and you were mentioning
at the beginning of the show when we had
our first interview that you were in
close contact with some of your
professors right um I have a professor
friend that studies chess um but
unfortunately he's he's not one of my
professors in the classes I'm taking so
I haven't been getting a lot of slack
from from the professors that create my
work but uh but it's fine yeah how about
today's game uh Hans came up with this
idea of Queen to E2 did you expect this
or no yeah I mean I was I was quite
scared for today's game because I think
nepo had this observation that Hans
typically likes to announce his
comebacks before he makes them
um about three days ago he announced
that he was about to make a cutback that
I see he wins three in a row and I'm
like wait a minute like I played him in
the last round like what's what's going
on here and yeah I knew he just wanted
to get a big fight like I'm lower rate
than him and like okay what I think what
he got was probably not the greatest
position
um but basically he wanted to keep it
closed and avoid a lot of Trades I think
um
just like for this event like my
strategy has sort of been to keep the
positions relatively simple
um I think like in the whole term I've
probably only played like two or three
middle games actual middle games most
night games go like straight to the end
game and I think it's helped me conserve
energy and just like I blunder less
um with you know with schoolwork and all
that so it's kind of my strategy going
into the tournament but here like I
thought like okay his position is so bad
that like I don't even care if um if
it's like a complicated middle game but
I think like his strategy really worked
out because yeah almost immediately I
think maybe yeah somewhere around the
middle maybe after F4 let's take a look
at what yeah
okay uh I wonder you had we were talking
about you needed to make yeah I think
like this queen D7 Queen C7 was a little
sloppy first of all like probably even
Queen C7 immediately because I think F5
is not even such a big threat
and then
yeah I thought Pierre maybe we're back
you're back okay that was fast
um I got here maybe yeah instead of
Queen D7 like okay I can just go Queen
C7 immediately instead of Queen
um all the way here yeah yeah and then
okay like she can do the same thing like
play Knight F3 but
um because I went like Queen D7 Queen C7
yeah and then yeah okay here I have like
F5 ideas or even like what I had in the
game with F6 is not so bad
um but I sort of just allowed his Knight
to come to E1 which I just missed and
yeah here yeah I definitely should have
just went Bishop F7 or something like
this um after 94. at least it's more
consistent with my plan and the idea is
like F5 G5 I lock up
um or if he goes F5
um then I have G5 Knight F3 B5 and I
think I'm quite fast on the queen side
yes at least this was kind of my
impression it feels awesome yeah and
yeah okay it's quite complicated I was
feeling good here um but yeah after G5
like okay he looked at me a little funny
like okay it's kind of typical for him
to do it I realized like oh crap he has
a style of five and yeah yeah sort of
yeah it was kind of my nightmare because
like I wasn't focusing so well
throughout this event and basically I
just severely blundered
um yeah and here again I thought I
should go Bishop H7 instead of Bishop G6
because I think yeah
okay yeah again like I didn't realize
that one was fine as well yeah yeah I
think not a big uh change yeah I didn't
see if Bishop takes D3 that's actually a
horrendous Miss but I think right yeah
it's been quite typical of my play this
event where like I think I'm quite fine
if the position is very simplified like
we get into some sort of end game
um but yeah and these middle games like
my form is is really just terrible like
I'm blundering everything which you guys
kind of did at this point right but yeah
here here I kind of felt like I was fine
like there's quite a bit of compensation
for the pawn and
yeah I mean it's it's a normal position
like I think with the two Bishops I
thought even I could get a little
ambitious but yeah we just trade
everything and I think he defended this
well and then okay I had to find some
macro moves and it was more or less
normal
I wonder congratulations uh for your
performance guys any questions for a
wander uh yes well first of all again uh
congratulations to you I wonder I
watched you struggling at the U.S junior
Champion you come in as the wild card
and you play like you belong
what was the difference between your
play in the U.S junior and your playing
the U.S Championship you played really
good here yeah no I think there's kind
of a few big differences I think in the
Juniors
um I first of all I had five blacks and
like a lot of my black games were
against some of the stronger players and
I really felt like I needed to push in
those games and
it was it was quite difficult because
like some of these Juniors like that
they're really strong and I learned that
the hard way unfortunately
um of course I had like my fair share of
blunders but I think yeah in the Juniors
I sort of didn't really come in with the
right strategy
um I was playing all these very
complicated middle games
um some of them I was getting tactically
outplayed and some of them like I just
blundered
um really badly in the late stage and
here I thought like I don't really feel
like I'll have enough energy to play
really long games every game or just
like these complicated positions where I
need to think a lot and
I decided like I made some changes to my
opening reporter so like first of all
um with white I had like several
contingencies just in case there was
school work or I was really busy like
basically I couldn't force a draw with
white against any player
um and with black like basically yeah I
wanted to make sure that like I kept it
really simple
um as I said like a lot of end games a
lot of very simple chests so that like I
knew that in these sort of complicated
positions that I have a tendency to just
blunder a lot just because I'm quite
Rusty and you know like mentally I don't
I didn't feel like I would have enough
energy especially late in the tournament
um but yeah what ended up happening in
this event at least was was yeah most of
my I think I outprepared my opponents in
nearly every game and I got like the
simplified positions that I thought felt
like I could play really well and yeah
luckily you know I managed to avoid at
least the worst blenders I think in
especially some of the late games um I
did start blundering a little bit but
yeah the positions were well within the
boundary days of at least equality so it
didn't end up that badly sounds like you
really did a lot of work on your
openings and you got you achieved the
type of positions you wanted Anastasia
any questions for a Wonder or great
performance yes yes I just want the task
which game you are proud of the most
after this event which gave you like the
most
yeah probably the game against Fabiano I
think is basically my best game of the
event I mean obviously I made plenty of
mistakes but it's
it's like it's probably been the most
difficult it was the most difficult game
of my life because like just the amount
of pressure that you face
um even like I got like all my
preparation basically and like the
engine said like triple zeros after it
so I was like okay like uh with this Pet
Shop like it's amazing
um but but like then you start to feel
like you know these 2750 2800 guys like
they put so much pressure and like just
to be able to defend that position for
so long and after five five six hours
like that's probably the best game I've
ever played in my life even I mean not
just not like from an objective
standpoint but just like
I mean like it's hard to describe like
when you're like sitting across the
board from this guy like it's just so so
intense um it's like the most difficult
game I've ever played
um and I was definitely lost at some
point or like several points
um but yeah even just to hold that like
I don't know after the game I felt so
tired I like I couldn't even like move
or anything like I just laid in my bed
for a few hours I had this like minor
headache
um it was just such a such a tough game
and yeah I was very glad that I managed
to hold
this is when you play against Fabiana
this is what happens actually yes but
I'm so surprised and even kind of
shocked that you didn't pick up the game
against Levon but we picked this game
yes it also shows something let's say
about the way you think right yeah it
was a good game against Lavon but yeah
again like going into the tournament
um I had like four players which like I
was just trying to hold against and like
you know like Fabiano
um Lavon Wesley and Dominguez and I felt
yeah against Levon like basically I
played this very solid line and he could
have forced to draw but
um yeah okay he he over pushed basically
or he really felt like he wanted to get
a game so I don't feel like it's as much
of an achievement from my part just
because I don't know he like
yeah it was it was kind of a surprise to
win this game
um but against Fabiano like just
yeah I just felt so so tired after this
game like yeah it's probably really one
of the best games I've ever played okay
great thank you so much absolutely once
again our congratulations uh to you
under very very nice result indeed let's
jump uh immediately to the game of Ray
Robson because
my understanding is things are just
going
um a little bit bad to worse F2 F3 well
that's uh weakening uh the king side uh
this looks big moment right now though
yes it has to find the move Knight to B6
Knight B6 which is a little bit off
right right it doesn't feel like you're
supposed to go in that direction you
want to play Knight F6 or something like
that yeah of course you want to play
Knight F6
The Rook The Rook wants to go to C7 so
you want to close the Rook off if the
Rook goes to C7 you could also go Queen
to here yes but if the Knight is on C4
well it stops the rook and you're
eyeballing this E3 Pawn which is an
immediate Checkmate right like if I have
been like for example Knight B6 Rook
here Knight D5 oops no but this is truly
very counterintuitive
Yes actually you have to go Queen d8 no
what what 95 okay first of all why not
why you can play yes and yes and queen
yes yes so you have to go Queen D oh
this is so careful no it's very
counterintuitive how can you find if he
finds this I mean it's just incredible
level of play but this is nice it's
beautiful because you're you you're
attacking The Rook with a gain of a
Tempo and you're ready to play Knight to
D5 and pardon me Knight to C4 yes and
that would just be it's all about
minimizing the counter chances coming
from White species active pieces right
okay I would bet on this at this moment
like that he will not find it unless
curse be very careful yes the moment the
moment you you make a definitive
declarative statement yes boy I gotta
tell you that is when you're really in
danger but I tell you this movement
Knight B6 the moment you see it you
radiate it like yeah it has this really
really great appeal the problem is
everybody wants to play Knight F6 and E4
as soon as possible just to blow up
White's King site but you know what now
once you see it you start understanding
especially this move Queen to d8 it
makes some sense if you look at it
because your queen on H4 doesn't
actually have a good way to invade but
via d8 and going to D2 that's a great
way to invade yeah you can tell me you
can try to yeah
not not very convincing yeah but no
Queen
this is very nice it's great and if you
go like Queen to c14 words no I hate
this computer's reading
incredible I mean they find all these
crazy moves I I love this expression
from
Carlson Magnus was asked by a journalist
do you play against computers not really
well why not it's depressing exactly
exactly what I feel like
what did we bet
I heard dinner did you hear dinner
Christian I heard dinner yeah yeah we
got a confirmation thank you Anastasia
that's very good we did we have to wait
for Queen Jade but Knight B6 is already
a step what a what a great move yes by
um Jeffrey I mean okay this is clear 95
uh Knight takes E3 runs into Rook takes
episode seven yes okay I want to
complete this movie exactly it maybe yes
you'll find it simply because there is
no other move exactly exactly but I mean
first of all uh I think Rey spotted it I
think Ray is spotted Rook C7 uh Queen d8
Greg has to make a move because he has
six minutes on the clock right now for
how many what's the time it's already
the second time control so let's say
it's we have 30 minutes until the end of
the game and at the moment you can see
that this is everything what he has six
minutes against 23.
because he saw he saw that the problem
with Brook C7 Queen d8
this is the beautiful this is where why
the night is such a beautiful a beauty
on the C4 Square because it just dropped
stops The Rook from having a life and
then I don't know what's happening if I
play a group D1 okay unfortunately you
just took away my thunder I was about to
say imagine you played it before okay E4
years
oh oh yes no no no a real Royal Fort
coming in but we do have a very special
guest uh a dear friend of ours Christian
is with you they left the door open
again
he snuck in he's snuck in we have
Maurice Ashley in the house Maurice uh
tell us a little bit about uh the U.S
chess championships what is your opinion
on that well it you know it's first of
all it's been fun being here hanging out
with everybody getting to see you all uh
going to dinners with Rex and the like
and getting into arguments with the
arena crushing the whole thing it's been
great the U.S championship of course is
the Premier championship in the world we
have the the best average players at the
high level however uh you know you got
to wonder about the youth movement here
because we're seeing somebody like a
wonder who did really well but he's in
college he's a college student he's a
he's talking like oh I'm just trying to
keep things simple and not blunder you
wonder how much he might stay in chess
eventually you want to see that happen
with somebody that talented really
pursue it we've been waiting for that
breakthrough from from Jeffrey Zhang for
a while he's been at that 2700 custom
he's kind of kind of plateaued there a
little bit and we're hoping to see him
take that next step so we really have to
to hope for more I think because the
average the average age is a little bit
High I mean the average age of our top
five players I I took a look is 34.4
that's the average age of our top five
players and for India the average age of
the top five players including Anand
who's 52 years old is 30 years old so
that's that's significant the youth
movement has has to come and we need to
see the youngsters start to thrive and
we're definitely seeing a very talented
crop of players right now where you have
Sam Savion Jeffrey Sean a wander as you
were mentioning Hans Neiman as well
there's something about this last few
rounds the tension is building up and we
start seeing blunders and things of that
nature sure from your experience as a
commentator is that natural
I think so I think that I actually I
think it's more so though the length of
this tournament we haven't had 13 Rounds
in a while and the players are
definitely feeling the fatigue the
tension the importance of the last few
rounds you see The Savvy vets like Fabi
who say how do we just chill out in the
end and not do anything crazy and take
those draws and let Rey suffer as he
tries to catch me so I think that's
smart uh but you also see somebody like
like Wesley so who didn't start out that
well but given more time the weight
starts to come in and the big dog shows
that he's got real teeth but I I do
think the length has been critical to
the tournament you mentioned those young
players in particular I see I think you
only see the real emergence of Hans
Neiman I mean for for various reasons he
has become a lightning rod of attention
I wonder I'm not really sure what his
intent are like I said it really looks
like he's he's bent on being a student
he really wants I mean he wants to
diversify it's clear get a college
really always nice to have something to
fall back on and also to expand yourself
as a person I think Jeffrey and Sam they
Sam sevillan I mean they've been there
they've been there for a while we've
seen them around this is not their first
rodeo no and we really need to see more
I mean I know they want more we don't
need to put any additional pressure on
them but we really need to see more if
we're going to have see them carry that
mental into the Next Generation in the
next few years speaking of uh Sam
Seville and I'm sure you will love to
talk about this situation did you see
what happened yesterday with the
decapitation of the king it's rare we
get to say those words in chess I mean
you know I would have really pumped that
one up if I was doing this broadcast I
mean come on whoever sees a guy grab the
opponent's key and then rip the top off
yeah okay you didn't quite rip it off I
was like dude my cake no take it in you
want it you can have it wow I'd have
been in absolute shock you try that and
broke good and see what happens let's go
glue it let's go through it
bro bro seriously where's the referee
you better come get this guy fix the
situation that was absolutely hilarious
never seen anything like it I don't
think we're gonna see anything like it
for a long time ago no I don't think so
either guys any questions yes
Anastasia you first I've got like five
just a second I've been writing go on
okay no I just have one comment like
every time Maurice comes to the city to
the town something happens
[Laughter]
yes I don't know what's going on here
but it's clear that it's good maybe
there is some connection Maurice come on
let's face it the U.S Championship the
creme de La Creme of the United States
very respectable tournament and somehow
we got on this wrong track and it it's
crazy crazy what what why why what what
happened I mean it's something strange
going on I don't know what to tell you I
mean it does seem as though after what
happened with with Hans uh it's all
going off the rails everybody is
sensitive I mean you remember you made a
mistake uh in your comments in your
commentary doing one of the games where
castling was illegal right it was a
hilarious moment you know it was fun yes
it was just all in good fun so I decided
to post about it uh who they let this
guy they actually paid this guy for GM
commentary right and of course this guy
is like one of my best friends so no big
deal take it in stride man the number of
people who got on your side and and
thought that I was a supreme jerk making
a joke about my my good buddy it's like
people
apologies
as much stuff as you said about me
[Laughter]
condescending to your fellow commentator
yeah no he's Christian get out of here
we've been having a lot of fun and
there's a lot of misinterpretation of a
lot of things that are happening here
absolutely even when even when good
friends are are having so I'm curious as
to that sensitivity I'm wondering if
it's real sensitivity or is it people
feel that they need to just simply be
obnoxious
or amplify you know a little thing
happens and all of a sudden it turns
into a conflagration and you're like
whoa what happened here I just think
it's the age we live in look we had a
lot of fun here in the studio and I said
the Asura and Anastasia were having a
lot of fun and a lot of laughs as well
even even everybody all the viewers
notice how much respect they had from my
colleagues here yes okay no I gotta jump
in Marie so you know you watched the
whole videotape right and the whole the
king and the the cross and here you can
have your king
then Han Hans comes in and he explains
what was said oh your cross let's go
glue it come on together we can leave
and we can go glue I mean I don't know
if you lip read but boy that was not my
interpretation of that conversation
is that the way you saw it as well let's
have a friendly discussion no no no no
that wasn't friendly at all he's not I
mean Hans has been living in New York
for a couple of years New Yorkers don't
talk like that you're in Brooklyn you
just grab my cake bro like what you
doing right I'm gonna be fighting words
right there uh fight you know that
there's no way and you saw him looking
at him like he was yes great gray
there's no way in the world they were
they were being genteel gently let's go
glue the Kings
look at that look bro what are you doing
right right that was just uh wow so uh
have you ever had this kind of fights
over the chess board or because of
something what happened on the
chessboard I mean not you but maybe we
see it I'm a lover not a fighter like no
I I've never had a fight although I have
seen stuff happen at the board and
certain kind of language which we cannot
have on this air right absolutely has
happened uh growing up like I said in BK
um
you know people get heated people get
emotional and the trash talking starts
and you know but I've never seen a
decapitated
exactly pick up your tickets right now I
mean Christian's gonna be dancing on the
dance floor no we don't want to see that
Maurice the statement is that and dude I
I got a discount for you it's like I got
a five percent discount friends and
family those 25 tickets yes everybody
can yes you're so nice yeah like I'm
going out on the limb for a year buddy I
think I'm on the list I think I'm okay
okay good to see you thank you for
joining us Maurice thanks guys enjoying
uh the show
um boy we still got some huge important
games going on here and especially in
the Ladies as a Arena Crush
with a victory clinches her ninth title
and I want to get this right that would
tie her with gasella yes aggressor for
the only woman in the United States to
win nine titles so it's a very
historical moment for American women
women's chest precisely so and she is
doing a very nice job in my opinion uh
is Arena I love these positions for
white and one of the things that I think
a lot of people don't understand about
the the queen is the queen should get an
award
as the best supporting actress okay what
I mean by that is the queen should be in
the back
should not be in the front Okay and in
this position this is an ideal example
of what I mean by the best supporting
actress what is your best setup Rook on
D4
Queen on D2 and once you get once you
see that the Rook on the the queen is
going to be supporting this Pawn you get
this idea of okay there's going to be
this nice exactly that there's going to
be these E4 and there's going to be this
nasty nasty pin on the D file so I think
that arena is doing a really really
great job not that she's winning
immediately but it's it's the way to go
pressure yeah I'm not and maybe also the
time is the clock as well and so I
really like what arena is doing now on
the other hand
the two ladies on board too I put it
like that Jennifer and um
please on a draw uh get get a result
well honestly because Jennifer two
minutes on our clock though yes that's
what I felt like I probably did that
Irene also puts pressure around on clock
right now she's playing very well Irina
yes and this position Jennifer has been
well more or less than the opening had a
very good position but this position is
again just like the same
so many pawns already were traded but
okay so imagine that uh black just plays
a rook here moves her King and then just
takes a pawn
uh which one H4 H1 okay yeah uh but I I
want to make sure that the pump excuse
my apologies for that I want to make
sure that the E4 Pawn is like over
protected like I don't want to allow
Rook takes uh E4 Knight takes E3 but
just to play
and a last round game Wesley so is
better against Sam sevillion but no
longer completely winning that we
thought he was really made the drop with
um
and I thought that a Wonder had the
better position there at a certain
moment in the game and over to you uh
Christian uh what do you think about our
uh all-important Arena Crush very very
cool game by Irina right now and let's
see if she plays this next move because
she's been improving her position
steadily every little maneuver right
right Queen D4 Queen D2 route to D4 and
now she has another chance to improve
her position with this move Bishop to A4
4. Bishop to A4 forces the move B5 of
course then I go back and now you have
another thing to worry about your uh
King is weaker than it was a move ago
and this increases the pressure in the
position all of her pawns are on the
light squares all of Black's pawns are
on the light squares and that's going to
be problematic in any ensuing end game
I'm really liking what arena is doing
right now she has another opportunity to
increase the pressure with the move
Bishop to A4 and take a look at the time
two minutes and 12 seconds for Anna
zatonski and she doesn't like her
position in 17 minutes all the time in
the world and she played it yes by the
way it's very interesting that after she
plays B5 Bishop goes to BC there is a
threat to play E4 now because now the
difference precisely maybe I don't know
still only six Queen will take maybe not
with a king on A2 but you can improve
that after King to A1 put the King on
dark swears and then we'll play E4 yes
trying to use the fact that now uh also
there will be some checks on D4 if Rook
takes on D4 and some variations
another weakness and it helps that Arena
will be working with right wow this was
really nice move like Bishop before
provoking I was only like an expert
player when I understood why the move
Bishop A4 was such a good move there
because uh I was one of those players
who thought that when I moved my pawns
forward I was doing good yes like
getting it closer to promotion but in
this case what uh Bishop A4 does is it
it forces the move B5 and this idea of
creating weaknesses that the pawns when
they Advance they leave behind weak
squares
A5 C5 or weekend which means that maybe
one day a queen would arrive on an A5 or
maybe one day The Rook will arrive on C5
and you won't like it uh the move Bishop
B3 by the way for me I it it's okay
there's nothing wrong with the move
Bishop uh B3 but at this moment I'm
starting to think what would be the
ideal Square for White's King is G2
better than A2
Arena has such a grip on the position
it's like she can almost afford to make
a very slow all the way over and put her
King on G2 uh but the move Bishop B3 is
fine but that kind of says to me as long
as Black's Queen stays on the C file
you're just gonna play King A2 now what
you guys were just talking about
yeah it's like uh King A1 and here is E4
yeah this is your tactic and Bishop
takes C6 and if you take Rook D4 if you
try to make the intermediate move I also
have one Queen D4 Check Yes exactly
you're not in time to take the bishop
and that will cost a piece we do have
King B6 by the way on this board so what
is the difference I think still we can
play King game one right and uh what
happens well I think it's time for for
what for for black to get out of the
threat of e3 E4 so the difference will
be that if we still play E4 you take a
take on the six yeah just to show no
longer check it's no longer check so
Rook D4 you have to take with the queen
and then black recapture the bishop you
didn't achieve anything yeah
actually it's not good so I now Arena
needs to to figure out
her best setup and what she should do
maybe we can still play four and take a
seven Pawn what do you think about this
idea yes we don't take E4 but we take on
G7 take and something
oh b55 yes you see I'm so I'm so
concentrated yeah
okay so this
uh what what about this ending I see it
very nice for white I mean again it's
like one of those endings that can only
be uh two results uh everything is it
enough to win because if you want to go
you you really need to be sure right
normally exactly the only thing what I
can understand about the sending the
topones are on the white squares which
for sure favors white precisely another
Rule and I think this was actually from
a book by Michael chishin okay and it
was a very nice book yeah Adrian he had
made a book for the fide it was for the
fide trainers in fact so this is a book
that fide produces that says hey if you
want to become a senior trainer you
gotta know you have to read all this
articles
so there was two stresses that Adrian
was making stress number one
patient patient when you're in an end
game play it slowly there's no rush when
you're winning don't you know go
overboard make forcing moves second
try to create two weaknesses in the
position so we understand we've got one
weakness let's try to make a second
weakness I like your idea of E4
transferring into Bishop only game how
about F3 what's the idea let me just
make a bad move
if you do this if you do help me by
trading this is immediately you start
running with this phone and then at the
moment black tries to it's a decoy right
I I will crash through on D5 so I liked
your suggestion very much of just hey
look go go E4 uh trade Rooks trade
Queens take the pawn and maybe I would
yes
or yes it's better but the method that
Adrian was pushing which was look for an
opportunity to create a second weakness
now in this case F3 and G4 appeal to me
in an in another set of circumstance the
second weakness might have been to be to
play for A4 create a weakness on B5 put
your Bishop on D3 you understand yes the
concept of just making more troubles for
your opponent I think in general this
quality to be patient I don't know how
to learn it but it's like one of the
most important things in order to do
it's really difficult I mean I
understand all this the other thing when
you have your game you still try to make
all this quickly I want to win quickly
so the fact that Irina puts so much
pressure and shows actually with slow
moves in a way she did she didn't play
King A1 with that idea of E4
A4 okay second week yes so but at the
same time that's why my question was
if I was going to play A4 my king would
be on G2 if I'm playing A4 and a b I'm
starting to wonder who is
why did I expose my own King so A4 we'll
keep an eye on this and Christian back
over to you how about Ray Robinson let's
take a look at what's happening in Talia
just before we go to Ray Robson because
right now Talia versus Jennifer Talia is
a pawn up and finally one of her Rooks
at least is getting some play in the
game right the problem is that I also
managed to bring my knight to the attack
and after Knight to G6 Knight takes H4
is coming and it seems like this is not
going to be pretty for uh Talia also
ideas of Knight to F4 followed by E3
take advantage that after the move
Knight to F4 my Pawn on D3 is protected
and you cannot take on E3 because you
lose the Knight on G3 a lot of threats
in the position and of course you cannot
touch this one on H5 because of Knight
to F4 you lose the Rook on H5 so big
moment right now and big move for Johnny
for Knight to G G6 this would pretty
much seal the deal at this point
okay let's go to rate because Ray is
down to his last three minutes as well
so maybe we can keep an eye on that one
absolutely uh I know we have
a very interested spectator and one
Fabiana
for sure that guy the guy who's in The
Dugout he's like waiting for outcome
Queen C7 by Jeffrey with a rather
straightforward threat E5 E4 discovered
check and there goes the queen now
having said that what's his follow-up if
I go King back to G2 uh does he want to
play H4 I don't know I wouldn't suspect
so
um yeah I see the threat of uh Queen t7
Christian and I'm not sure is there
another one I just moved my J2 okay King
to G2 no I'm saying that he so not this
before yeah yeah he played King G2 he
did play yeah he played King G2 now with
the queen on C7 can I start getting
ready to go H4 followed by E4 yeah that
was my question should he be playing for
H4 I mean if I managed to get before on
the board I think I'm doing quite well
yeah I bet it hmm
it it's
it's like I thought you wanted to play H
five and you wanted to break break up
the king side not to
close it yes but if you break it up also
my Rook gets some sort of deployment in
the position let's say I crawl away
if you go here then you give me a check
yeah and then I'm gonna play F4 keeping
things locked down
right right so maybe I have to prepare
it maybe I have to go King H7 first
after King F2 oh sorry you still like H4
why not let's King F maybe H7 or H6 I'm
100 sure where right by the way four is
on the board H4 is on the board okay and
I guess I've got to get out of the the
thread of E4
you know again I'm going to my intention
is to meet E4 with F4 whether
hmm
still still a lot of work to do so now I
go Queen D6
I'm saying that finally I took over the
D file that's an important file
there's not going to be a big tactic it
seems like right it's just going to be a
slow in which I'm taking more and more
important squares from your position
from your possession as well exactly I
can easily imagine you playing G5 and E4
and what is happening by the way in the
Wesley so game I mean Wesley would be
making a dramatic return actually yes if
he wins the game loses he's putting some
pressure but that one is not that
important right I think we should stay
with this okay Rey versus Jeffrey game
this is the title
there's a there's a title on the line
right and by the way he didn't play King
F2 uh he he played instead Rook D1 Rook
D1 uh
uh not worrying about Knight B2 because
of Queen d
6 and or queen d8 so Queen D6 Queen C2
and then Rook D2
seems to be the Saving Grace
check
and whoops I'm just doing fine just in
position all right so now we should
you're trying to go Queen d8 right and
you're saying that that end game maybe
it's okay for you
this is once again that uh position and
maybe in this exact position well no
Queen hangs my Pawn what about this idea
of playing Bishop D5
Bishop D5 something we looked at it
probably forces you to go E4 almost
right
does it
I have funny ideas of taking on F3 and
going E4 I guess it's fun actually I'm
not sure if they work but they look
funny yeah some Queen just me after I
don't even know what I do for a pass by
the way to allow you to do that let's
let me make a terrible move and you have
this huh I I don't think it actually
works but
they look like something okay yes
even though I still have Queen H2 even
in that position
industry King D3 Knight B2
but then even at the end you have some
Queen E7 Queen H1 we're going to give
Checkmate yeah yeah
unnecessary yeah necessary right very
good all right well there's definitely
okay
still
something you know some labor important
now remember uh having slipped having
the victory let's say slip away from his
grasp and tying for first and forcing
the playoff Ray is thinking look a draw
would be great and I take clear second
and life will be really really really
wonderful this happens sometimes yes for
everybody yeah
um
so now it's Jeffrey who is thinking at
this moment so it's time a factor for
Jeffrey I know it's always around I
think six minutes and 30 seconds on his
clock maybe we can see it five minutes
never mind and three 329.
okay okay if I'm in if I'm in um
Jeffrey shoes the move I desperately
want to play of course is E4 but the
problem with E4 is check and then
shutting things down with F4 so one move
that definitely comes into my mind is
this idea of playing G5 so that when I
do play E4 and you give me a check and I
move my king I'm not sure where I should
move my queen you're not going to play
F4 maybe
I'll still play and take on the floor
but it feels like G5 weekends
like Queen E4 now
Chief okay then finally you stop me all
together for playing E4 by playing Queen
no any check on the seventh rank is
almost a mate if I manage to do that
right you know I feel a bit uneasy in my
King's position with the King okay so
you like the pawn on G6 as a protection
whoa what E4 okay E4 well this is force
check well 94 has to be played yeah that
is just a force because again anything
that allows Queen G3 check which is
shy away from that's just so yeah let's
try to calculate it check King has to go
probably F7 right F7 fine I was I'm not
sure I was I was going out of this
question so many moves I'm really not
sure you want to go there okay I want to
keep a queen F6 uh at Bay I don't want
you to have Queen F6 Queen H4 ideas okay
so after King F7 F4 as white I'm feeling
a lot happier that this Pawn is on e4
where quite frankly I think it's
vulnerable one thing I can do is
exchange the Queens right
maybe Queen B6 Queen B6 yes you would
like to trade Queens by Queen B6
it's an idea in the position and now
that's why I also wanted to take and
maybe if you play rugby six four then
okay six if you give the spawn on the
street it's bad yes
not so clear at all
so let's see Queen to D4 we're expecting
sequence history why what is the
difference
we did not anticipate that no because
then Queen B6 will be can be unpleasant
because okay that's just for the moment
just say King F7 because we're again
we've got this oh crushing we need five
wait
to go Queenie
[Music]
friend Queenie so what happens if
instead of King F7
Queen
so oh that's a completely different
approach by Jeffrey so he just maybe
wants to say this is winning award we do
take on a four or you play F4 I don't
know and then if we kind of get that
same ending that we just spoke about
with the queen on B6 and instead of
having the pawn on F4 they're doubled
that's that's an interesting approach by
Jeffrey yes it takes yes no I just
wonder if he'll play a four or he takes
the C4 Pawn
well it's still a poem the problem with
F4 is that after night yeah it's not so
easy for you to take this Pawn either
keeping in mind that there will you you
would have to preface preface it pardon
me with uh King F2 and Rook D4 Rook
takes E4 that's going to be a lot of
moves in the meanwhile Knight takes
night night takes so what do we do well
I have to take on e4 yeah yes it feels
like this that you kind of oh wait wait
what no never mind
don't leave us hanging dude what was the
great move what was the idea
it was a very bad move
Anastasia as uh as our uh broadcast of
13 broadcasters he's 13. Championship
rounds are coming to a close it's time
to give thanks to a lot of people
there's no way these broadcasts would
have happened if not for Rex and Genie
of course absolutely right off the top
they they're philanthropy their support
is just fantastic and we just say thank
you thank you thank you yes we really
appreciate everything
here secondly the club the club and the
staff everybody at the St Louis chess
club in Scholastic Center I mean you
come in they're friendly what can we do
for you how can we help you you need
this and this and this it's just so it's
so wonderful absolutely they make sure
that everything will go really great
also in terms of the event right I mean
there's an organization Tony Rich is
whole staff Ryan Chester everybody Caleb
thank you thank you all yes and even and
even
I was doing uh commentaries uh for the
Grand Master res and Ben Simon would be
there at each of those and recording and
uploading and so there's so many people
we'd like to thank are that coordinator
Rebecca of course so many people who
were behind the scenes exactly also
Vanessa West who was a journalist for
this event and who was doing Recaps and
she was taking care of social media yeah
of course so who who is else well the
Silverback and Spectrum
Studios The Producers yes and all of the
people behind the scenes uh you know we
have the Kevin then Brian Adams and
Marcus and yeah yeah Megan our graphics
editor you see the beheading of the king
exactly that was really really really
nice and uh again
it's just that it's one thing you know
you kind of come to work
but no you come to work here and it's
like you're enthusiastic yeah well you
enjoy it this time yes awesome also all
the team who works here right exactly
yeah and Finn uh getting our coffees and
making with everything yeah yeah yeah
and again uh to our audience for uh
shouting out and telling us we're doing
a good job and that the team chemistry
is working and yes you know there is
some respect here and stuff like that
let's not go too far I mean no no but
many many comments actually during this
event I would say that the social media
again I mean many many people started to
follow the accounts many comments also
on YouTube channel you can find all the
interviews which we had during this
period of time so many people were
watching also the interviews if they
didn't catch them during the broadcast
right so it's very important I would
like also to thank you yes sir it's so
many lessons I learned I mean literally
I have a feeling that my understanding
has improved and let's see
[Music]
and say for Christians I wanted to say
uh thank you Anastasia I mean you get
thrown in right deep end with uh
Christian and I and you come in every
day with a big smile you're very
enthusiastic so thank you because it's
such a pleasure to be a commentator in
one of the best Nations maybe the best
national championship right U.S
Championship is really all we always
were following them even I was not here
I always really liked what was happening
and lots of fights really great prices I
told Yasser also that when I was like 10
15 years ago when women started to get
this crazy amount of money you know ten
thousand for the first price I thought
maybe it's time to change the
citizenship again the green party those
are like really great Support also to
women players and they will appreciate
it as well as big fan of women's chess
myself and finally and this is very
important a big shout out to the players
I mean it our job as commentators is so
much easier when everybody is fighting
fighting really really hard and and
playing for a win and the large number
of decisive games yes give us something
to talk about if everybody's just
playing berlins and making a draw this
would not be a funny event to call so a
big shout out to the players and lastly
and low man on the totem pole I mean you
know the podcaster himself I can't
believe it you were wonderful it was it
was great you would come in every day
with a big smile as well and dancing for
us you know the dancing just this one
time
well that was a little bit weird I don't
know if you felt uncomfortable but I
but Christian you were wonderful thank
you thank you so much and thank you guys
yeah I had a lot of fun working with you
too I think the chemistry was good I
really enjoyed it and the games have
been wonderful and actually let's talk
about the games
I just wanted to say let's talk about
the games this one is about to be over
the game between Talia and Jennifer you
because I mean Jennifer you just invaded
the king only two D2 is coming E3 is
coming as well you cannot move the Rook
from the h file because you get checked
mainly
so if you move the Rook anywhere oh Rook
D5 for example is Checkmate in two moves
Rook H3 followed by Rook to a position
and of course this is over E3 is coming
yes it's it looks really winning you
don't want to go D1 and get only one
Rook for your labor no no no no you want
to get much more than that you go E3
right now exactly
and that there's a lot of pressure guys
on Irena who really needs to win this
one but otherwise it's a playoff we'll
we'll we'll we'll go through the mutual
admiration all over again tomorrow
please
actually yes that would be terrible that
would be terrible uh by the way that E3
move I think that's just a clincher by
the way there's no way I'm playing D1
here I'm looking at King F2 and yeah
Again Jennifer what a roller coaster
unbelievable what a roller coaster it
doesn't matter how she finds the
strengths you know to come back and just
play like nothing happened the day
before I mean after surgery now I would
it would take months for me to come back
to normal right wow wow great wow and
there's a lot of pressure on Irina right
now who I'm not sure if she's winning or
anything of that nature or Anna is
really fighting very hard to hold on to
the draw in this position by the way I
think it's kind of funny because I was
talking a while ago about Arena bringing
her King to G2 you know taking the walk
across the board and getting your king
into safety it's kind of ironic that
actually is the one is is taking the
perp walk here and is that the right
decision because is can we take the
phone that was my question can we take
the ball you can but you know what that
means it means that my Rook is invading
as well and I'm getting
are we sure we want to play this I don't
know it's actually who's better no I I'm
not I'm not sure I would want to go down
this uh path at all anything where I
have to play F4 and you know this Rook
is really really active uh Rook it's
about to go to F3 and maybe I can go
even route to G2 actually well the one
problem unless I'm trapping The Rook
Rook to G2 Rook here
it could be awkward but no I don't think
Arena would be anywhere close to she was
thinking about she's thinking about it
but maybe five and by the way I think
Irina just dropped down to her last
minute as well if not let oh queen queen
I think she just decided to simplify the
position maybe
remember I talked a moment ago about
creating a second can they speak English
that's why don't allow B4 because who
whose weaknesses you know and I think
she's kind of she thought she's winning
this Pawn yes let me just double check
it's that's a very good one no you can't
play King here that's for sure and if
you play King here I won the pawn so the
only move is this right but doesn't that
look a little maybe yeah doesn't the
king look a little bit
a little bit strange I don't know guys
maybe it's already
dangerous wow before I don't know I
don't know maybe after before I have to
go no no you have no choice so for
example you take rugby five maybe I have
to play already King A3 and Bishop A4
and then B3 you know ugly okay what can
I do she's done it before check on the
board and I'm sure Irina missed it I'm
sure one of the one of the strange
problems uh that uh the opponents yes of
Anna zatoski have and I've seen this at
olympiads I've seen this in the U.S
championships Anna runs down on her
clock and the girls are all really happy
oh now that Anna's in time trouble I
will take advantage of her no no no no
way no no no she starts playing even
better with no time on a clock in school
by the way
back in the game as well Ray Robinson is
oh yes oh my gosh what he's not losing
anymore right now what is what okay go
ahead uh to take it away Christian you
want to work through C6 this is what we
have right now Rook C5 is coming I'm
going to pick up the B5 phone if I
managed to pick up the B5 Pawn then I
thought the Knight was going to C2 and
picking up the B4 Pawn I know let's see
we've got G5 on the board yes okay
[Music]
okay I'm just sorry excuse me for doing
this oops I've got the wrong position
I've gotta refresh so we left it after
the queen
and then I thought this was all she
wrote I thought it was coming night to
C2
10 seconds yes
oops he made a move who is how many so
just a few seconds so I thought this was
winning for Jeffrey after Knight C2 you
play King of six Knight C4 and I would
not just missed the win
what I don't understand anything just Mr
winner right now
it seems like oh my goodness Anna might
be back in the game
wow what is going on I think it's just
really A detention the tension is so
high that players started to do some
mistakes simply because it's just it's a
marathon to begin with right it's
already fifth or maybe the end of the
physics
let me check yeah yeah
we ended the fifth hour
we're tired and exhausted after so many
rounds I mean it's a big chance that you
will start to making mistakes
wow from King F2 on the board now
well again I mean I'm just seeing this
move Rook to C5 and how am I going to
deal with this move Rook to C5 I've got
to keep this guy under control I've got
to keep the B5 on and I just played
Knight E5 and he's looking at Bishop C
well don't go Rook C5 now
D3 checks but Rook B6 is forced right B6
be sure to check so probably they will
just trade everything and what's it
don't play this for against yes but that
should be enough for equality right for
I don't know yeah equality for sure uh
oh that's all Ray wants right well I
mean yes but why did Jeffrey why did
Jeffrey go for this whole line because
I thought he was just much better he was
yeah he was he was
maybe not right now in the last couple
of moves but he did have great chances
before well in this ending too I meant
uh even with uh yeah I thought that
after we got here oh in the same game
yeah yeah he he should have played
Knight C2 right so what do you do okay
six still you can play well
but Bishop is hanging so okay six first
and Bishop is before this was the key
yes pick up the before pawn and take it
yes you have a professor so if I try
something like if uh yeah don't forget
my king is actually pretty close I agree
so it sounds like six and yeah we all
stop it but I'll try to move mine wow
chances was a really great chance let me
just refresh because uh pick up that
pawn and take it from there right you
have the passer and then you have real
chances of winning that and once again
our congratulations to Jennifer
who won with black after this these
Championship rounds I mean I I sometimes
you feel they bring out the best in
players but also the worst in players
and what happened in this game of Arena
just a second Let me refresh because you
said she missed a win oh yeah she missed
the win could you go back a few moves
yes before when the King was on D6 keep
going at that point E4 exactly now
exactly at this point E4 first I see
she in fact she included a nice little
extra move and this is where we stand
currently yes
and
this looks fine for blacks it is fine
yes it is because the king is
beautifully centralized guys I think
we're gonna have a playoff we might have
a playoff guys yeah I take all my words
back
apologize I'm sorry it should never have
spoken out of turn but it's still not
over I mean this is the commentators
who's in time trouble both of them oh
okay that makes it simple
but uh Anna is actually on ahead on time
right now she's on two minutes and 14
seconds against 45 seconds for Irina wow
yeah I'm holding my breath yes
can I believe what's going on like okay
if I'm in Honor shoes I want my phone on
A5 I want my Pawn on F6 and I'm gonna go
King E5 and I'm like I've got the draw
clinched and if I get those moves in and
I don't see how arena is gonna be able
to take advantage
if if the bishops come off
then the pawns are perfect
seven seconds really wow so she decided
to take and by the way also a little bit
you know yes that's almost an acceptance
move yes I just accepted the fact that
we're probably going to draw this game
yeah but the it was again this capture
on D5 was not made with alacrity it
wasn't made like she was not happy right
okay but look the time is running I mean
she can just lose like that if she will
not pay attention King 85 14 seconds 10
seconds right now for Irena
and then King D3 probably Bishop takes
D5 Rook takes D5 very good by the way uh
while Irene has been thinking Anna has
been picking up time on her clock and
Arena's gonna be doesn't she have to be
a little careful or am I being making a
mistake she's got the more active King
yeah but you just go King E3
and there's no I'm not taking on D5 no
no no no no no
King C King E3 or King C3 and then I see
if you don't take on D4 then I move my
Rook away yes
so if I play for example move like I
give you checks yeah okay I don't
exchange there right that's what I
wanted to say that that you better not
do this yes
if you want to keep the balance just
yeah so King E5 what about black can
black take on D4
well then the then the thing is then
white has the no position well but also
the uh more active King and that was
what I was trying to avoid so if I'm I'm
honestly
Anastasia is it Anna satonski I'm
playing King E5 yes okay go ahead take
my Rook or yeah or move it away but um
it's taking your time yes
but maybe she is a freaking five I take
taken King before
okay that was a race what about maybe
she's trying to calculate yes uh
probably this I'm probably being way too
slow right yes I think white is better
here takes before
but actually
you know whether you could play five but
no no uh
okay B8 is also check so
by the way just to mention uh Alex
Linderman won his game won his game so
um
right now and uh
Jeffrey are going to make a draw so I
think we're going to have a repetition
and that means we will have a U.S
Champion so maybe we can move to that
one
let's check this game yes it's very
important for the standings right
between Ray Robson and Jeffrey Zhang and
I mean it's a draw in this game means
Fabiano caruana is the 2022 US champion
and also it means that Ray Robson will
be the second and imagine if Ray would
make this draw a long time ago he would
have come to the studio and say oh okay
this draw but I didn't want to risk and
something now that you made the draw
after all what happened you are so happy
you were like oh yeah I made a draw
second place yes it's been an
interesting ride
for Ray well there we go and we do
expect the king F7 King F7
removes Rook to A7
and that means big Miss by Jeffrey huge
mess
did you know what this means what what
it's terrible it means a Christian yes I
know what you want to say no yes
can you believe it I can I can last time
I also choose Fabi and he also won yes I
remember this nine nlx Championship yes
it was more exciting at this moment but
he was not bleeding at all so he came
first on led the last round
Christian I will have to kind of admit
that he won this race
lucky professionals are professionals
yes yes okay actually it's gonna be
second time that Fabi right it's going
to be his second title title the U.S
Champion his very first was after he
well he was born of course here in the
United States but then he went to play
for Italy and then he won four times
back
from Italy in the United States and when
he was eligible for his first U.S
Championship he won and that was back in
2016. 36 years ago so I mean
his second title will be more than
welcome as far as Bobby's concerned and
Fabi has not had a great 2022 not at all
he's had some real problems difficulties
but winning the U.S Championship will
cheer him up a lot washes a lot of
scenes away yes yes Victory does that
doesn't it it washes away the sins
cleanses yeah okay Rook check and how
many times have they reached this
exactly well actually a king seven uh
Jeffrey did not play before so that was
an escape out of repetition I have seven
was his previous move so what's he'll
play Bishop I doubt it I mean Bishop D7
King E4 yes maybe you're starting to
hope maybe you can take on D7 and King
F5 especially if you start I know Pawn
hunting like uh-oh
and trying to go for H3 then I go King
D5 E6 and you might resign
um but once you play this move King to
E8 it feels like wait
is wrote G7 I move now well that's the
that was my next question can I take and
then I go Knight F7 I take on E5 and I
go Knight F7 don't do that maybe it's a
Wall Street don't do that that's the
last trick
these guys man yeah
they're gonna give you every single
chance to mess it up right 907 by the
way not I think the Rook isn't trap but
uh but no need to do this yeah I need to
do this okay by the way rookie check he
played that move with alacrity is time a
factor uh at this exact moment no Rook
okay now there's
there's going to be a repetition right
okay so I think we're about to make a
repetition and then we can officially
congratulate Fabiano on winning
undefeated
the U.S Championship the second time
okay eight
plus four plus four is a nice score
well we when he was plus four after I
don't know round seven because he never
won anything a 2900 result but now maybe
only plus four after round 13 maybe he
just gained a few rating points maybe a
couple apart the title is is what it's
all about of course
yes 60 000 is not bad qualification to
the world cup yep yep
I think you maybe you could could
qualify by rating as well but okay
but I don't remember exactly the rules
do we I mean I'm seeing a lot of rookie
HX how is this not a three-time
repetition I don't know
I think it probably is but none of the
players want to actually call The
Arbiter and give the opponent two minute
on a wrong claim
[Music]
they don't want to give their opponent
the satisfaction that okay I was the one
that asked for it ah
okay okay and still he doesn't claim the
Drone how many times King E7 I see
already like I said I'm coming three
times for sure three times
yes seven three times also yes and
Brooke says seven yes it was the
repetition happened three times already
so I don't know if so they will repeat
five times so let's we'll have will
happen
I saw that once in a game between
Anatoly karpov
and John vanderville okay
we'll claim the car yes but it was the
zaitsev with Knight G5 Rook Cafe three
Rook E8 John Vanderbilt played it four
times and then made another move
unbelievable it was it three times
four-time repetition
Jeffrey is not happening no yeah but I
think both players somehow uh let's say
Ray had some really good prospects at
the moment he he played the move Queen
B1 if he had played Queen A1
uh yes he's disappointed you can see on
his face some emotions finally yes
disappointed but really you bet he got
clear second
and we do have a winner congratulations
father and all his fans yes and
Christian as well
very very painful very very painful very
impressive she has commentary is not
what it used to be
that's a competition nowadays
we're missing we still have one game to
go guys yes we did move to that one
because that was intensifying as well no
no this one I mean we still have a
championship on the line yes we did not
yet over we do we in fact we have two
games our defending Champion is still
playing
what happened it went into I know wow I
mean how many moves got played here in
our absence I mean it happened very
quickly Rooker for yeah it was King E5
by the way and Anna
she played G4 now we have this race we
went all this way who's playing for a
while I'm not sure
D4 yeah
Rook of three well I mean if she wanted
to make a draw she would have played
King G2 and H4 H4 so I guess Anna is the
one playing for a win you have to go B5
now yeah B5 H4 you take yes and G3
simply be six or something like that I
think I can even take you can take on G3
and play Basics yeah I think the king is
too far yeah and also we still have H
Pawn but Rook F3 on the other hand is
like a one move type of thing
okay so perhaps is it that easy okay
wait wait wait be fast okay so
she played Rook A5 what okay look
whoa whoa whoa I'm sorry I'm just going
to refresh my board apologies to my
audience our audience here Rook A5 well
that probably works as well right yes
but
but why to no that makes a lot of sense
actually yeah so and that simplifies the
position I think any trades is helpful
and you put the pawn goes up one so I
guess I have to play Rook F3 and takes
and now the position is going to get
simplified I will of course
end up giving my rook and
why will I end up giving her a rook so
Rook A5 maybe that was actually the best
move
the opposition yes because this move G4
did
intimate H4 and GG and things could have
changed
yes
no no no Jennifer who would be dreaming
about it in this case
yeah
and in case this game is a draw when do
the playoffs start they speak uh the
playoff begins at 1 20 tomorrow 120 is
uh central time Central Time yes so
Central West End
by the way just to let you know that
Wesley got this position Knight and Rook
against Rook I recognize yeah so yes yes
Sam is
holding on holding on
he was two pawns down I thought Wesley
was going to win that game ages ago but
Sam tough man tough man to beat Rook A5
um
this move really surprised Anna because
she's actually in a tank
and thinking things over
any chances in this one Christian for
either player no no it's going to be a
problem so we'll have playoffs I think
we take on A5 oral Cafe okay Rook Cafe
is an admission basically that is time
to call it uh call it a day right Rook
f8 6h5 you take on G3 I go and she's
done that she's taken on H5
taking on G3 and I think right now we're
probably going to speed towards uh naked
Kings naked Kings C5 King B6
push
he said well you might as well go back
go behind it don't I'm trying not that
either I'm trying to set up of course I
can play Rook H2 I'm trying to set up a
position
[Laughter]
sometimes have you ever been really
really really clever
too clever yeah it's cost you like you
wanted to win in a beautiful way really
it's better not to remember oh really
it's that bad
to Forget You you try to be artistic and
you let the wind Escape
yesterday's game of Jennifer in the way
like
like you think that now you are winning
but at the end of the day you miss
something simple and right that's it
but it's quite often
Walter brand our six-time U.S Champion
Walter Brown told me this fantastic
story that he played against Bobby
Fischer
and uh he he about he Walter saw a win
and then he saw a second win like
there's two and one win was prettier
than the other he went for the pretty
win so he just made the move that was
the pretty win and then he saw Bobby's
face light up like ah
[Laughter]
oh I can go Rook F4 and Rook G4
okay now we're talking B6 is on the oh
she didn't go she's not too smart for
her yeah that's that's good why would
Rook F4 check have done
Rooker 4 and then Rook G4 because yeah
and I'm actually the first one
and in the end it's your queen as well
but I go Queen Jade and I pick up yours
but by the way I put the King on the
wrong Square after The Rook yes I should
have played the King on D5 no no keep it
on C5
is smart just take the pawn on G2
exactly just just take it yes oh just
take my gosh that was so painful no
oh by the way guys King C5 Rook F5 yes
Rooker five will takes King G4
G1 and then G1 check yes so King 85 yes
if you hit gun King C you can see five
you could lose yeah wow this is nice
okay so she has played King D5 but just
just just
on the edge check
check and now that was your last chance
yes very nice very very nice how to
trick yourself that she has played King
D5 and that was so much confidence they
have here I will just take this on
YouTube because I know that I can
literally lose any position so it's
better just to make sure it's zero right
the pawn
G2 oh this is funny lots of confidence
of course yes you I mean you need to
have this King C6 keeping that part on
the board
okay let's go okay Rook F6 and the roof
takes B6 no no that's Queen a queen okay
I want to have the extra Rook for a
couple of moves exactly
you know it was actually very funny I
was talking to Gary uh Kasparov in his
match with deep blue in in such a
position Deep Blue
would promote his Pawn to a rook really
and not a queen so I thought that was
really funny that you didn't promote the
pawn to a queen but to a rook and I
asked Gary why does deep blue do that
and he says well he doesn't want to lose
on the trade
because it's algorithm tells it you know
like yes so you promote it to a rook no
she promoted Queen actually it would be
funny if we promote it into a rook yeah
all night yeah
that was too funny to promote it to a
rook
here we go
uh guys I think we have a playoff we do
have a thing we're going to be here at 1
20 did you say tomorrow yes and just to
review our playoff rules in in case of
two players tied four and four four
they're gonna play Rapids they will play
rapid it's 10 minutes for the whole game
uh that with two seconds increment from
move one and in case if it's uh we won
one after two games yeah uh one one
score we have Armageddon nice
we fight against four right
an increment after move six testing this
will be the case but somehow I I like
the finish I think it will be a very
good finish to have a playoff between
these two outstanding competitors
exactly we see Jennifer you and Irina
crush on the screens and the score is
different right now because Jennifer won
two games but Irina won one game here in
this event right round 12 yeah that is
the updated result in their head to head
and once again just to review uh
Anastasia yes 50 players and this is
what we have two players tied for the
first place two rapid games will will be
played tomorrow uh 10 minutes plus two
seconds increment and if it's still
tight we have our Market on game five
minutes provide four for black black
wins if the game ends in the draw
outstanding
and Christian we have one of those
competitors in studio we do have a
Jennifer you with us Jennifer an amazing
Victory congratulations you must be
buzzing with excitement for tomorrow's
playoffs
yeah I guess now I just have to mentally
adjust to play another match tomorrow I
was just I don't know after yesterday I
just thought it was over
I just thought I was done like I was
like this is just awful
um but I'm really happy I have another
chance to go for the title again because
I mean after a way I played yesterday I
was like I just honestly don't deserve
another chance what did you do yesterday
after uh that loss to come back
um
I don't know I usually uh like recover
after losses pretty quickly like I just
get over it really fast but you know
when you lose like that like I played a
move that I don't think I would have
played like when I was like eight years
old I don't know I was like literally
hallucinating I did not know what I was
doing and then after I played it I was
like damn like I thought because I
thought I lost like the title with that
move I was like because otherwise I was
like oh I'm doing fine here
um and I knew that and I was just like I
I don't know what was going on so
um after that I was just like you know I
honestly don't deserve a chance like the
way I've been playing it was just awful
but you see still still came back with
the black pieces against the surging
player five wins in a row for Talia very
difficult opponent how did you approach
this one
um I charge it so basically I pretend
this game like I had no chances off I
was like I don't really care like I'm
just gonna play like normal
um I didn't look at irena's game an
entire round I only saw it like after I
finished
um I was just like just pretend like
it's over
um and just play normally because
otherwise there's just too much to think
about because usually I do fine Under
Pressure it's just like after yesterday
like it's actually because I keep
thinking back on I'm like why would you
play that move like it's just so bad
um so that's kind of my mentality I
should kind of do like some mental
gymnastics there I feel like Reno was
doing something very similar because I
didn't see her looking at your game
either she was very focused on her game
as well you were very focused on your
game as well and you guys were very
close to each other you didn't pick at
all no I like I try like I I think I was
looking at like the screen that had like
all the games on it I like accidentally
picked her game once I was like no
that's too much I was like no I have to
I can't look at that game because it's
not even like the pressure it just makes
me feel
so mad at myself for the way I played
yesterday because I just felt like I
threw it away completely when did you
feel like you were actually getting
realistic chances in this one
um so from the opening I
um I definitely surprised her here
because like I've never played this
before and definitely was not that good
but here at Queen before I just started
feeling pretty good about my position
because
um like this end game is just very
comfortable for me to play I can just I
feel like I basically can't really lose
it if I just like keep um the pressure
don't let her play like F3 or F4 at some
point
um because what happened in the game was
like she just got very passive and then
um like she didn't really have any moves
at some point and you found this nice
idea against this 93 night day four with
which Basics to put pressure on E2 first
and then defend with route to p8 yeah uh
very nice and at this point I think it
was this moment
sometime after you played this move d4
did you see this move Rooks to C3 yeah I
thought Rook C3
um I looked at Rook C3 more after edcd
Rook T3 but that that's just D3 um I
thought I assumed after next year here
right now this just doesn't work yeah
um I assume that
I could play D3 here too but I think
oh right
that's tricky
yeah it was a tricky move and I think
you have to go something like Rook F7 or
look at Faith but it becomes a bit
trickier than yeah maybe it should have
been no I like
um near the end of time with row I think
I misplayed it a bit because like this
is fine but it's I think there's easier
ways to win and
um I think in a few more moves so after
Rook A4
um
yeah right here that you found uh yeah
so I like At first I wanted to play
um so I saw this a few moves in advance
and I thought I was just gonna play uh
E3 and then I was like oh there's Brooke
takes E3 because this is just like
really different
um no E3 like I saw this like moves ago
in advance I was like E3 just doesn't
work what I got like because Brook D3
into draw yes and I was like that's bad
and then I was thinking
um Rook takes G3 Rook F and then E3 but
then Rook teeth and then you're like oh
the Panzer pushy but then rook d3923 and
perfectly Keen F3 and I think this isn't
as easy as it looks because it's so
tricky with uh you have to be so careful
not to lose age up this guy and not lose
the H5 Pawn Yeah because that's the
problem I think I could pick up the G
and H1s pretty easily
but do you have this move by any chance
probably not Rook A1 yeah
um and then so I was just like you know
I spent a lot of time and I was like
Knight G6 seems pretty simple to play
yep um yeah and that was actually
winning and after that you went on uh to
convert
Jennifer congratulations big one how are
you going to prepare for tomorrow's
playoff
um well
prepare against her again but you know
start like forget kind of about the
tournament like Bishop A4 and then just
kind of start clean
um I haven't the last time I played the
playoff was actually at us Junior so I
have a little bit of experience but I
didn't really have time to prepare for
that one because it was the same day so
um I hopefully I can do more this time
and you know I'm just really excited to
have another opportunity because I mean
it's just a really interesting
tournament now I guess you know it's
more exciting when I should go get your
rest and we'll see you tomorrow
our congratulations Jennifer good luck
in tomorrow's playoff we're going to be
here to call all the action yeah I mean
and here it is uh once again the ladies
a championship
so uh Jennifer you will play against
Arena crash tomorrow at 1 20 p.m please
come back don't think that it's over
absolutely absolutely
and now that was a question that I had
does the money chain change like like if
one player gets you know the title yes
right do they get a little bit extra
extra no no no no actually you see that
there it is 35 for each 35 for each and
then we have also Valley who is on the
third place yes I did Southern and then
with 15 and then 30 actually who won
today look at this she's on the fifth
place maybe she even I know there are
two spots in you know it's actually
Alice Lee also gets eight so like it's a
tie for the kids place and then we have
um
placed nine together with Rochelle vu
and and so on I'm surprised with Nazi by
kids in this event because like I
thought that maybe she will try to fight
for the first place okay sometimes it
happens a little rusty for her she
hasn't played too much
and in the open section we still have a
game remaining our defending Champion uh
Wesley so trying in a um Rook at night
to get to that seven and a half of a
wonder and linear that would be a nice
Heyday for him by the way sad to say
that Alice Lee did lose that final game
today in the last round against Megan
Lee that was the one where she was under
a lot of pressure out of the opening in
that Dutch stone wall now this ending
that they do have that the players have
on their board I mean this has been a
very well-known draw and it's actually
kind of funny because there was a book
by Dr John Lennon yes he gave me his
book it was called pondless end games or
rather end games that have no pawns I
got it yes
John gave me this book and he said yes
sir this book is absolutely absolutely
unique and I said well how's that John
he says well it's the only book only
chess book in the world may be the first
and only book in the world that all of
the analysis is absolutely correct
like it's table Basin yes because it's
absolutely perfectly correct and I go
really and I opened up the book and the
first thing at this is it shows this
ending yes it's like from an A 9th
century Arab manuscript and and the
Islamic scholars had gotten the end game
accurate yeah what was the most famous
game in descending it was actually Gary
because
Judith Polgar yes Gary somehow won with
the Knight and Judith just got so angry
yes oh she was angry and even though
it's a well-known draw I've even seen
Magnus Carlson win this against Irwin
mummy so there are some tricks I want
this one as well actually you do yeah
whoa so we have an expert here you're
right against
who is a pretty decent grandmother from
Iran like 2650 or something absolutely
I don't remember how I did it it's
almost impossible to win this seven game
was it an open or where was it where did
you play no no no no no it was um a pro
chess League match ah okay okay well in
that case it was like a rapid it was a
rapid game yes yeah here you get 30
seconds uh increment which is important
let's say and and Sam doesn't even seem
to need that because he's been blitzing
his moves well up to this point up to
this moment yeah
interesting that still but what he's
doing is very correct he's just like
keeping the Rook as far away from the
King as possible
uh especially against the bishop it's
called the Cochrane defense
where you keep the Rook as far as
possible and then you give checks
now against the Knight I think it works
as well for example if you try to take
the opposition with King B6 let's say I
don't know k6 King C6 King B8 King B6
which is not a great thing to do for uh
for black but let's just put those moves
on the board which moves sorry King C6
King B8 and King B6 King C6 King B8 King
so six King B8 and King B6 oh sorry just
a second I'm I'm doing something oh
right because it's yeah it's actually
white to move here
so you like to play King C6 here no no
no there's a knight on D5 okay so King
C8 King C6
I don't have King C8 is that King A6 or
like yeah
okay let me just get there I'm just
gonna get there so when we get this
position you're saying I should be able
to play check no no no no no I just
thought King C8 is that King A6 is
actually King C8
I don't know why
first we're gonna teach you how the
castle probably now
it was very similar to The King's
decapitation moment right
so King C6 now King C6 now and now I go
uh Rook H6 and I'll just give you checks
from far you or I can go Rook a
what what is this Dixie one check we'll
see one check there we go that's the
simplest
and uh for Wesley so who's had
a poor event uh this a win in this round
would really take a lot of the edge off
he would score seven and a half out of a
possible 13 that's plus two which you
know by his standards is still not that
great but
it's salvageable oh yeah of course and
also don't let's not forget rating
points are also very important and for
Wesley Wesley is one of those players of
very aware of the rating he knows that
he's a tough organizers like to have the
high rated players participate in their
event and get very good Financial
conditions so he is one of those players
who who does pay a lot of attention to
the ratings
yeah but this position probably is not
so Wesley is like he doesn't look uh
look thrilled about his prospects
than this one yes
okay
um tell our viewers how black could go
wrong what what are the what are the
pitfalls that you you you should be
trying to avoid in the position by the
way just one second I wanted to see when
the last piece has been captured so to
understand
50 moves rule yes exactly yes move 71 so
uh you need to get to move 121.
by the way the 131 games yes move game
between Christopher and Lanier that was
special we're trying to beat it uh sorry
again uh Christian if you don't mind
just show a couple of the traps there
obviously you know Gary Kasparov did win
it the players have won it uh what is
black trying to avoid
so let's try to figure that out
um because it's not that easy to lose
this one
give it to me and they'll do it right
it's quite difficult so
Rook 2 okay I like that move for example
yes
let's go King d8
let's go A5 yes I don't know why I'm
looking at the board reverse I think
it's okay so everybody
first for whatever reason I'm 100 sure
why because you see it on the video and
you kind of think about it from the
other side ah yes maybe maybe maybe
maybe so you want to go King A7 or King
A5 where are you thinking
how do you want to lose the game I'm not
sure if I can lose it but still let's
try we have faith okay King C5 and then
you play any movement
okay this is where this is how we start
to get and Knight C3 that's the problem
but then you run with the King and it's
still nothing happens
yeah you just keep running with the King
no no no no no no no no no no and now
actually
oh there's a mate there we go there we
go nicely fun
man it's tough it's tough wow try to
lose a Cooperative cooperation yes it's
not easy it's not easy to lose this uh
position but we do Let me refresh my
board apologies for that and quickly
check okay you can also lose it for
white if you play now a king C5 and who
goes on B5 but King C5 and don't go okay
that one that one's easy so okay so we
have some trickies now with Knight C7 no
no still not uh still not uh winning
well even after King A7 for example if
you do try to go Knight C7
but let's show this yes please so if you
go King A7 and you try to go Knight C7 I
can go Rook C6 ah
I'm in stalemate that is a good eat nice
I mean if you're going to show a
Checkmate for one player you might as
well show the stalemate for the other
very nice
okay we do have a rook
H5 yes
so um I guess
maybe Rook B6 followed by root to D6 if
you go to A7 and try to transfer on the
other side Rook to B6 but it doesn't
really make a lot of sense because you
already cut the King on the last on the
background yeah you you've actually
achieved your maximum that you can do is
push the the king to the side of the
board whether it be on the first okay
another Pitfall maybe maybe let's go
Rook B1
okay and now let's say you try to keep
the connection with the Knight but you
go no you go Rook F5
okay boom now I go King C6 and there's
no check there's no more check
and now I'm still not that's a Checkmate
right that's the Checkmate yes because
so you have to go back you can still go
back and even this I'm not sure if you
can win
oh but now I give you a check on um yes
but you go back please
that's nice yes
we'll be trying to lose it and we
finally managed well we've lost it a
couple of times but we've also shown
that it requires almost a Cooperative
opponent and the move Rook F5 I think is
also rather Cooperative I'll let it go
King A7 in the oh sorry this is not the
current position I apologize I update my
board
now oh he he he he basically
uh allowed the king to uh B7 yes
hmm
have you had this
this position
no I don't remember that I found another
way to lose this one well done so let's
go hook F3 instead of rookie three Rook
F3 instead of yes King B7 I'm happy I'm
escaping okay Rook F7 and this is a bit
more realistic okay you go King CA okay
okay I go King C6 okay
now you go check I put the knight in
front
yeah and threatening me and that's why
Rook of seven and now you probably have
to go King B8 but now I go King B6 okay
and there's no more King C8 because it's
so now once I get the Rook on Eighth
rank I feel I'm close
[Laughter]
oh I think I am wait wait so I give you
a check with the night or with the group
B7 yes this is the win this is how I
beat durability yes King C8 and our Rook
A7 and there's no way
yes yes this is uh this is how I won my
game I remember now oh wow very
impressive truly
so maybe but Rook F7 was the key we
really tried
desperately trying to uh we made a
concerted effort right to win this one
um yeah you have to cover you have to
find oh there's another cover like
there's another nice win at this moment
like let's say let's say white makes a
move and black makes a bad move then you
have this type of uh
a checkmate
very nice yeah yeah so you've got to
keep that pick okay so now I guess you
have to go look at to Roku G5 right and
he's actually played Rook F7 there is
that Rook move right the mysterious
seven now okay we're expecting Rook to
Chief five from G5 yes that makes the
most sense this is the one where touch
move on your king would make you cry yes
six maybe I know
Rook E5 okay
A little reluctant to become close to
the I think this is still alive it's
still okay but yeah
you're always a little bit worried that
uh by releasing the night with the tempo
that uh you you could you could be in
trouble eight more moves to the time
control
I would be very very reluctant to ever
step into an opposition and I would play
King B7 yes
maybe something was can G6
right because of the tempo you mean you
have King B7 Rook B6 maybe six first to
make sure that the king will go
somewhere
but then we have this Rook D5 ideas
sometimes yeah
and for example if I play King A7 yes I
cannot play King C6 I think because Rook
D5 exactly that's
okay
I'm capturing something yes definitely
you're right
so Rook check this is our current
position
so what if I go uh King to A5
yeah that was just exactly let's try to
move that I would be so uh
okay I work with six check let's see I
think Wesley has given up as far but he
just has to play it to the 50 move right
he made it for 45. if you if you've made
it for 45 you have to finish he might as
well finish Jeff
yeah King A7 the sad part is that right
now even if he gets somehow to a winning
position he won't be able to convert it
yes because you don't have
to do it I remember in the Women's
Championship I believe it was between
Anna zatonski and Naji it was rook and
Bishop versus rook and literally like
she wins The Rook with one move to spare
wow yeah it was a draw all the way
through 40 moves but then suddenly it
became a win yes and she just had enough
moves in the 50 move rule to uh to make
a victory so thanks God we don't have a
closing ceremony today because imagine
now the whole event will would be
waiting right we're actually to finish
his game but yeah I mean the closest
ceremony will happen tomorrow exactly
yes and don't forget you have still
chance to join it if you're in St Louis
right now somewhere nearby by the way I
I I really like this American
tradition of having the closing ceremony
literally the next day as opposed to the
same day because it means that we can
have a playoff leisurely and in Europe
they often have the closing ceremony on
the the final round yes and what does it
mean they play the final round like four
hours earlier yes sometimes yeah so
instead of starting at one o'clock in
the afternoon which is traditional you
start at 10 in the morning or something
so that you have time for the closing
ceremony yes and then you have to run
with your bags exactly yeah
that's terrible but in U.S events
sometimes it also can be challenging two
rounds per day oh yes hello in the open
tournament yes
have you ever played like nine routes in
five days I was I I was raped like this
yes okay wow yeah trust me those were
not
Friendly Moments happy moments into B5
Rook H5 how many moves right now is only
four moves to go
oh
four moves to go
and Sam's doing a great job by the way
of keeping his Rook pinning that night
making it incredibly
difficult to impossible we're a Wesley
to win yep
yes Wesley kind of gave up this idea he
played so quickly and Rook if I was to
check you know what's going on right
where did Sam did that against
I want to say Hans he made this very
very quick move H three
[Music]
forty and thirty for the answers yes so
it's not a thirty five thirty five cents
ten thousand difference between two
players
so we can check it now on our screen so
you gave me misinformation yeah okay
where is my
mother is
layoff it means that if I win a crush
for example wins tomorrow she will get
40 something and Jennifer will get 30
and it will go other other way around
exactly and they can all the ball rolls
wow well that would be a very exciting
uh tie break with ten thousand dollars
on the difference yes right still it's I
think it's nice actually that it's not
only the title but also the difference
in money here we go and we're going to
see a Shaco fans very soon because right
now I think finally
will be looking at his score sheet yes
shaking her hands right I'm sure he
knows when the 15 more rule happens
right
yeah he's checking what we must have
noted somewhere yes what will your coach
what will your coach tell you normally
just no beheadings on the king
beheadings here uh on this one and I
think they've you know it's funny
because my screen went and said draw it
is between Wesley so because the players
haven't claimed it but there we have it
the software the safety move rule said
excuse me guys you don't have to play
anymore this is a draw yes so normally
if you have the situation like you put
the small we point on this course there
we have it when you have this 50
confirmed by our Arbiter Frank Guadalupe
123 moves not the 131 move Marathon
Christian that yes
Christopher cracking a smile right now
yes I think there's so much relief from
the players too like it's just over the
like linear we heard from Lanier like
he's just thinking of rest rest
and uh
is just happy uh that this event is over
bring it up uh the final thoughts of
this uh 13th Championship round
Christian I mean wonder what an amazing
round we had in both sections in the
open section sure Fabiano finished fast
uh but Ray what was putting a lot of
pressure on his opponent Jeffrey Sean
and could have easily taken the full
point and uh forced the playoff in the
ladies section I mean just the fighting
Spirit of this young woman Grand Master
Jennifer Yu she's been playing
incredible chess all throughout the year
she's won the Juniors Championship with
the dominant score and right now she's
proving to everybody why she deserves to
be here and why she deserves to
potentially win the US Women's chess
championships but there's one eight time
National Champion Irina Crush who will
say tomorrow no no no I'm here to stay
and I'm here to win my ninth
Championship what will happen only time
will tell but we will be here to call
all the action thank you for that and
Anastasia final standings of the ladies
so two players will play the playoff
Arena crash on Jennifer you they share
the first place right now Tyler
Cervantes lost her game but finished on
the third place really great result in
this event truly Ryan young
um on the fourth place uh that's if by
winning this game jumped on the fifth
position together with Ellis Lee Megan
Lee and Megan Lee and let me just call
out both Alice and Megan for two
outstanding uh tournament competitors
really really really great and it was
wonderful to see Megan win her final
game as she had been leading earlier
really great result and beg him is on
the eighth place and we have a tie for
the ninth place and as a dance
and that's where the 500 Goes By the Way
That 160 500 and in the open section uh
tell us uh who were the big prize money
winners there Fabiano caruana 60
thousand he won the first place and
second time he won the U.S Championship
oh congratulations congratulations
Fabian Ray Robson is on the clear second
place after making draw in the final
round right dramatic final round
Domingos and the Wonderland shared the
third place congratulations to those two
players of age take home 30 000 and then
and tied with 13 750 we have Wesley so
refresh Sam shankland uh same Savion and
Hans Neiman our congratulations and
again tomorrow
120 uh St Louis time uh we were going to
have a tie break exactly between
Jennifer you and Arena Crush you can see
their previous results on the screen and
please join us for this moment
absolutely really interesting they will
play for 10 let's say 10 000 difference
exactly
thank you all for joining us and sharing
your day with us we will see you all
tomorrow good night good night
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited